ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRIAN BURKE THE ROOM
CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHEN
CHIU CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY
LACKEY LEE LEVINE. LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORK CORK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO C. R. TO SMITH STONE
TEEN RELATIVE ERRORS THE
APPROVED VIA VOEPEL WALDRON
WARD WEBER. WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT
TO THE FLOOR SO WE MAY GET THE
BUSINESS OF THE HOUSE MOVING.
MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR SO WE MAY BEGIN. TAKING
UP ITEMS IN EARNEST.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. DAVE PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN
HIMALAYAS ARE. IN THE NAME OF
GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. ALMIGHTY GOD WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT YOUR MERCY IS
GREAT AND IT COVERS A MULTITUDE
OF OUR SHORTCOMINGS. YOUR
STEADFAST LOVE IS FOR EACH ONE.
AND IS UNCONDITIONALLY
AVAILABLE TO ALL. THEREFORE-
GOD WE SEEK YOUR GUIDANCE IN
OUR WORK AND OUR WORDS WE NEED
YOUR WISDOM FOR OUR DEBATES AND
OUR DISCUSSIONS. AND WE HUMBLY
PRAY FOR PEACE IN OUR TIME FOR
PEACE IN OUR COMMUNITY AND FOR
PEACE IN OUR WORLD I MEAN. WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
GARCIA. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SALUTE TO OUR FLIGHT READY
BEGIN. BASICALLY WE ARE. IT IS
A LITTLE YEAH S. R. THANK YOU
MAY BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
GERMAN SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JUNE
TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE ASSEMBLY REDDIT NINETY AM
THE AUDIBLE REBEKAH POWER QUE
HANNAH SUSPECTED WRITTEN FOR
THE ASSEMBLY PRESIDING CHIEF
BURKE CHIU PART OF THE
DESPERATE FOR DAVID BOWMAN
READING ROLL CALL RULES CALLED
MACRO THIS RARE MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS. THE READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
HABITATIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S
ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
MISS RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MAIENSCHEIN
GALLAGHER AND RUBIO TO SPEAK ON
AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE FLOOR MANAGERS
PLEASE MOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS
TO THE INACTIVE FILE ITEM SIXTY
TWO SB THREE FIFTY FIVE BECKER
BY KALRA. I ITEM EIGHTY SIX SB
SEVEN FORTY NINE BLASIER BUYOUT
ARAMBULA. AND ITEM ONE TWENTY
TWO SB. FIVE FIVE NINE WITH
OTHER BY GRAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I MOVE TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN THE
ONE DAY WAITING PERIOD FOR
CONCURRENCE ITEMS TO ALLOW
AUTHORS TO TAKE UP THEIR
ASSEMBLY BILLS TODAY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS THEIR ITEMS
FOURTEEN THROUGH THIRTY NINE
INCLUSIVE. MISTER FLOOR FOURTH
PURPOSE SIR WE WITHHOLDING
HOUSE CONSENT ASTRONOMICAL
MISTER FLORA IS WITHHOLDING. MS
REYES MOVES. M. AS PARA QUE HAN
SECONDS. ON THE ROSI'S PENSION
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTES CARPOOL OF THE ROLE.
REYES IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND MR FLORA IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. MS REYES IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTES MISTER. FLORA IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. MEMBERS
THIS IS A PRE VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL EYES FORTY TWO DOES
FOURTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
FIVE THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTY FIVE SENATE BILL. SEVEN
FOUR TWO. AND A COVERING.
SEETHER OF THE CORRECT
IMMEDIATELY THIS PARA QUE HAN
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT SB
SEVEN FORTY TWO A BILL THAT
BALANCES THE RIGHT TO ACCESS
HEALTHCARE PRIVACY AND
CONSTITUTIONAL FREEDOM OF
SPEECH. AS A BODY WE HAVE SPENT
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF
WORKING SIDE BY SIDE TO FOLLOW
THE SCIENCE AND THE DATA TO
SAVE AS MANY LIVES AS WE CAN
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. OFTEN AT
THE COST TO OTHER PARTS OF OUR
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
SEEN A FOUR AND A HALF. MILLION
CASES A CO IN NINETEEN AND
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND PLUS PEOPLE
HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES TO THIS
PANDEMIC. WE'VE EXPERIENCED THE
PAIN OF TRYING TO GRIEVE FOR
LOVED ONES FROM AFAR. SOME
HAVING TO SAY GOODBYE OVER
FACETIME. WE HAVE THE STREAM
THE STRAIN ON FAMILIES WORKING
FROM HOME OR LOSING THEIR JOBS
AND THE ECONOMY SUFFERED. MANY
OF US HAVE EXPERIENCED NEEDING
TO SUPPORT OUR CHILDREN.
LEARNING ON A COMPUTER INSTEAD
OF IN THE CLASSROOM. THE
STRUGGLE OF SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS HAVE BEEN THE ONES WE
HAVE WORKED HARD TO ADDRESS
AMONGST THE OTHERS. MANY OF US
EVEN WORSHIP TO VIRTUALLY
SOMETHING WE NEVER IMAGINED IN
PRIOR YEARS. ALL OF THIS WAS TO
BUY TIME UNTIL SCIENCE COULD
CATCH UP. AND WE WOULD HAVE THE
BREAKTHROUGHS TO KEEP THE
COMMUNITY SAFE. BECAUSE OF
DECADES OF RESEARCH AND I'D BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T MENTION THE
SCIENCE A WOMAN. WE NOW HAVE
THE VACCINES THEY CAN KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE. AND WHILE OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ARE STATE
GOVERNMENT AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WORKED INCREDIBLY
HARD TO DISTRIBUTE THE VACCINES
AND EDUCATE OUR COMMUNITIES WE
KNOW THAT THEIR ANTI VACCINE
EXTREMISTS THAT ARE ESCALATING
THEIR TACTICS TO DISRUPT AND
STOPS THESE VACCINE EFFORTS.
THAT IS WHY TODAY I ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT SB SEVEN FORTY TWO WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BOTH
PRACTICE FREE SPEECH AND GET
THE HEALTHCARE THAT THEY
DESERVE. AND NEED PUBLIC
OFFICIALS NEED THE TOOLS TO
ENSURE THAT PATIENTS AND
FRONTLINE WORKERS AT OUR
VACCINE CLINICS ARE SAFE FROM
INTIMIDATION HARASSMENT AND
PHYSICAL OBSTRUCTION. MOST OF
YOU ARE AWARE THAT THE VACCINE
CLINIC AT DODGER STADIUM WAS
SHUT DOWN WHEN EXTREMISTS
BLOCKED PEOPLE FROM ENTERING.
THIS IS HAPPENING ALL OVER OUR
STATE AND OFTEN TO THOSE WHO
ARE MOST VULNERABLE TO THE
VIRUS. AN ADDITIONAL THING THAT
IS HAPPENING IS THAT THE
HEALTHCARE INFORMATION OUR MOST
PRIVATE INFORMATION THAT WE
HAVE LOST THE PROJECT IS BEING
OUTED BY PEOPLE WHO ARE
VIDEOTAPING AND PHOTOGRAPHING
PATIENTS TO OUT THEIR PRIVATE
HEALTH CARE INFORMATION. AS WE
CONTINUE TO NEED TO SPREAD THE
VACCINE AS OUR YOUNG CHILDREN
GET ACCESS TO IT WE WILL NEED
TO USE STADIUM SCHOOL CAMPUSES
A NONTRADITIONAL HEALTH CARE
SETTINGS TO DISTRIBUTE THE
VACCINE. AND WE NEED THESE
PROTECTIONS TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN DO SO. WE NEED TO PROTECT
OUR FRONT LINE WORKERS WHO WORK
TIRELESSLY. TO WRITE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE EVEN IN THE DARKEST
DAYS OF THIS PANDEMIC. THEY
SHOULD BE FEAR OF HARASSMENT
ASSAULT AND VIOLENCE. THAT IS
JUST IN THE GUISE OF PROTEST.
MANY MIGHT ARGUE OR SOME MIGHT
ARGUE THAT THIS BILL TAKES AWAY
FREE SPEECH BUT AS WE ALL KNOW.
THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
FREE SPEECH. IS NOT WITHOUT
LIMITS. TIME PLACE AND MANNER
RESTRICTIONS ARE ABSOLUTELY
ALLOWED. UNDER THE CONSTITUTION
AND THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE TODAY. THERE'S AN
URGENCY CLAUSE IN THIS BILL
MEMBERS SO THAT WE CAN GET THIS
WORK DONE NOW. AND PROTECT AS
MANY COMMUNITY MEMBERS AS
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU IS BETTER
K. THIS GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU MEMBERS
I'M GONNA BE BRIEFED BY
COLLEAGUES AND THE BAY AREA DID
A GOOD JOB OF SUMMARIZING THIS
BILL I SHOULD BE ABLE TO
PROTECT MY HEALTH AND DO WHAT'S
BEST FOR MY FAMILY IN A SAFE
AND RESPECTFUL MANNER OUT THERE
IN THE SAME WAY THAT YOU SHOULD
BE ABLE TO PROTEST AND WAS-
VOCALIZED A VOICE IN THIS BILL
SIMPLY ALLOWS US TO BE ABLE TO
DO BOTH- IN A WAY THAT WORKS
FOR ALL PARTIES OUT THERE. YES
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHORS
WERE WORKING ON THIS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YU MISTER C.
MISTER COOPER. YOUR RECORD LAST.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE TO
SUPPORT SB SEVEN FORTY TO A
BILL THAT BALANCES ARE RIGHT TO
ACCESS HEALTHCARE PRIVACY AND
FREEDOM OF SPEECH THIS BILL
SIMPLY GIVES LOCAL OFFICIALS
MORE TOOLS TO ENSURE PUBLIC
SAFETY. CITY FROM THE DEADLY
DISEASE OF COVERED MESSAGE FOR
PATIENTS THAT ARE SIMPLY TRYING
TO GET MEDICAL SERVICES IF YOUR
FORMER LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
TOO OFTEN WE ARRIVE ON SCENE
THE DAMAGE IS DONE. THE
SITUATION HAS ESCALATED BEYOND
THE POINT OF RETURN THIS BILL
SIMPLY DRAWS A CLEAR LINE TO
STOP PATIENT AND STAFF ARRESTED
PEOPLE VISITING A VACCINE
CLINICS WHILE STILL GIVING
PROTESTERS A CLEAR SPACE TO
PRACTICE THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS. MEMBERS WE'RE ALL
FIGHTING HARD IN THE PANDEMIC
AND I URGE EVERYONE SUPPORT
ACCESS TO LIFE SAVING VACCINES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
COOPER DR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT IF SENATE BILL SEVEN
FORTY TWO. NOW DISTURBINGLY WE
ARE SAYING THOSE WHO ARE TRYING
TO DO THE RIGHT THING AND
TRYING TO OBTAIN THE VACCINE
BEING INTIMIDATED HARASSED AND
EVEN ASSAULTED. BY SOME OF
THOSE SAME SKEPTICS WHO NOW
DECLARE MY BODY MY CHOICE. IN
MY OWN DISTRICT THERE ARE
PROTESTS OUTSIDE OF THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL WHERE I
WORK. WHERE PROTESTERS ARE
SIMPLY TRYING TO SCARE PATIENTS
OF CHILDREN SEEKING MEDICAL
CARE FOR COMPLEX HEALTH
CONDITIONS. MANY OF WHOM ARE
NOT EVEN ELIGIBLE TO GET THE
VACCINE AT THIS TIME. SB SEVEN
FORTY TO STRIKE THE BALANCE
BETWEEN THE RIGHT OF THOSE WHO
WISH TO SAFELY AND FREELY
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE
PERSONAL MEDICAL DECISION OF
SOMEONE THAT THEY'VE NEVER EVEN
MET. FIRST OF THE ABILITY OF
THAT PERSON TO ACTUALLY MAKE A
MEDICAL DECISION FOR THEMSELVES.
LAST WEEK THE HOUSE
OVERWHELMINGLY SAID ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH WHEN IT COMES TO TH
MISINFORMATION BEING A SPOUSE
ONLINE AND ACROSS OTHER SOCIAL
PLATFORMS WHEN WE DECLARED
PUBLIC HEALTH MISINFORMATION A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. TODAY WE
CAN START TO OVERCOME THAT
CRISIS BY ENSURING THE
REMAINING MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS THAT HAVE YET TO
RECEIVE THEIR VACCINE REGIMEN
CAN DO SORT DO SO WITHOUT FEAR
OF INTIMIDATION OR ASSAULT. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON SB SEVEN FORTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR WEBER.
THE SCENE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. MISTER KNU MICHAELS I
JUST LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FROM LA SAN DIEGO
AND SACRAMENTO FOR THEIR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
WITH THAT THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR ON
THE URGENCY.
WELL CLOSE ROLE
AND TELL YOU THAT I TWENTY FOUR
KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY.
HIGHS FIFTY FOUR KNOWS YOU'RE
ON THE MEASURE THAT BILL PASSES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO THE TOP OF THE-
CONCURRENCE FILE WE TAKING A
CONCURRENCE ITEMS. THIS IS
CONCURRENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE. ASCERTAIN. WE ARE GOING TO
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO. WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE A FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX. IN THE
CORPORATION SOME PEOPLE
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BARRICADE HAND
AND OTHERS AN APPLE INTO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THIS BACKHAND THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. NUMBER IS
LAST WEEK THE SUPREME COURT
DECIDED NOT TO UPHOLD. A
WOMAN'S. RIGHT TO PRIVACY AS
DICTATED IN ROE V. WADE AND NOW
IN THE STATE OF TEXAS WOMEN.
BASICALLY DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO
AN ABORTION ANY LONGER OR
ACCESS TO AN ABORTION. AND SO
TODAY I BRING BACK ON
CONCURRENCY BE THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX WHICH WILL HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ENSURE A MEANING
FULL ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH AND ABORTION IN
CALIFORNIA. AND AS WE SEE WHAT
IS HAPPENING ACROSS THIS NATION
IT IS INCUMBENT UPON US TO BE
THE BEACON FOR WOMEN WHO NO
LONGER HAVE ACCESS IN OTHER
STATES. AND SO WHAT THIS BILL
DOES WHICH ENSURES SAFE. ACCESS
TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. FOR
PATIENCE AND A REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH WORKERS T OUR CLINICS
IN CALIFORNIA FREE FROM
INTIMIDATION THREATS AND
VIOLENCE WILL BE THAT
ADDITIONAL PROTECTION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THE PATIENCE BOTH
HERE IN THOSE THAT MUST COME
WILL HAVE. BUT I MUST ADMIT.
THAT YOU KNOW I HAVE MANY
RELATIVES IN TEXAS AND MANY
YOUNG NIECES. WHO WHEN THEY
NEED ACCESS TO ABORTION WELL
THEY CAN COME VISIT ANTI
REBEKAH AND ALL ALWAYS PROTECT
THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE. BUT WE
CANNOT TO PROTECT THOSE WOMEN
WHO DON'T HAVE THAT PRIVILEGE
WHO WON'T BE ABLE TO MAKE IT TO
STATES WHERE THEY HAVE ACCESS
SO THIS IS A SMALL STEP IN WHAT
SHOULD BE THE FIGHT THAT EACH
AND EVERYONE OF US THAT
BELIEVES IN A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE. IN MAKING SURE THAT
WOMEN IN EVERY STATE IN THIS
NATION HAVE CONTROL OVER THEIR
OWN BODILY AUTONOMY. AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE
VOTING CURRENCIES AND
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MS BACK A
HAND. SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEVERAL OF
THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS WELL WOODS ADDED VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ALL THE TIME BUT I
FORTY NINE NO SEVENTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE HEARD IN.
MEMBERS PURSUANT. TO ASSEMBLY
ROSE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT. TWO I
REFERRING TO THE FOLLOWING
BILLS THE COMMITTEE. I AM
TWENTY TWO S. B. FIVE TWENTY
SEVEN AVOID. TO THE PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE.
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE COOPER TO
THE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE. I'M THIRTY EIGHT AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS TO THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. AND
ITEM SIXTY FOUR S. B. THREE
EIGHTY ONE PORTANTINO TO THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY.
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. WE ARE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR. WE ARE
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE. AB.
THREE NINETY. BY MISTER BERMAN
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
NINETY BY SOME MEMBER BERMAN
AND OTHERS BACK WITH THE
BUSINESS REGULATION MR BERMAN
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AB THREE
NINETY IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
THE BILL WILL ENSURE CONSUMERS
ARE BETTER INFORMED ABOUT WHEN
AND HOW MUCH THEIR CHARGE FOR
SUBSCRIPTIONS AND MAKE IT
EASIER FOR CONSUMERS TO CANCEL
THEIR SUBSCRIPTIONS ONLINE
WITHOUT HAVING TO JUMP THROUGH
HOOPS. AB THREE NINETY WAS
AMENDED IN THE SENATE TO GIVE
BUSINESSES MORE TIME TO REMIND
CONSUMERS THAT THE ANNUAL
SUBSCRIPTIONS ARE ABOUT TO
RENEW AND CLARIFY THAT IF
CONSUMERS UNWILLING OR UNABLE
TO AUTHENTICATE THEMSELVES
ONLINE PRIOR TO CANCELING A
SUBSCRIPTION ONLINE THEY MAY DO
SO OFFLINE THESE AMENDMENTS
REMOVED NEARLY ALL OF THE
OPPOSITION IN THE BILL RECEIVE
NO NO VOTES IN THE SENATE
RESPECT THEY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK WITH BERMAN. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE CORPORAL OF
THE ROLE. WHO IS OUT OF IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSER ALL TIED UP
IS SIXTY FIVE. NO SIX ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX A.
B. NINE SEVENTEEN CORKERY. SOME
PEOPLE NINE SEVENTEEN BIASED
MEMBER BLOOM AND OTHERS BACK
LEADING TO VEHICLES THIS
DIPLOMA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES AB NINE
SEVENTEEN IS HERE ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE SENATE INCLUDE ESTABLISHING
A FIVE YEAR SUNSET REQUIRING A
REPORT ON THE PROGRAM'S
EFFECTIVENESS DUE TO THE
LEGISLATURE BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. EXTENDING THE WARNING
CITATION PERIOD FROM THIRTY
DAYS TO SIXTY DAYS AND
REQUIRING TRANSIT OPERATORS TO
PROVIDE OPTIONS TO WAIVE OR
REDUCE CITATIONS THE MEASURE
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN BOTH THE SAM SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU AS
WELL C. NOTIFICATION DEBATE
CORPORAL. IS OUT OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS REPRESENTATIVE OF.
FEDERAL. CLARK WELL. YOUR
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP IS
FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE SENATE
AMENDMENTS WORKING CURTAIN.
THERE IS WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN THE PRINCESS TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB ELEVEN TWENTY
SIX CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AND OTHERS
BACK WITHIN CITY GOVERNMENT.
THIS ALONE. THANK YOU AGAIN
MISTER SPEAKER AB ELEVEN TWENTY
SIX ESTABLISHES A PERMANENT
COMMISSION ON THE STATE OF HATE
AND IS HERE FOR CONCURRENCE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS WERE MADE
BASED ON FEEDBACK FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AND REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF MEMBERS ON THE
COMMISSION FROM ELEVEN TO NINE
CLARIFY THE FUNDING FOR THE
COMMISSION IS SUBJECT TO AN
APPROPRIATION. PERMIT THE
COMMISSION TO SEEK FUNDING FROM
SOURCES OUTSIDE OF THE GENERAL
FUND AND MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL
IN CLARIFYING CHANGES. THE BILL
Z. BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES AND HAS HAD NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR PRIVATE. THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM SAY NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. CORPORATE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. FIFTY FIVE NEAR ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS WORKING HEARD
IN. PASSERINE CHAIN ON FILE
ITEM NINE THIS IS FILE ITEM TEN
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY OPERATE A
SYMBOL FIFTEEN SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY ACCORDING
TO DISTANCE LEARNING. YOUR
DAILY YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS
BILL WILL LEAD TO GREATER
BROADBAND ACCESS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. BY
HELPING MORE STUDENTS GET
ACCESS TO FREE OR LOW COST
INTERNET SERVICES THE
AMENDMENTS FROM THE SENATE WERE
CLARIFYING IN NATURE. THERE HAS
BEEN UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER DALY
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
REPRESENTATIVE OF. ALL MEMBERS
REPRESENTATIVE OF CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLL TIE THAT I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS N.
FILE ORDER FILE ITEMS ELEVEN
AND TWELVE PASS AND RETAIN THIS
IS FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB NINE
FIFTY EIGHT CORKERY. SUMIKO
NINE FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON AND ACTIVATING
THE PEACE OFFICERS MISTER
GIBSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FIVE DAYS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS AIMS TO. MORE
EFFECTIVELY PROHIBIT MEMBERSHIP
PROVIDES- EXTERNAL BEST
OCCASION TO ADDRESS RACISM OF
THESE GANGS AB NINE FIFTY EIGHT
HAS ENJOYED A UNANIMOUS AND
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE ON
NINE FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
MISS GIPSON SAY NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY
SEVEN OH ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE INCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE ARE
NOW GOING TO BE MOVING TO TAKE
UP SENATE BILLS ON SENATE THIRD
READING. THESE ARE SENATE BILLS
ARE SENATE THIRD READING. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR UNDERSTANDING FOR
CELLS. WE'RE GOING TO SET THIRD.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEMS FORTY TWO AND
FORTY THREE. WE'RE GOING TO
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER. FORTY FOUR. WE ARE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM. FORTY FIVE. WE ARE
ALSO PASSING TEMPORARILY. ON
FILE ITEM FORTY SIX. EVERYONE
OF PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM. FORTY SEVEN. WE'RE GOING
TO PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE
ITEM FORTY EIGHT AND. FORTY
NINE. IT TAKES US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY. FILE ITEM FIFTY
S. SENATE BILL SEVEN TWELVE.
BERMAN. FILE ITEM SEVEN TWELVE
CORPORATION SENATE BILL SEVEN
TWELVE BY CENTER HUESO AND
OTHERS MACALINTAL LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. MS WALDRON YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. SB SEVEN TWELVE WILL
RECTIFY YEARS OF LONG STANDING
PRACTICES BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT HAVE DEPRIVE NATIVE
AMERICANS FROM A FAIR PROCESS
IN THEIR ATTEMPTS TO ACQUIRE
ANCESTRAL LANDS. NATIVE
AMERICANS HAVE SUFFERED FROM
DECADES OF MISTREATMENT
EXPLOITATION AND DISPOSSESSION
OF IT AND SOCIAL LANDS. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TODAY ALLOWS
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES TO
TAKE BACK THOSE LOST ANCESTRAL
LANDS TO A FEAT TO TRUST
ACQUISITION PROCESS. THIS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE TRIBES
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE SIGNIFICANT
YET IGNORED. TRIBE SUPPORT
LOCAL FIRE DEPARTMENTS INVEST
IN INFRASTRUCTURE ENHANCE
HOUSING ENVIRONMENTAL KRUGMAN'S
AMONG MANY OTHER THINGS. WE
MUST TAKE THESE BENEFITS INTO
CONSIDERATION. WHEN MAKING A
DECISION ON WHETHER TO SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE THE FEE TO TRUST
ACQUISITION BY REQUIRING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO EVALUATE THE FEE
TO TRUST APPLICATION ON ITS
MERITS. AND ALSO KNOWLEDGE IN
THE TRIBAL CONOMIC BENEFITS SB
SEVEN TWELVE WILL BRING
FAIRNESS TO THE FEE TO TRUST
APPLICATION PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON C.
NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. FOR CORPORATE. IT IS OUR
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
DEVELOPED. CLARK WELL CLOSER
ROLE TELL YOU WHAT I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM FIFTY
ONE. PASS AND RETAIN OUR FILE
ITEM FIFTY TWO. THAT BRINGS US
FIVE FIFTY THREE SENATE BILL
THREE EIGHTY SIX. CORRECT
SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY SIX BY
SENATOR UMBERG AND OTHERS
NEGLIGENCE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
MR DALY YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS
BILL ALLOWS THE OWNERS OF THE
HONDA CENTER ARENA IN ORANGE
COUNTY TO EXPAND THEIR EXISTING
SPONSORSHIP TIED HOUSE
EXEMPTION. VIA A FUTURE PLAN
NINETY FIVE ACRE DEVELOPMENT
AROUND THE FACILITY. THIS WILL
PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN
CREATING JOBS AND REVITALIZING
THE LOCAL ECONOMY IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AROUND THAT ARENA.
EXPECTED TO CREATE TEN THOUSAND
CONSTRUCTION JOBS AND THREE
THOUSAND PERMANENT JOBS THE
BILL HAS STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
DALY. C. NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE BACK. TWO MINUTES
RAISES ITEM THIS IS FILE ITEM
FORTY FIVE. FILE ITEM FORTY
FIVE SENATE BILL THREE THREE
FOUR. AND THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY FOUR
BY SENATOR ALSO AND OTHERS MAC
LEADING TO DETENTION
FACILITIES. ISRAEL'S YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. TO THEIR PRESENT SB
THREE THIRTY FOR THE DETENTION
FACILITY ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
AUTHORED BY SENATOR DO IT ALSO.
WHICH WILL REQUIRE PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT PRISON PRISONS AND
DETENTION CENTERS. TWEET HERE
TO ALL APPROPRIATE STATE AND
LOCAL HEALTH SAFETY FIRE AND
JAIL STANDARDS. TO MAINTAIN
COMPREHENSIVE INSURANCE
COVERAGE INCLUDING GENERAL
LIABILITY. AUTOMOBILE LIABILITY
WORKERS COMP AN UMBRELLA
LIABILITY. TO REQUIRE DETENTION
FACILITIES TO SUBMIT ANNUAL
COMPLIANCE REPORTS TO BOTH THE
INSURANCE PROVIDER COMPANY AND
THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE. THE REQUIRED SURE IT'S
COMPANIES PROVIDE COVERAGE TO
DETENTION FACILITIES. AND BE
ADMITTED THAT THEY BE ADMITTED
AND RECOGNIZED BY OUR STATE.
MEMBERS THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL APPLIES EQUALLY TO FOR
PROFIT FACILITIES ENGAGED IN
CIVIL THE DETENTION OF CRIMINAL
DETENTION LIKE THEY DO FOR
PUBLIC FACILITIES. BECAUSE WE
EXPECT ALL FACILITIES OPERATING
IN THE STATE TWEET HERE TO THE
SAME STANDARDS AND GUIDELINES.
WITHOUT THIS BILL THESE
FACILITIES WILL CONTINUE TO
FAIL TO MEET THE STATE'S
STRINGENT HEALTH. SAFETY JAIL
LABOR AND CARE STANDARDS THAT
APPLY TO ALL ENTITIES DOING
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS REYES SAY
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THE
CLUB THE ROLE. IS THERE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE TO SACK TO
VOTE. AND THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE
A ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY
KNOWS THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES. BACK IN FILE ORDER.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIFTY THREE
THE CAR FOR ME SENATE BILL
SEVEN FIFTY THREE BIAS IN A
ROCK CONNECTING TO IMPLEMENT
MIS READ US YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD IS REQUIRED
TO CONDUCT AN EVALUATION OF
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS FUNDED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THE EDT
PROVIDES THE BOARD WITH
REQUIRED WAGE AND EMPLOYMENT
DATA TO EVALUATE THE EFFICACY
OF THESE PROGRAMS SB SEVEN
FIFTY THREE INTENDS ON
PROVIDING THE E. D. D. WITH THE
STATUTE TORIA FORTY TO PROVIDE
THE SAME WAGE AND EMPLOYMENT
DATA SHARED WITH EVALUATING
FEDERAL FUNDED WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS TO THE BOARD WHEN
EVALUATING STATE FUNDED
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS. THIS BILL
SIMPLY PROVIDES CLARITY THAT
THE EDT CAN SHARE IDENTICAL
INFORMATION WITH THE BOARD FOR
THE PURPOSES OF EVALUATION AND
ANALYSIS OF STATE AND FEDERALLY
FUNDED WORKFORCE PROGRAMS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS RIVAS SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLUB CLUB IN
THE ROLE. ZERO ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSER
ROLE TIED UP I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES WE'RE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE. WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM FIFTY
SIX. S. B. TWO TWENTY ONE THE
CORPORATION. SENATE BILL TWO
TWENTY ONE BIAS IN A WIENER AND
OTHERS SNACK WITH THE HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE MISS WALDRON YOU
MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR WIENER AND AS
A CO AUTHOR TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL TWO TO ONE. ESTABLISHING
CLEAR TIMELY ACCESS STANDARDS
TO FOLLOW UP MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER CARE. BY
CLARIFYING THAT THE EXISTING
TIMELINESS REQUIREMENT APPLIES
TO FOLLOW UP APPOINTMENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN IT COMES TO
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS WE ARE FAILING TO
PROVIDE LIFESAVING FOLLOW UP
CARE. SO THAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS. REQUIRE IT.
COLLEAGUES WE WOULD NEVER
TOLERATE THIS BEHAVIOR FOR
PHYSICAL HEALTH WOULD YOU
TOLERATE YOUR LOVE ONE BEING
TOLD THAT THERE LIFESAVING
CANCER TREATMENT. WILL BE
PROVIDED BUT THEIR APPOINTMENTS
TAKE PLACE EVERY FEW MONTHS
WHEN TREATMENT IS RECOMMENDED
EACH WEEK TO HAVE A REAL SHOT
AT BEATING THEIR DIAGNOSIS. I
IMAGINE THE ANSWER IS NO. WE
MUST REMEMBER THAT PROVIDING
MEDICALLY NECESSARY CARE IS
SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH WHEN THAT
CARE IS SO DELAYED THE PEOPLE
ARE LITERALLY TAKING THEIR OWN
LIVES. WITH RECENT AMENDMENTS
TO DELAY THE IMPLEMENTATION
OPPOSITION IS NOW NEUTRAL AND
THE BILL IS UNOPPOSED. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON DR WOOD
THANKS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I STAND IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO TWENTY ONE IS THIS BILL
WILL CLOSE A LOOPHOLE IN STATE
LAW MAKE CLEAR IN APPROPRIATE
TIME THE AXIS STANDARD FOR
MENTAL HEALTH FOLLOW UP
APPOINTMENTS BEGINNING JULY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY. JULY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO I HEALTH PLAN
WILL ENSURE THAT IN IN RALEIGH
UNDERGOING TREATMENT FOR AN
ONGOING MENTAL HEALTH OR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
CONDITION IS ABLE TO GET FOR A
FOLLOW UP APPOINTMENT WITHIN
TEN DAYS THIS BILL WILL HOLD
HEALTH PLANS ACCOUNTABLE TO
ARRANGE WITH TIMELY FOLLOW UP
CARE. WHICH WOULD ROWLEY'S ARE
ENTITLED AND HELP MINIMIZE
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES
ASSOCIATED WITH DELAYS IN
TREATMENT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK GOD
WHAT. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CLERK
WILL OF. THAT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY
TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE. SB. FORTY
SEVEN. AND THE CORPORATION
SENATE BILL FORTY SEVEN BY
CENTRE LIMóN AND OTHER SNACK
LIVING OIL AND GAS. MISTER
BENNETT YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS- I RISE
TODAY SPEAK ON BEHALF OF SB
FORTY SEVEN IT ADDRESSES A
SERIOUS PROBLEM OF DESERTED OIL
WELLS IN CALIFORNIA- IT'S BEEN
ESTIMATED THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
AN ESTIMATED LIABILITY. OF OVER
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR DESERVED OIL WELLS AND
TODAY IN CALIFORNIA CAL GEMS IS
CAPPED AT ONLY SPENDING THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY ON
DESERTED WELLS IT'S CERTAINLY
AN INSUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF MONEY
TO DEAL WITH A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR DESERTED WELL
LIABILITY. ALL THIS BILL DOES
IS STOP THAT CAP FROM ACTUALLY
BEING REDUCED TO ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND INSTEAD RAISES THAT CAP SO
THAT WE ADDRESS FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF WELLS EACH
YEAR SEEMS VERY APPROPRIATE FOR
US TO DO THAT GIVEN THE
TREMENDOUS LIABILITY OF FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
DESERTED WELLS. THAT HAS A VERY
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THIS
DESERTION OF WELLS HAS TAKEN
PLACE AND PUTS TAXPAYERS AT
RISK OF HAVING TO REPAIR THESE-
BECAUSE OF OIL COMPANIES GOING
BANKRUPT SO I RESPECTFULLY
ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE ON SB
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER BENNETT MYSTERY OF
US YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY SEVEN. AND
TWENTY NINETEEN CAL JIM
IDENTIFIED THREE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE OIL AND GAS
WELLS AS POTENTIALLY DESERTED.
DESERTED OIL AND GAS WELLS CAN
HARM GROUNDWATER AND PUBLIC
HEALTH SB FORTY SEVEN IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL TO PROTECT
RESIDENTS WHO LIVE NEAR OIL AND
GAS WELLS AND ENSURE THAT OIL
COMPANIES PAY TO CLEAN UP. THE
MESS THAT THEY CREATED THIS
BILL WILL REQUIRE OIL COMPANIES
TO PAY FIVE MILLION A YEAR TO
PLUG. A BAND AND A PLUG
ABANDONED AND DESERTED OIL
WELLS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
RIVAS. C. NOTATIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLICK
LIBERAL. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. WELL. CLOSER ALL. HOWEVER
I FORTY SEVEN NO SIXTEEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. BACK IN THE
PREVIOUS FILE ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN. SENATE
BILL TWO FIFTY FIVE CORRECT
SENATE BILL TWO FIFTY FIVE BUYS
CENTER PORTANTINO AND OTHERS
ENACTED IN THE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE MS BURKE YOU MAILED IT
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBER
S. S. B. TWO FIFTY FIVE OR
PROTECT W. TO FREELANCE COMMON
LAW TV COMMERCIAL PRODUCTION
EMPLOYEES FROM LOSING THEIR
EXISTING HIGH QUALITY NO COST
INSURANCE RESULTING FROM A
RECENT CHANGE IN LAW HOW. DO TO
RECENTLY ENACTED LEGISLATION
THESE FREELANCERS ARE NOW IN
JEOPARDY OF LOSING THEIR
INSURANCE PLEASE SUPPORT OUR-
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY IS
VALUABLE WORK FORCE BY VOTING I
ON S. B. TWO FIFTY FIVE. THANK
YOU MISS BURKE. SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. CORPORAL THOSE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED SAID ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS REPRESENTATIVE OF.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL THE TIME
BUT I SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE.
THE MEASURE PASSES. RIGHT A
PASSER IN TANDEM FIVE OUT OF
FIFTY EIGHT THAT BRINGS US TO
FIVE OUT OF FIFTY NINE SB THREE
TWENTY ONE CORKERY SENATE BILL
THREE TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR TO
RAZA AD OTHERS BACK LEADING TO
EMPLOYMENT MR CHU YOUR MAILBOX
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL ADDRESSES
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OVER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOMESTIC
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA MOSTLY
IMMIGRANT WOMEN WHO ARE HELPING
TO CARE FOR THE FAMILIES IN
MORE THAN TWO MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS. THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE
THAT WOULD DEVELOP EDUCATIONAL
INVOLUNTARY GUIDELINES FOR
PROTECTING HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
THESE WORKERS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ADDITIONAL
STEPS THAT ARE LEGISLATURE OR
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS COULD TAKE TO BETTER
PROTECT THESE WORKERS THIS
MEASURE IS ON OPPOSE AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP TOWARD
PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF HOUSEHOLD DOMESTIC
SERVICE EMPLOYEES AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER Q.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. OUT OF IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ROADSIDE OF L. WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE I FIFTY ONE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS
IS FILE ITEM SIXTY SB THREE
THIRTY SIX CORPORATE. SENATE
BILL THREE THIRTY SIX BY A
CENTER OCHO BOW GRANDMOTHERS
MACULATA PUBLIC HEALTH TWO
CLEARLY OR TO SEE THEIR OF THE
COMMITTEE LEAGUE. MISTER GIBSON
YOU MAIL IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
US SENATE BILL THREE THREE SIX
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR ALL TOLD
BOAT- THIS A WILL HELP TO
ENSURE THAT COMMUNITIES. IT
HAVE ANY IMPACT OR ANY
INDUSTRIES ARE AWARE AND ARE
PREPARED- FOR CHANGES AS
RELATES TO COVERT THIS BILL
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT
I VOTE. ON THREE THREE SIX.
DAVIS GIPSON SAY NO DISCUSSION.
OR DEBATE ON THE I DON'T. CLICK
LOW PAROLE MEMBERS TURNS OUT TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS VALUES ARE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY TWO NO ZERO
THE URGENCY I SIXTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO ON THE MEASURE. THE BILL
PASSES.
MISTER CHOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
PLEASE MOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS
TO THE INACTIVE FILE ITEM FORTY
THREE SB FOUR TEN LEYVA AT THE
REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ ITEM SIXTY FIVE SB
THREE NINETY SIX DOLLY AT THE
REQUEST OF A SET. OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BASE. THE CLERK WILL
KNOW.
AVERAGE BACK ON THE FILE
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM. SIXTY ONE.
THIS IS MR SANTIAGO FILE ITEM.
SIXTY ONE. SENATE BILL. THREE
FORTY ONE. COOKERY SENATE BILL
THREE FORTY ONE BY THE SENATE
MCGUIRE AND OTHERS MACULATUS
TELECOMMUNICATIONS THIS IS YOUR
SANTIAGO EMAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I TODAY I RISE
IN AND MASS RIVAL FOR SB THREE
FORTY ONE BY CENTER MCGUIRE
THIS WOULD ALLOW THE PC THE
TORY TO CREATE A PACK OF
BATTERIES AND RULES FOR CELL
TOWERS LAND LINE OPERATIONS AND
CABLE SYSTEMS. IT WOULD ALSO
AMENDED THE CAL- YES SHARE
NETWORK OUTAGE INFORMATION THEY
ALREADY RECEIVE FROM COME TO PC
THEREFORE INCREASING
TRANSPARENCY IN PUBLIC. SAFETY
THE COMMONSENSE BILL THAT WILL
ALLOW OUR NETWORKS TO BE MORE
RESILIENT IT IS SUPPORTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION STATE SHERIFFS
EMILY CITIES ARE STRICTLY
OUTSIDE OF. THANK YOU MISS
SANTIAGO. SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE I DON'T. FOUR
GLOBAL ROLE. OUR VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ALL THE TIME BUT I
SIXTY NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
SIXTY TWO. THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTY THREE. SB THREE SIXTY SIX
REFEREE SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY
SIX BY CENTER- BURKE IMMACULATE
INTO VEHICLE DISMANTLING MISS
CLARK SILVA THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY
SIX ON BEHALF OF SENATOR AMBER
THIS BILL WILL REESTABLISH THE
VEHICLE DISMANTLING INDUSTRY
STRIKE TEAM SO THAT IT CAN TO
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THE SERIOUS
ENVIRONMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC IMPACTS. CAUSED BY AN
LICENSE AND UNREGULATED
AUTOMOBILE DISMANTLING SB THREE
SIXTY SIX WILL ALSO ENHANCE
FINDS ON LICENSE VIA VEHICLE
DISMANTLE ORDERS AND DISC
PLAYER THEM AS A PUBLIC NEW SON.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE AN
IMPORTANT WORK OF ADDRESSING
THESE UNLICENSED AND
UNREGULATED VEHICLE DISMANTLING
SHOPS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK REST
PURCELL SENIOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. USER TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. AND
BOB RIVERS AT ABOUT. LIKE WELL
CULTURAL TIE BUT I SIXTY FIVE
NO ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR THREE
SIXTY SIX PASS AND RETAIN.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM SIXTY SEVEN. PASS
A RETAINER FIVE OUT OF SIXTY
EIGHT. PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEMS SIXTY NINE AND SEVENTY.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY ONE SB. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT. CORRECT SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT BY CENTER RUBIO
AND OTHERS TACKLING TO
RESTRAINING ORDERS THIS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY
I RISE TO PRESENT SB FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT A CRITICAL MEASURE
FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND GUN
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS SEEKING
PROTECTION FROM THEIR ABUSERS
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
WILL ALLOW VICTIMS TO FILE
ELECTRONICALLY FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS AND ALLOW
VICTIMS TO TESTIFY REMOTELY.
SOME STUDIES HAVE SHOWN DOUBLE
DIGIT INCREASES IN THE VOLUME
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES IN
THE U. S. WHICH HAS BEEN
REFERRED TO AS A PANDEMIC WITH
A PANDEMIC WITHIN A PANDEMIC
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE GREATER
SAFETY FOR VICTIMS AS THEY TRY
TO LEAVE DANGEROUS SITUATIONS
ESPECIALLY THOSE DEALING WITH
COURSE OF CONTROL. WHICH CAN
RESULT IN PARALYZING FEAR IN
VICTIMS. PREDICT THEM EVERY DAY
IN FRONT OF THEIR ABUSER CAN BE
THAT THEIR LAST MEMBERS THIS
BILL HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS RECEIVED ZERO
NO VOTES THANK YOU AND I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MAYES RUBIO. SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM CLARK LOCAL ROLE. WHAT IS
THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THOSE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE. WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE OUT I SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS
IS. MISTER KALRA. FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY TWO. FILE ITEM SEVENTY
TWO S. FIVE SIXTY SEVEN. FILE
ITEM SEVENTY TWO SB FIVE SIXTY
SEVEN. OPERATE SENATE BILL FIVE
SIXTY SEVEN BY CENTER BRADFORD
MACULATA CRIMINAL PROCEDURE.
MISTER KALRA YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE RESENT SB FIVE SIXTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR BRADFORD SB FIVE
SIXTY SEVEN CREATES A
PRESUMPTION OF SENTENCING
JUDGMENT NOT TO EXCEED THE
MIDDLE TERM UNLESS THERE ARE
AGGRAVATING CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
JUSTIFY THE IMPOSITION OF THE
HIGH TERM. CURRENT LAW
SPECIFIES THAT A STATUTE
SPECIFIES THREE POSSIBLE
SENTENCING TERMS FOR FELONY
OFFENSES WILL MIDDLE AND HIGH
WITH VARIATIONS OF TRYING TO BE
SERVED WITH CHOICE OF THE
APPROPRIATE TERM REST THE
DISCRETION OF THE COURT.
EXISTING LAWS SUNSET ON JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND SB
FIVE SIXTY SEVEN IS A JUST AND
FAIR REPLACEMENT. THAT IMPROVES
OUR SENTENCING PROCESS. WITHOUT
SB FIVE SIXTY SEVEN CURRENT LAW
WOULD REVERT TO THE LAW AS IT
WERE BEFORE TWO THOUSAND NINE.
FORD TO CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT HAS FOUND TO BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL ON THE BASIS
THAT BOX HOCKEY PRESENTED TO A
JURY. AND PROVEN BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT. SB FIVE SIXTY
SEVEN PROVIDES THAT WHEN A HIGH
TERMS IMPOSED THE FACTS
SUPPORTING THE AGGRAVATION MUST
BE ONE. STIPULATED TO BY THE
DEFENDANT OR TO SUBMITTED TO
THE JURY A PROVEN BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT OR THREE.
FOUND BY THE COURT IN A BENCH
TRIAL IN THE INSTANCE WHERE
THERE ARE NO THERE'S NO JURY
INVOLVED. SB FIVE TO SEVEN
ALLOWS THE PARTIES DISPUTE
FACTS IN THE RECORD AND PERMITS
TO BONUS REQUEST BIFURCATED
HEARINGS. OR TRIAL CHARGES IN
CERTAIN INSTANCES. IN THE
CONTEXT OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM OUT IS APPROPRIATE. TO
PUNISH PEOPLE FOR COMMITTING
CRIMES WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GIVE IMPACT PEOPLE
PROPER DUE PROCESS. THAT IS
BUILT UPON FAIRNESS AND STOCKS
THAT BOSSES REHABILITATION
ABOUT ALSO SHE'S PUBLIC SAFETY.
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE SB BY SIX
SEVEN DOES ALL THAT. AND IT
SAVES US MONEY BECAUSE STUDIES
SHOW THAT ON WARRANTED UPPER
TERM SENTENCES ARE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE. TO
REHABILITATION. REASON FOR
MEMBERS ARE TECHNICAL IN NATURE
AND ADDRESSES CONCERNS REGIONAL
COUNCIL TO CHANGE FOR THEIR
POSITION FROM OPPOSED TO
NEUTRAL. IN ADDITION THEY ALSO
CHAPTER OUT AB FIFTEEN FORTY IN
AB ONE TWENTY FOUR WITHOUT
REPLY MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN IPHONE S. B. BY
SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA. SEEING NO DISCUSSION FOR
DEBATE ON THE ADAM CLARK LOCAL
ROLE. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF.
MISTER
KALRA MOOSE CALL. YEAH. WE ARE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE. WE
WILL TAKE A FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FOUR SB. FIVE EIGHTY NINE. IN
THE CORPORATION SENATE BILL
FIVE EIGHTY NINE BY CENTER
HUESO AND OTHERS MACKLIN TO AIR
POLLUTION. MR GARCIA EMAIL ME
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MORNING I PRESENT SB FIVE
EIGHTY NINE BY THE SCENE
SENATOR FROM SAN DIEGO THIS
BILL. IS SIMPLE MEASURE TO
ENSURE THAT OUR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION POLICIES REFLECT
THE NEED FOR IN STATE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES AND WORKFORCE
EQUITY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU MR GARCIA
C. NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE ON
THE ADAM CLARK LOCAL ARE ALL.
MEMBERS WHAT IS THAT VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE- RYSZARD
VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS
IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE SB
FIVE NINETY EIGHT. CORPORATE
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY EIGHT
BY CENTER PAN AND OTHERS BACK
WITHIN A PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT MR
MCCARTY MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR PAN AYE THIS WOULD
ALLOW OUR REGIONAL TRANSIT
AGENCY TO MOVE THEIR UNFAIR
LABOR PRACTICE PROCEDURES FROM
THE PURBA. TO THE PER BOARD AS
OPPOSED TO THE OVER BURDENED
AND UNDER RESOURCE SUPERIOR
COURT SYSTEM THIS IS A- A BILL
THAT WILL FOCUS ON MAKING SURE
WE HAVE A STREAMLINED PROCESS
AND OUR- AND OUR LABOR
PRACTICES ASKING ARRIVAL THANK
YOU. THANK IN THIS REGARD. THE
ROLE. IS THAT A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL THE TIME
BUT I FIFTY TWO NO SIX THAT
MEASURE PASSES. PAST RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX. THIS IS
FILE ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN SB SIX
FORTY THREE. THIS IS MISTER
DALY. AND THE- CORKERY SENATE
BILL SIX FORTY THREE BY THE
CENTRE ARCHULETA AND OTHERS
MACINNES AIR POLLUTION. MR
DAILY EMAIL BUT THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS BILL
REQUIRES RELEVANT STATE
AGENCIES TO PREPARE STATEWIDE
ASSESSMENT OF THE FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FUEL
PRODUCTION NEEDED TO SUPPORT
THE ADOPTION OF ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS BUSES AND OFF ROAD
VEHICLES THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
TO THE MEASURE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER DALY CITY NO
DISCUSSION. OUR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CARPAL OF THE ROLE. IS
THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
THAT ARE DESIRABLE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TYLER I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT.
SB SIX FIFTY OPERATE SENATE
BILL SIX FIFTY BY SOONER STERN
ACCORDING TO SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES MR MURATSUCHI. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M PRESENTING SP
SIX FIFTY AN IMPORTANT BILL BY
SANDRA STERN THE CORPORATE
TRANSPARENCY IN ELDER CARE ACT
THIS IS A TRANSPARENCY AND
GOVERNMENT OVERSIGHT BILL OVER
A TROUBLED NURSING HOME
INDUSTRY IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
STATE AUDITOR ISSUED A REPORT.
ABSENT EFFECTIVE STATE
OVERSIGHT SUB STANDARD QUALITY
OF CARE HAS CONTINUED ONE OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
STATE- AUDITOR WAS TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY OVER V. COMMON
PRACTICE OF NURSING HOMES USING
RELATED ENTITIES BASICALLY
RELATED PARTIES WHERE. THE
NURSING HOME LICENSEE THE OWNER
THE OPERATOR THEY HAVE THE
OWNERSHIP INTEREST SO THEY
THEY'RE THEY'RE BASICALLY
SPENDING TAXPAYER DOLLARS MEDIC
MEDICARE TAXPAYER DOLLARS GOING
TO ENRICH THE BAD ACTOR NURSING
HOME OPERATORS RATHER THAN
DIRECTING THEM TO RESIDENT
CARE. THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY
SEIU CALIFORNIA- CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM AND SUPPORTED BY THE A.
R. P. AND HAS NO OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AS MURATSUCHI SAYING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
AT A LOCAL OF THE ROLE. IS THAT
A VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT
A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL.
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP AT I.
FORTY NINE KNOWS THREE THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MISTER CHOW YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
THE RULES TO TAKE UP AB ONE OH
ONE MEDINA TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MR
SHABAZZ WALTER FOR PURPOSE WE
OPPOSE THE MOTION AND ASK FOR A
ROLL CALL. MISS WALDRON IS
WITHHOLDING MISTER CHILD MOVES
AND MISS PARA QUE HAN SECONDS
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION.
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MR CHALICE ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND MISS WALDRON I KNOW
MISTER CHOW'S ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MISS WALDRON I KNOW THIS
IS PROCEDURAL. CLARK WELL CLOSE
ROLL EYES FIFTY DOLLARS
SEVENTEEN. THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. AND THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. WE'RE GOING
TO THE MEDINA ITEM WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE THIS IS. AB
ONE ON. ONE IN THE CORPORATION
SOME PEOPLE WANNA ONE BIAS
MEDINA AND OTHERS TACKLING THE
PEOPLE INSTRUCTION MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB ONE OH ONE IS BACK
ON CAN CURRENTS. AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE CLARIFY AND
TIGHTEN THE GUIDELINES
SURROUNDING SCHOOLS FLEXIBILITY
WHEN ADOPTING THE MODEL
CURRICULUM APPROVED BY THE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION. THEY REAFFIRM AN
OPEN AND TRANSPARENT PROCESS
WHEN ADOPTING ETHNIC STUDIES
MODEL CURRICULUMS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. THE LATINO CAUCUS THE
BLACK CAUCUS THE NATIVE
AMERICAN CAUCUS THE API
CHARACTERS AND THE JEWISH
CAUCUS ALL STAND IN SUPPORT OF
THE FINAL VERSION OF AB ONE OH
ONE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
MEDINA. SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISSPELLED THERE'S YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER IS MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
IN OPPOSITION OF AB ONE OH ONE
MEMBERS I COULDN'T AGREE MORE
WITH THE AUTHOR THAT KNOWLEDGE
OF OUR HISTORY PLAYS A CRITICAL
ROLE IN SHAPING WHO. WE BECOME
IT'S CLEAR THAT WHEN STUDENTS
LEARN ABOUT THEIR HISTORY THEIR
CULTURE AND THEIR BACKGROUND
THEY ARE SO MUCH MORE ENGAGED
IN THE CLASSROOM. MY HAVE MY
FAMILY HAS A HISTORY LIKE THAT
AS YOU MANY OF YOURS MY
GRANDPARENTS FIRST CAME TO
CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN ELEVEN
IN NINETEEN SEVENTEEN FROM
MEXICO THEY MOVED TO THE KERN
COUNTY TO BAKERSFIELD. TICKETS
IN THE FIELDS OF GRAPES AND CON
YOU NAME IT MY FAMILY PICKED IT
AND ARE CENTRAL VALLEY. THIS IS
A HUGE THEY ARE PART OF THE
LABOR MOVEMENT MY GRANDMOTHER.
WORKED ALONGSIDE SAYS HER
TRAVIS IN THE FIELDS WITH
GRAPES I UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF CULTURE MY FAMILY
HAS LIVED THIS. WE TALK IN THIS
CHAMBER ABOUT HOW THE STORY OF
IMMIGRANTS HELP MAKE UP THE
AMERICAN HIS AMERICAN HISTORY.
LITERATURE AND CULTURE WE ALL
AGREE THAT THESE STORIES ARE
SIGNIFICANT A SIGNIFICANT PART
OF OUR COLLECTIVE HISTORY. AS
AMERICANS THEY HELP DEFINE WHO
WE ARE AS A COLLECTIVE. MY
STORY AND YOUR STORIES ARE PART
OF THE STORY- PART OF THE STORY
AND CULTURE OF THIS COUNTRY AND
STATE. IT IS FOR THAT REASON
THAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
WE'RE INTERESTED IN
SEQUESTERING THESE STORIES AND
UNNATURALLY REMOVING THEM FROM
OUR COLLECTIVE HISTORY. LET'S
TELL THE STORIES THE WAY THEY
NEED TO BE TAUGHT IN CONTEXT MY
STORY AND YOUR STORY ARE A PART
OF HISTORY A PART OF LITERATURE
AND A PART OF SOCIAL SOCIAL
STUDIES. THIS BILL DOESN'T
TEACHER STORIES IN CONTEXT
INSTEAD IT REMOVES THE STORIES
AND PLACES THEM AND SEPARATE IN
A SEPARATE CLASS. IT PLACES A
NEW GRADUATION REQUIREMENT ON
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS MOST OF
WHOM HAVE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF LEARNING LOSS AND A
POTENTIALLY WORSENS. THEIR
CHEAP MAKE UP WE CAN'T GET THE
BREAK THE BASICS RIGHT IN MATH
AND ENGLISH. AND EVEN THOUGH I
BELIEVE THE AUTHOR WELL
INTENTIONED I SINCERELY FEEL
THAT THE BILL WILL PROMPT
FURTHER DIVISION AMONG OUR
STUDENTS AND WILL IRONICALLY
WORSEN ECONOMIC OUTCOMES. FOR
MOST DISADVANTAGED MINORITY
STUDENTS I URGE A NO VOTE THANK
YOU. MS GARCIA YOUR RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU ADDRESS THE STRONG
SUPPORTER THIS BILL AND I WANT
TO REFERENCE. TO COMMENTS THAT
MY COLLEAGUE FROM NORTHERN L.
A. COUNTY JUST MENTIONED ONE
ABOUT THE FACT THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE STRUGGLING IN MATH
AND BASS AND OTHER BASIC
SUBJECTS AT THE FORMER MATH
TEACHER. I KNOW FIRST AND
FOREMOST THAT OUR STUDENTS
GOING ABOUT THEIR HISTORY
RESTRAINS- THE TAP IN THE GOOD
THE BAD AND THE UGLY ONLY MAKES
IS BETTER STUDENTS TO MAKE IT
MORE RESILIENT. I OFTEN THINK
TO MYSELF ABOUT THE CHALLENGES
MY FAMILY HAS GONE THROUGH-
ALSO I SAW FARMWORKERS ALSO HAS
UNDOCUMENTED ALONG THE WAY.
ANYTHING ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THEY CAN FROM THAT STOCK- AND
THAT'S AUGUSTINIANS THAT'S AND
I WOULD BE SUCCESSFUL. AND
OFTEN AT THE MY TEACHER I WOULD
TELL MY STUDENTS THINK ABOUT
THAT REMEMBER THOSE STORIES. A
WE WERE THE- THINKING INTO
CONGRESS BUT WE THRIVED
ANYWAYS. A LOT OF THINGS HAVE
HAPPENED ALONG THE WAY AND SO.
I KNOW FIRST ND FOREMOST
ANECDOTALLY THAT THIS WORKS.
SECONDLY RESEARCH TELLS US THAT
THIS WORK BETTER STUDENTS DO
BETTER WHEN THEY ARE EXPOSED TO
THEIR HISTORY. THIRD THIS IDEA
ABOUT THE VISION I THINK THE
MORE WE TECH TELL THEIR
STORIES. AND THE MORE WE TELL
THEM IN THE CONTEXT OF OUR
REALITIES. THE CLOTHES ARE
GOING TO BE THE MORE EMPATHY
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE. AND THE
BETTER STUDENTS ARE GOING TO BE
TO BE THE LEADERS THAT WE NEED
THEM TO BE. OUT THERE SO I
STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT I VOTE.
OUT THERE AND I THINK WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY. TO NOT IGNORE
THE RESURGENT NOT IGNORE THE
DATA OUT THERE. AND NOT JUST
VOTE ON REACTIONARY STATEMENTS
OUT THERE. ARE THIS COMFORT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE A BAD THING-
SOMETIMES WE'VE DONE A LOT TO
MAKE PEOPLE COMFORTABLE. AS
PEOPLE OF COLOR BUT IT'S TIME
THAT SOMETHING TO MAKE THEM A
LITTLE BIT UNCOMFORTABLE OUT
THERE. SO THAT WE CAN MOVE
EVERYONE FORWARD AND NOT JUST A
CERTAIN PART OF THE POPULATION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GARCIA MISTER
BRIAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN STRONG.
STRONG STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. PRIOR TO BEING A MEMBER
OF THIS BODY I TAUGHT AND-
ETHNIC STUDIES RESEARCH CENTER.
AT THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
LOS ANGELES. WE DON'T KNOW OUR
HISTORY IN SCHOOLS AND AT THE
TIME THIS COUNTRY AND CRITICAL
RACE THEORY IS UNDER ATTACK AND
WRITE HIS HISTORY IS BEING
SUBVERTED FOR REVISIONIST
HISTORY. ALL ACROSS THE SOUTH
AND ALL ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
THIS IS CALIFORNIA THIS IS
WHERE WE LEAD. THIS BILL WAS A
COMPROMISE BETWEEN ALL THE
ETHNIC POCKETS IS THE JEWISH
CONGRESS AND OTHERS WE HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT RACISM. WE HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT STRUCTURAL VIOLENCE
WE HAVE TO TALK. ABOUT ANTI
IMMIGRATION SENTIMENTS WE HAVE
TO TALK ABOUT ISLAMOPHOBIA WE
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT ANTI
SEMITISM I'M GOING TO TALK
ABOUT IT COLLECTIVELY UP AND
DOWN THE STATE WE DO IT AT THE
COLLEGIATE LEVEL. I WOULD DO IT
BETTER THAN ANYBODY ELSE AND
THERE'S NO REASON ALL HIGH
SCHOOLS. WHICH ARE FILLED WITH
MORE STUDENTS OF COLOR THAN
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THIS COUNTRY
SHOULD NOT HAVE A RIGHT TO THE
HISTORY BEING TAUGHT I'M PROUD
OF THIS LEGISLATURE. THIS BILL
HAS BEEN THREE YEARS IN THE
MAKING IT'S LONG OVERDUE. LET'S
PASS IT TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER
PRIME. MINISTER BERMAN. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I PROBABLY
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH
ONE AND ONCE THEY ALSO DO IT ON
BEHALF OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS AND
THE CHAIR OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS.
WHO CAN'T BE HERE TODAY BECAUSE
HE'S ACTUALLY IN SECOND DAY
SERVICES FOR RUSSIA SHAWNA- BUT
WAS JUST TEXTING ME FRANTICALLY
I MAKING SURE THAT WE SPEAK UP
IN SUPPORT MAKING SURE THAT WE-
EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE TO THE
AUTHOR OF AB ONE OH ONE FOR HIS
STEADFAST LEADERSHIP OF THIS
ISSUE AND FOR A LITTLE. DOZENS
IF NOT HUNDREDS OF
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD.
ABOUT ETHNIC STUDIES ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF ETHNIC STUDIES-
BUT ALSO ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF MAKING SURE THAT. THERE'S
SOME GUARDRAILS IN THE BILL TO
MAKE SURE THAT. ON CERTAIN
THINGS THAT WERE OF CONCERN IN
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY FOR
EXAMPLE. OUR ADDRESS AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR GUARDRAILS
THAT. MAKE SURE THAT FOR
EXAMPLE ANTI SEMITISM CANNOT BE
TAUGHT. IN OUR SCHOOLS AND THE
AUTHOR HAS DONE THAT- AND HE'S
HE'S PUT THOSE GUARDRAILS IN
THIS BILL AND WE ARE GRATEFUL
TO HIM. FOR HIM BEING OPEN TO
DOING THAT AS WITH ANY THROUGH
OUR CONVERSATIONS. I'VE LEARNED
THINGS ABOUT MY OWN COMMUNITY
FROM COLLEAGUES WHO AREN'T A
PART OF THE JEWISH COMMUNITY-
AND I THINK THAT'S YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS MEANT TO.
PROMOTE AND SPUR- THOSE
CONVERSATIONS SO THAT WE ALL
LEARN FROM EACH OTHER BUT THAT
WE ALL LIVE AND LEARN. THE
TRUTH. ABOUT OUR HISTORY AND
THE TRUTH ABOUT OTHER
COMMUNITIES HISTORIES THAT MAKE
CALIFORNIA SUCH AN AMAZING
PLACE- BECAUSE OUR DIVERSITY IS
OUR STRENGTH T IS UNEQUIVOCAL-
AND ETHICS IT BUT THE FACT
THAT. WE HAVE PEOPLE GROWING UP
IN CARE AND GOING TO SCHOOL IN
CALIFORNIA WHO DON'T LEARN
THEIR TRUE HISTORY. IS A SHAME.
AND IT'S A SHAME THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED AND IT'S A SHAME
THAT THIS BILL WILL HELP.
ADDRESS SO THE CHAIR OF THE
JEWISH CUCUS I MEAN A WHOLE
LOT OF OTHER STUFF I WAS
SUPPOSED TO READ. I'M NOT GOING
TO- BUT JUST AGAIN WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL-
FOR HIS DIALOGUE WITH US- AND
HEARING US. IN FOR IS HIS LONG
LEADERSHIP OF THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE THANK YOU. MEMBERS OF
YOUR PARTICIPATING IN THIS
DEBATE PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONES AT THIS TIME.
PLEASE RAISE YOUR MIKE'S NOW.
MS RUBIO YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I'M I
STAND HERE BEFORE YOU AS AN AND
OF FORMER DEPORTED IMMIGRANT
AND UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS UP
UNTIL I WAS THIRTEEN YEARS OLD
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT MY
JOURNEY TO THIS. AMAZING FLOOR
HAS BEEN VERY DIFFICULT. FOR
YEARS I FELT GUILTY I WAS IN
MEXICAN ENOUGH BUT I WITHIN
AMERICAN ENOUGH I'VE LIVED IN
THE MIDDLE MOST OF MY LIFE
BECAUSE THERE WAS NEVER ANY
EDUCATION OR ANYTHING THAT
REFERENCE MY JOURNEY OR MY
PEOPLE. WHICH IS VERY DIFFERENT
THAN VERY MANY IMMIGRANTS AND
SO I STAND HERE BEFORE YOU AS A
MEMBER OF THIS LEGISLATURE
BEING THE FIRST DEPORTED. AND
THE FIRST UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANT STANDING ON THIS
FLOOR TODAY I DON'T WANT MY
CHILDREN TO LIVE IN BETWEEN.
AND NOT FEEL GUILTY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND NOT FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE NOT MEXICAN ENOUGH AND
THEY ARE NOT AMERICAN ENOUGH
BECAUSE THERE IS NO REFERENCE
TO OUR JOURNEY IN ANY OF OUR
HISTORY BOOKS. SO I STAND
PROUDLY IN FRONT OF YOU IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL FOR
MYSELF.AND FOR MY CHILDREN FOR
MY CHILDREN'S CHILDREN I WANT
THEM TO KNOW THEIR HISTORY AND
KNOW THAT IT'S OKAY FOR US TO
BE STANDING HERE TODAY AND BE A
MEMBER OF THIS HOUSE OR
WHATEVER IT IS THAT THEY WANT%
TO DO. MY FAMILY BROUGHT US TO
THIS COUNTRY TO THIS AMAZING
COUNTRY BECAUSE OF THE
POSSIBILITIES NEVER IN MY
PARENT'S DREAMS THAT THEY
IMAGINE BACK NOT ONLY ONE
DAUGHTER BUT TWO DAUGHTERS
SENATORS SUSAN RUBIO WOULD BE
IN THIS HOUSE. AND I WANT THEM
TO KNOW THAT THEY CAN BE PART
OF THIS HISTORY AS WELL SO I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND MY
COLLEAGUES FOR BRINGING THIS UP
AND I PROUDLY SUPPORT AB ONE OH
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MAYES
RUBIO MR GIPSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS. I WANT
TO I WAS NOT PREPARED TO SPEAK
BUT I FEEL LED TO DO THIS. AND
I WANT TO COMMEND BY MY
COLLEAGUE OF. FOUR ONE HAVING
THE VISION TO BRING US TOGETHER
BECAUSE I BELIEVE WITHOUT A
VISION THE PEOPLE PERISH. AND
CERTAINLY CALIFORNIA STANDS AT
THE CUSP. OF BEING THE BEACON
OF LIGHT IF THE OTHER STATES
ALL ACROSS THIS THESE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AND WHAT
BETTER WAY TO- MAKING SURE THAT
WE DO NOT LOSE HISTORY. BUT THE
TEACHER TO OUR YOUNG PEOPLE I
STAND HERE AS AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS. RALLY BEHIND AND
SUPPORT THIS AUTHOR BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE IN THIS OFFCE WE
BELIEVE IN ETHNIC STUDIES IT IS
IMPORTANT WE TELL THE STORY AND
NOT THE LET THE STORY'S NOT BE
TOLD. AND SO SOMEONE WHO HALL
SO YOU LOOK AT MY FAMILY MY
FAMILY REPRESENTS CALIFORNIA IN
THE DIVERSITY WHERE YOU HAVE
YOU KNOW US US THE MORE IN A
GRANDSON AND A LATINA. TWO
GRANDDAUGHTERS AND SO WE ARE
PROUD OF THAT AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE YOUNG
PEOPLE GROWING UP- REFLECTED
ALSO UNDERSTAND THEIR RICH
CULTURE THEIR RICH HERITAGE. SO
I KNOW THAT THIS AUTHOR WORKED
HARD. I KNOW THAT WE SPENT SOME
TIME TOGETHER TALKING IN HOTEL
LOBBIES ABOUT THE
DISAPPOINTMENT OF THIS OF THIS
BILL- IN PAST BUT TODAY IS OUR
DAY TO DAY WE CAN TURN A RE
WRITE A NEW NARRATIVE IF FOR
THIS STATE. AND I AM SO EXCITED
TO LOOK ACROSS THE ROOM ON THAT
SIDE AND SEEING ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES STAND UNITED BEHIND
IT AUTHOR BECAUSE HE HEARS
ABOUT GOING THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND I'M SO PROUD TO
STAND AND WHEN I PUT MY
MICROPHONE DOWN. I'M GOING TO
STAND OVER THERE WITH HIM TO.
DAVIS GIPSON. MISS CARILLO. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I WANNA
JUST BRIEFLY TALK ABOUT THE
POWER OF HISTORY AND THE POWER
OF AN EMPOWER TEACHER. WHEN I
WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL AT ROOSEVELT
HIGH SCHOOL. ASSEMBLY HEIGHTS.
I HAD AN AMAZING HISTORY
TEACHER WHO HAD ONE OF OUR
STUDENTS HE WAS A FOOTBALL
PLAYER. PICK AN ARGUMENT WITH
HIM IN FRONT OF THE CLASS WE
DIDN'T KNOW THAT THIS WAS
HAPPENING. AND AFTER THE
ARGUMENT OCCURRED AND HE SENT
THE STUDENT TO THE- HE'S- HEY
GUYS. HE SENT THE STUDENT TO
THE PRINCIPAL'S OFFICE HE HAD
AS RIGHT DOWN ON A PIECE OF
PAPER WHAT WE SAW WHAT WE
WITNESS. WE TURNED IN THAT
PIECE OF PAPER TOWARDS THE
FRONT OF THE CLASSROOM. AND HE
VERY INTENTIONALLY STARTED
RIPPING. ALL OF OUR STATEMENTS
AS TO WHAT HAPPENED AND NOT OF
THIRTY STUDENTS IN THE
CLASSROOM. HE HAD. TWO PIECES
OF PAPER LEFT MR GIBBS. AND HE
SAID HISTORY IS TOLD BY THOSE
IN POWER THERE WERE THIRTY
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM WHO
WITNESSED THIS ARGUMENT AND OUT
OF THE THIRTY WE'RE ONLY GOING
TO TAKE TWO ACCOUNTS OF WHAT
HAPPENED AS HISTORY. THAT IS
THE HISTORY THAT HAS BEEN
TAUGHT. ACROSS THIS NATION. AND
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT THE STORIES OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE MISSING BECAUSE
THEY'RE TOLD FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE. THAT IS DIFFERENT.
THAT DOESN'T COME FROM US AND
THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE THE
STORIES OF OUR COMMUNITY THE
WASHINGTON POST HAD AN
INCREDIBLE STORY. ABOUT A SLAVE
NAMED YORK WHO MADE THE JOURNEY
WITH LEWIS AND CLARK AND
DISCOVERED AND SAW FOR THE
FIRST TIME. THE PACIFIC OCEAN.
EVENAFTER THAT INCREDIBLE
JOURNEY HE WAS NOT FREED. IT
DOESN'T NEED TO BE THE
WASHINGTON POST OR NEWSPAPER TO
SHARE THOSE STORIES EVERY HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS A RIGHT TO KNOW
BUT THE HISTORY OF THE STATE
AND THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE AND
THAT IS WHY ETHNIC STUDIES IS
SO INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT CRUCIAL
TO THE DEVELOPMENT. OF FUTURE
CALIFORNIANS IN THE FUTURE OF
OUR STATE IN THE FUTURE OF OUR
NATION WHICH IS WHY THIS BILL
WHICH HAS BEEN YEARS IN THE
MAKING IT'S FINALLY MOVING
FORWARD AND WHY ALL OF US ARE
STANDING HERE. SHOWING
SOLIDARITY TO THE AUTHOR WHO
HAS THIS HAS BEEN HIS PASSION
AND WE ARE ALL IN SUPPORT TO
ENSURE THAT IT BECOMES A
REALITY SO WE ALL RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK GOODNESS CARRILLO. SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. OUR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM MISTER
MEDINA YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. I COULD DO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE SPOKEN
WE'RE STANDING BE EYEING ME IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH ONE. I
THINK WE SEE TODAY- THE
CULMINATION OF A LONG STRUGGLE
A STRUGGLE OF FIFTY YEARS. WHEN
STUDENTS AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE
AT UC BERKELEY STOOD UP UNITED
TOGETHER ACROSS RACIAL GROUPS
ACROSS ETHNIC GROUPS TO SAY
THAT WE NEED TO BE REPRESENTED
WE NEED TO BE REPRESENTED IN
THE CURRICULUM. THAT STRUGGLE
OF FIFTY YEARS THAT STARTED AT
SAN FRANCISCO STATE. AT CAL
BERKELEY HAS OVER THE YEARS
TRICKLE DOWN. AND STUDENTS FOR
MANY MANY YEARS HAVE BEEN
SAYING THE SAME THING AGAIN
BACK TO NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT
WHEN STUDENTS AT EAST LA HIGH
SCHOOLS. WALKED OUT. SAYING THE
SAME THING. THAT WE NEED TO BE
IN THE BOOKS IN THE HISTORY
BOOKS WE NEED TO SEE OURSELVES
REFLECTED IN THE HISTORY BOOKS
THE WE NEED TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS COUNSELORS WHO
LOOK LIKE US. THAT IS BEEN THE
STRUGGLE OF FIFTY YEARS. AND
TODAY AS WE ARE GOING TO PASS
AB ONE OH ONE. WE ARE
REAFFIRMING THOSE STRUGGLES.
AND I WANT TO RECALL ALL THOSE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN IN THAT
STRUGGLE. TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA CLARITA. JESS THIS WEEK
MONDAY A NEW STUDY A NEW STUDY
THAT REAFFIRMED THE WORK DONE
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ABOUT
SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND THE DIFFERENCE
THAT ONE CLASS HAD ON STUDENTS
STUDY CAME OUT MONDAY. AND
FOUNDED THE BENEFITS THAT SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED STUDENTS WHO
TOOK ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES IN
NINTH GRADE LASTED THROUGHOUT
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL RESULTING AND
AS MANY HAVE POINTED OUT HIGHER
ATTENDANCE HIGHER GRADUATION
RATES INCREASED ENROLLMENT. IN
COLLEGE AND THAT THEIR
ACHIEVEMENT. WAS MARKEDLY
DIFFERENT FROM THOSE STUDENTS
WHO HAD NOT HAD ETHNIC STUDIES
IN CLOSING I WANT TO REPEAT
SOMETHING THAT I HEARD IN THE
COMMENTS IN THE SENATE. AND
THAT IS FOR THE MANY YEARS THAT
I'VE BEEN HERE IN THIS CHAMBER
WE'VE CELEBRATE EVENTS PEOPLE.
WHO HAVE DONE GREAT THINGS IN
HISTORY. BUT WE RECOGNIZE IN
THIS CHAMBER BUT STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA HAD NEVER REALLY HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR AND
LEARN ABOUT WITH THE PASSAGE OF
AB ONE OH ONE WE ARE MAKING
SURE THAT THE CELEBRATIONS THAT
WE HAVE HERE ON THIS FLOOR
EXTEND TO THE STUDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE ON AB ONE OH ONE.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA. AND WITH
THAT THE CLERK WILL. OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE- DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE PRESERVER.
ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE FIFTY FIVE
KNOWS ELEVEN SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO BE TAKING A LUNCH
BREAK. WE'RE IN RECESS FOR
LUNCH. AND THE DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS WE ARE RETURNING TO THIS
FLOOR AT ONE THIRTY. WE ARE
RETURNING TO THIS FLOOR AT ONE
PROBABLY A ONE THIRTY TO RESUME
THE BUSINESS OF THE HOUSE. ONE
THIRTY MEMBERS WE ARE IN RECESS.
YEAH MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN
SESSION PLEASE COME TO THE
FLOOR. PLEASE RETURN TO THE FOR
MEMBERS.
YEAH INVADING AND.
MEMBERS WE ARE RESERVING
SESSION PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FLOOR WE WILL BE TAKING A BILLS
MOMENTARILY.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
TAKING UP ADDITIONAL SENATE.
THIRD READING ITEMS THIS IS
SENATE THIRD READING. WE'RE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY. ON
FILE ITEM NUMBER. SEVENTY NINE.
GOING TO. PASS TEMPORARILY YEAH
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A FILE
ITEM EIGHTY THIS IS FILE ITEM
EIGHTY. SENATE BILL SEVEN OH
TWO. BY MS CARILLO. CORPORATION
SENATE BILL SEVEN OH TWO BY
CENTER WE MOAN AND OTHER SNACK
WITHIN THE STATE GOVERNMENT.
THIS CARILLO YOUR MAIL THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR 2% SB
SEVEN A TO YOU ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR LIMON. SB SEVEN OH TWO
ESTABLISHES THE WORKING GROUP
TO DISCUSS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE WAY TO
ENSURE BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
STATE. THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
THAT BY DECEMBER FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND ANNUALLY MOVING
FORWARD A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE WILL AGGREGATE WITH
AGGREGATED DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION OF INDIVIDUALS
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR BE
DISCLOSED. TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP
REFLECTS ITS GREATER POPULATION
THE COLLECTION OF GUBERNATORIAL
APPOINTEE DEMOGRAPHIC DATA IS A
CRITICAL STEP TO ACHIEVE AND
MAINTAIN. GENDER ETHNIC AND
GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY ON BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS THE ANNUAL REPORT
WILL SERVE AS A TOOL TO
IDENTIFY GAPS IN REPRESENTATION
ENCOURAGE OUTREACH TO
COMMUNITIES AND ADDRESS
BARRIERS. TO SEEKING AN
APPOINTMENT AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK HIM ISRAEL'S SAY NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CORPORAL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE. YEAH. WELL
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP HIGHS
FORTY FIVE KNOWS THREE THAT
MEASURE PASSES YEAH MISTER CHOW
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO AA THE
FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE FOLLOWING COMMITTEES
TO MEET APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE TO HEAR S. B. EIGHTY
MCGUIRE ON THURSDAY SEPTEMBER
NINTH AT NINE THIRTY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH TWO AND
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY THREE COOPER ON FRIDAY
SEPTEMBER THE TENTH AT NINE
THIRTY IN ROOM FORTY TWO- TO.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. FIRST BACK
ON THE FILE WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON. FILE ITEM
EIGHTY ONE THIS IS FILE ITEM
EIGHTY TWO. SB. SEVEN SIXTEEN.
CORRECT SENATE BILL SEVEN
SIXTEEN BY CENTER MCGUIRE AND
OTHERS MACULATUS LAND USE.
MISTER EDUARDO GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AS A SPEAKER SB
SEVEN SIXTEEN WILL EXTEND THE
SUNSET FOR THE HABITAT FOR
RESTORATION AND ENHANCEMENT ACT
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
MISTER CSE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CORPORAL.
HE SAID ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF
THAT IS THAT ABOUT. THE CLARK
WELL. CLOTHES ARE ALL CHARRED
ABOUT I. SIXTY ONE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ORDER FILE ITEM. EIGHTY
THREE. THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY
THREE. SB SEVEN EIGHTEEN.
CORPORATION SENATE BILL SEVEN
EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR BATES AND
ACCORDING TO HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE MR MAKE CHECK THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB
SEVENTEEN WILL GRANDFATHER IN A
SUCCESSFUL ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLAN THAT HAS BEEN IN EXISTENCE
FOR ALMOST A DECADE THIS BILLS
RECEIVE NO NO VOTES IN EITHER
HOUSE THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU RESERVATIONS C.
NOTICE KASHER DEBATE ON THE
ADAM CLARK LIBERAL. SACRAMENTO
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF IT IS THAT OF A.
WELL CLOSER ALL THE TIME BUT I
SIXTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. PASS AND RETAIN FILE
ITEM. EIGHTY FOUR. WE HAVE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY FIVE PASS AND RETAIN A
FIVE EIGHTY SIX THAT BRINGS US
FILE ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN SB SEVEN
NINETY SIX CORPORATE. SENATE
BILL SEVEN NINETY SIX PRICE IN
A BRADFORD AND OTHERS MACKLIN
IN STATE PARKS DECLARE THERE'S
EITHER UP THE CREEK MEDIALLY.
THIS BURKE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS SB SEVEN NINETY
SIX WILL CORRECT A GROSS
INJUSTICE THAT TOOK PLACE IN
MANHATTAN BEACH ALMOST ONE
HUNDRED YEARS AGO. THIS BILL
ALLOWS LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO
RETURN THE LAND KNOWN AS BRUCE
SPEECH. TO THE LIVING
DESCENDANTS OF THE BRUCE FAMILY
AFTER IT WAS STOLEN FROM UNDER
THEM FROM FALSE PRETENSES OF
BUILDING A PARK IN REALITY THIS
LAND WAS STOLEN FROM THE BRUCE
FAMILY IN THE NINETEEN TWENTIES
BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE. AND
AFTER YEARS OF RACIST ATTACKS
AND HARASSMENT DIRECTLY AT THE
FAMILY THE CITY OF MANHATTAN
BEACH SEIZE THE BRUCE FAMILY
PLANT WHICH WAS LATER
TRANSFERRED TO THE STATE AND TO
THE COUNTY. SB SEVENTY NINETY
SIX BEGINS TO UNTANGLE THAT WEB
OF RACES AND JUSTICE AND ABEL'S
LAND TO BE RETURNED TO ITS
RIGHTFUL OWNERS. THE STORY OF
CHARLES AND WILL BRUISE IS JUST
ONE EXAMPLE OF THE COUNTLESS
INSTANCES INCIDENTS WHICH
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION AND
RACIALLY MOTIVATED. VIOLENCE
HAS CONTRIBUTED TO AN AN EQUAL
DISTRIBUTION OF WEALTH IN THIS
COUNTRY I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I WILL. THANK GOODNESS FOR
MISTER MURATSUCHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
NINETY SIX AS A- PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
INGLEWOOD STATED THIS. IS IN
MANHATTAN BEACH WHICH IS IN MY
DISTRICT. I'VE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH. THE GOOD
FOLKS IN MANHATTAN BEACH.
MANHATTAN BEACH IS NOT A RACIST
COMMUNITY THERE ARE MANY GOOD
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE. BUT THERE
IS BROAD RECOGNITION THAT- WE
NEED TO RIGHT THIS WRONG THAT
TOOK PLACE ALMOST A HUNDRED
YEARS AGO. IT'S INTERESTING GO
THAT MANHATTAN BEACH TODAY. I
IS ABOUT 80% WHITE. AND THE
BLACK POPULATION LAST TIME I
CHECKED IS ABOUT POINT 5% AND
SO YOU KNOW MANHATTAN BEACH FOR
THOSE OF YOU THAT HAVE VISITED.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL COMMUNITY WITH
MORE THAN ITS SHARE OF. MULTI
MILLION DOLLAR HOMES. THIS-
PROPERTY AT ISSUE IS. A BEACH
FRONT PROPERTY AND- IT IS
INTERESTING TO. CONSIDER THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THE TAKING THIS
ON JUST TAKING THAT TOOK PLACE
A HUNDRED YEARS AGO HOW
MANHATTAN BEACH WOULD HAVE BEEN
DIFFERENT WITH THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GROW GENERATIONAL WEALTH IN
THIS. BEAUTIFUL COMMITTEE. ADD
THIS ON JUST TAKING NOT HAVE
TAKEN PLACE A HUNDRED YEARS AGO
SO WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
MAKE THIS RIGHT. I KNOW THAT
THIS. YOU KNOW IT THE WE CAN
ADDRESS ALL OF THE INJUSTICES
WE CAN ONLY SPECULATE AS TO HOW
MANHATTAN BEACH MAYBE DIFFERENT
AT THIS NOT TAKEN PLACE. THERE
ARE OTHER ISSUES I WAS RECENTLY
CONTACTED BY. REPRESENTATIVES
OF THE GABRIELA TONGA. I TRIED.
AND THEY WERE ALSO MAKING THE
POINT WELL WHAT ABOUT US THIS
WAS ORIGINALLY OUR LAND. BUT
HERE TODAY WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. DELIVER A
MEASURE OF JUSTICE FOR THE
BRUCE FAMILY AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI
SEEN NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE THIS BURKE YOU MAY
CLOSE I'D LIKE TO THINK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR SUPPORT ON THIS
MEASURE AS A MEMBER WHO HAS A
DISTRICT THAT'S TWENTY MINUTES
PARTS OF IT ONLY TWENTY MINUTES
FROM THE BEACH AND I HAVE AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY. AND
ALL THE TEMA COMMUNITY THAT
HAVE NEVER SEEN THE OCEAN THIS
IS ONE SMALL STEP TO REMIND MY
COMMUNITY THAT THEY ARE WELCOME
AT THE BEACH THANK YOU AND THAT
IT THAT BEACH IS FOR EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU. AND WITH THAT THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THAT A VOTE. WELL CLOSE WORLD
TITLE BUT I SIXTY FIVE KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE.
THAT BILL PASSES. IN FILER THIS
IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT SB
EIGHT OLD ONE. CORPORATE SENATE
BILL EIGHT OH ONE BY CENTER
ARCHULETA AND OTHERS BACK
LIVING TO HEALING ARTS MR LOW
EMAIL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
SB EIGHT ZERO ONE IS THIS
SUNSET BILL FOR THE BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY IN THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MR LOW SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. CARCLUB MORAL. THAT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS RESERVE A.
WELL THOSE ARE ALL TIED UP BUT
I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE PASSED SEVERAL TEN ON FILE
ITEMS EIGHTY NINE AND NINETY.
THIS IS FILE ITEM. NINETY ONE.
SB. THREE ZERO TWO. CORPORATION
SENATE BILL THREE OH TWO BY
SENATOR DIED AND OTHERS
SPECULATED TO TRIBAL GAMING TO
CLEAR THE ABSENCE EITHER OF TO
CORRECT IMMEDIATELY MISTER
BIGELOW THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS SB THREE OH TWO
RATIFIESTHE NEW TRIBAL STATE
COMPACT BETWEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE PICAYUNE
RANCHERIA WE HEARD THIS BILL
LAST WEEK AND HAD AN AYE VOTE
ON IT ENCOURAGE ANOTHER AYE
VOTE THIS WEEK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS BIGELOW. SEEING
THEIR DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
THE ADAM. APPLE OF THE ROLE. OF
MEMBERS OF. IS THAT A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS REPRESENT ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SERVER. CORRECT
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIE THAT I
SIXTY FOUR KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE. THAT BILL PASSES.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY. ON FILE ITEM.
NINETY TWO. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO THE
CONCURRENCE FILE WE'RE GOING
BACK TO CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS. WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE ARE MOVING TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN THIS IS FILE ITEM.
FIFTEEN AB. TWO TWO NINE.
CORPORATE SYMBOL TO TWENTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN AND
OTHERS NATURALLY TO PROFESSIONS
AND VOCATIONS MR HOLD. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
TWO TWO NINE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THE MEMBERS TAKEN
IN THE SENATE REQUIRE THE
APPROPRIATE USE OF FORCE
TRAINING TO BE CONDUCTED
THROUGH TRADITIONAL CLASSROOM
INSTRUCTION FOR A MINIMUM OF
FIFTY PERCENT. OF THE COURSE
AND THE BUILD NOW INCREASES
FINE AMOUNTS FOR SECURITY GUARD
OPERATORS WHO FAIL TO DELIVER A
WRITTEN REPORT TO THE BUREAU
SECURITY INVESTIGATION
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES
DESCRIBING THE CIRCUMSTANCES
SURROUNDING THE DISCHARGE OF
ANY FIREARM OR PHYSICAL
ALTERCATION WITH A MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC WHILE ON DUTY. I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANKS
HOLDEN SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM OF CLOTHING
ARE ALL. IS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS AND IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL RIGHT RESERVED. ZERO CLARK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEMS. SIXTEEN
THROUGH. EIGHTEEN THAT BRINGS
US TO FILE ITEM NINETEEN THIS
IS MISS CARILLO. BY THE
NINETEEN IS AB FOUR SIXTY TWO.
AND A CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR SIXTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO ENACTED INTO
HEALING ARTS. MS CARILLO YOU
MAY OPEN. YEAH YEAH. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS
BILL IS BACK IN CONCURRENCE AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. EGGMAN THRILLED SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CLARK
WELL OVER THE ROLE. JENNIFER.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIGN OF. FOR
TWELVE CLOSE THE ROLE TELL YOU
WHAT I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE BACK. TWO FIVE FOURTEEN.
IN THE CONCURRENT FILE THIS IS
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN. AB ONE OH
SEVEN COOKERY ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
OH SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SALAS AND OTHERS NOT GOING TO
LICENSURE AND MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR MISTER SALAS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB ONE
OH SEVEN IS BACK FOR CONCERNED
SENATE AMENDMENTS WERE
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING IN
NATURE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THEY WERE SALAS
SAYING NO DISCUSSION. CORPORAL
SANTA ROSA. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MY REFER.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS RECORD IN.
WE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN. THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN. THIS IS THE
CONCURRENCE FARMERS FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN AB THREE NINETY SIX.
OPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
NINETY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CABLE AND OTHERS BACK LIVE IN
THE COW FRESH MR GABRIEL. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB THREE
NINE SIX IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
AFTER RECEIVE UNITS FROM
SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. C. NOTIFICATION OR
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. THE SERVER ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS VOTE. WELL CLOSE ROLE
TIDE BUT I SIX SEVEN NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS WORKING
CURTAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN. AB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
BY MISS RAYOS CORKERY SOME
PEOPLE FOR THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS AND
OTHER SNACK LIVING TO SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES THIS PRESS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS. I
PRESENT AB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT A
PARITY BILL THE STANDARDIZES
THIS LAYOFF THE LAST PROCESS
EXTENDS HEARING RIGHTS. TO
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES SO THAT
THE SAME PROTOCOLS EXIST FOR
ALL SCHOOL EMPLOYEES THIS BILL
IS BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS TAKEN AT
THE SENATE DRESSY OPPOSITION
CONCERNS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
REYES NOTICE OR DEBATE I'M
SORRY. MR FONG YOUR RECOGNIZE.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT UNFORTUNATELY
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN AND THE
SENATE HAVE NOT REMOVED ANY OF
THE POSITIONS THAT I'VE THAT
I'VE I BELIEVE STILL SHARED THE
SENTIMENTS. THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE DISTRICTS PROVIDE
UNNECESSARY LAYOFF NOTICES FAR
IN ADVANCE OF WHEN THEY WERE
ACTUALLY KNOW THEIR STAFFING
NEEDS FOR THE NEXT YEAR. THE L.
A. O. HAS FOUND THIS
REQUIREMENT TO BE EXPENSIVE
BURDENSOME AND DETRIMENTAL FOR
EMPLOYEE MORALE UNCERTAINTY AND
A SCHOOLS WORKFORCE WILL CREATE
UNCERTAINTY IN THE CLASSROOM
WHEN WE NEED STABILITY MORE
THAN ANYTHING. OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE DOING EVERYTHING
THEY CAN TO HELP OUR CHILDREN
TO GET BACK ON TRACK AND ADDING
ANOTHER ROADBLOCK TO THE
RECOVERY WILL SET DISTRICTS
BACK ADMINISTRATIVELY AND
FINANCIALLY CREATING MORE
DIVISION IN OUR SCHOOLS IS NOT
ONLY BAD FOR STUDENTS WILL HOLD
SCHOOLS BACK FROM REGROUPING IN
THE WAKE. OF AN ALREADY
DETRIMENTAL YEAR I REGION ABOUT.
THIS DALY YOUR RECKLESS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I ALSO RISE
TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
FOUR THREE EIGHT. AS A FORMER
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER I AM
GREATLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES THIS WILL
HAVE ON OUR LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARDS. LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS ARE
INCREDIBLY DEPENDENT ON THE
STATE BUDGET AND THIS BILL
MANDATES SCHOOL DISTRICTS MUST
ACT UPON NEARLY 90% OF ITS
BUDGET THREE MONTHS BEFORE WE
EVEN ADOPTED OUR STATE BUDGET.
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC SCHOOL
DISTRICT FOR ALREADY FACING
DIFFICULT CHALLENGES. DECLINE
ENROLLMENT THE STATE'S LONG
TERM PROJECTED BUDGET DEFICIT
AND INCREASING PENSION COSTS
AND OTHER FISCAL IMPACTS. THIS
BILL ONLY ADDS TO DISTRICTS
PLATE A TIME WHEN WE ALREADY.
HAVE OUR OVERBURDENED. I URGE A
NO VOTE. THANK YOU MR ALLEY.
SAY NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
FOR DEBATE. THE CLUB WORLD.
MEMBERS RESERVE A ALL MEMBERS
OF THE- DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS FIRST IS THAT A VOTE.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
ICE FORTY NINE KNOWS THIRTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN. AB FOUR
FIFTY ONE CORKERY ASSEMBLY GO
FOR FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA AND EXPLAIN TO
HEALTH FACILITIES DR ARAMBULA
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB FOUR FIFTY ONE IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS SENATE AMENDMENTS WE
HAVE REMOVED OPPOSITION FROM C.
SACK AS WELL AS THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS YESTERDAY
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SIR SAY
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. CORPORAL
OF THE ROLE. IS THAT A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. WE
HAVE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM.
NINETEEN THERE WAS WARY FIVE
TWENTY AB FIVE ONE FIVE.
CORKERY SOME PEOPLE FIVE
FIFTEEN BY SIN REMEMBER CHEN
ACCORDING TO TRESPASS DR CHECK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
FIVE ONE FIVE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER AYE VOTE. FOETIDA CAN SEE
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IS THAT A VOTE
ALL MEMBERS MEMBERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE I SEVEN NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN.
EVERSEN FOWLER
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE AB
FIVE TO SIX CORKERY. SOME
PEOPLE FIVE TWENTY SIX MONTHS
MEMBER WOULD PACOIMA HEALING
ARTS THE CLEARLY TO SEE THEIR
UP THE CORRECT IMMEDIATELY. DR
WOOD THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB FIVE TWENTY SIX IS
BEFORE YOUR CONCURRENCE WITH
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
TO NUMBER ONE AD BAXEEN COURSE
OFFERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PHARMACY ASSOCIATION TO THE
COURSES AVAILABLE FOR
CONTINUING EDUCATION CREDITS
FOR DENTISTS AND PODIATRISTS.
AND IT ALSO CONTAINS SOME
CHAPTER IN THAT CHAPTER NOT
AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ABOUT. THANK THAT WOULD
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM BURKE LIBERAL. ESERVER
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
WELL. CLOSE ROLE TYLER I SEVEN
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY TWO AB FIVE TWENTY SEVEN.
CORRECTION WE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TO THAT ITEM. WE ARE
FOLLOWED TWENTY THREE. AB FIVE
THIRTY TWO. CORRECT ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD NOT CLEAR
HEALTHCARE BILLING DOCTOR WHAT
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB FIVE THIRTY TO
PROVIDE SPECIFIC TIME FRAMES
FOR HOSPITALS PROVIDE PATIENTS
WITH INFORMATION ABOUT OPTIONS
FOR CHARITY CARE AND PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE A LINK TO A LIST OF
THE HOSPITALS SHOPPABLE PRICES
FOR VARIOUS SERVICES AND THE
INTERNET ADDRESS OF AN
ORGANIZATION WILL HELP PATIENTS
NAVIGATE THE PAYMENT AND BILL
PROCESS THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ADDED THAT THE LIST OF
SHOPPABLE SERVICES MINOR
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
CHAPTER NOT LANGUAGE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. C. NOTIFICATION AVE. THE
CLUB LAUREL. DESERVE IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. DESIRABLE. CLICK
WELL CLOSE ROLE TO BUT I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO SAN I'M
IN ARE CONCURRED IN. THIS IS
FILE I TWENTY FOUR A. B. FIVE
SO ONE BY MISTER MAY TO CARPOOL.
SYMBOL FOR SEVENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES AND
ACCIDENT HOUSING MISTER MESS
THANK SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS BILL
BY ON CONCUR IN WAS A MENACE TO
PRINT CAPTURING OUT ISSUES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I. C
NOTICED. OR DEBATE ON THE ADAM.
CARPOOL OF MORAL. IS THAT OF A
ALL MEMBER VOTERS AND VOTE. ALL
MEMBER VOTERS ARE A. WELL CLOSE
ROLE TO ABOUT I NO ZERO SENATE
AMEND WORKING. IN FILE ORDER
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY FIVE. A. B. SIX OH TWO
BY MR GRAYSON THE CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX OH TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON AND
OTHERS AND ACKLINGTON LAND USE
MR GRAYSON. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SOME OF THOSE SIX ZERO
TWO IS BACK FROM SAN ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS WERE
TECHNICAL NATURE BILL HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I'VE-
THANK S. GRAYSON. C.
NOTIFICATION DEBATE CORPORATE.
ALL MEMBERS FOR THEIR VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS REPRESENTATIVE OF. WELL
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWENTY SIX AB EIGHT
SEVENTEEN. CORKERY SYMBOL EIGHT
SEVENTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER
WOULD AND OTHER SNACK WITHIN
THE SPORTFISHING DOCTOR WHITE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS IS A BILL HAS BEEN
TEN YEARS IN THE MAKING SO
THANK YOU TO STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO PUT COUNTLESS
HOURS INTO THIS ISSUE OVER THE
PAST DECADE. CURRENTLY ANNUAL
SPORTFISHING LICENSES EXPIRE ON
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
REGARDLESS OF WHEN THE AYE WHEN
THE LICENSE WAS PURCHASED THIS
BILL WOULD INSTEAD AUTHORIZED
THE DEPARTMENT TO MAKE LICENSE
IS VALID FOR A YEAR FROM THE
DATE OF PURCHASE JUST LIKE YOUR
CAR REGISTRATION THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN BILL AND HAS HAD NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ABOUT. THANK YOU WOULD
MISTER FLORA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR TAKING THIS BILL
ON A- ARE THERE CENTER FROM OUR
AREA TRY TO RUN THIS BILL FOR
MANY MANY YEARS US IN OUR
BERRYHILL. THIS WAS SOMETHING
HE WAS INCREDIBLY PASSIONATE
ABOUT. SO IT'S AWESOME THAT WE
CONTINUE IN THIS THING AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET IT DONE I
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THIS. THANK
YOU MISTER FLOOR SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
JEFF WHEN YOU MAY CLOSE WE WISH
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD. CLICK
LIBERAL. THE DESIRABLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM. ALL
MEMBERS WERE THERE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ALL TIED UP I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SEVEN MM AND
SPARKING CURTIS. HIS FATHER
TWENTY SEVEN AB EIGHT FORTY
FOUR. PERFORATE SOME LEGAL AID
FORTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON AND OTHERS TACKLING TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. MR GRAY SAID
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SOME
ABILITY FORTY FOURS BACK FROM-
SENATE ON CONCURRENCE- MINUTES
WERE TECHNICAL NATURE AND
SIMPLY ASKING FOR AN IPHONE
THANK YOU. C. NOTIFICATION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL. OUT OF VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS REPRESENTATIVE OF CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLL. TIDE BUT I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS. R. CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM. TWENTY EIGHT
AB NINE FIFTY FIVE BY DOCTOR
QUIRK. CORRECT SOME PEOPLE NINE
FIFTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK AND ACCORDING TO HIGHWAYS.
DR CORK. THANK YOU SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS AB NINE FIFTY FIVE
WHICH SIMPLY REQUIRE CALTRANS
TO NOTIFY. RUTSCHMAN PERMIT
APPLICANTS OF ALL APPLICATION
REQUIREMENTS SAID A THIRTY DAY
MILESTONE TO VERIFY THE
APPLICATION IS COMPLETE AND
CLARIFY THAT CALTRANS WILL ACT
AS THE LEAD AGENCY FOR THE
SEQUEL PROCESS IN THE EVENT
THAT KNOW WHETHER LOCAL AGENCY
TAKES THE ROLE. THESE
IMPROVEMENTS- TO THE CALTRANS
ENCROACHMENT PERMITTING PROCESS
WILL MAKE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE MORE
EFFICIENT HELP TO ADDRESS THE
BROADER DIGITAL DIVIDE I ASK
THE ARRIVAL THANK YOU. THANK
THAT QUICK SCENE NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ADAM CLERK
WILL OVER THERE ALL. THIS
ADVERT ALL MEMBERS REPRESENT
ABOUT. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SEVENTY NO ZERO. SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA BE RETURNING
THE SENATE BILLS AT THIS TIME
THIS IS SENATE THIRD READING
RETURNING TO SENATE. THIRD
READING.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO RESUME THE PRIOR FILE ORDER
WHEN WE'RE ON SENATE THIRD I
BELIEVE WE'RE A FILE ITEM
NINETY THREE. FILE ITEM NINETY
THREE. IS S. B. TWENTY EIGHT.
CORPORATE SENATE BILL TWENTY
EIGHT BY CENTER CABALLERO AND
OTHERS NOT QUITE IN THE
COMMUNICATIONS. MR SALIHU
MAILED WITH. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SB TWENTY EIGHT STATES
THE DIGITAL INFRASTRUCTURE
VIDEO COMPETITION ACT HI THIS
BILL WILL HELP CLOSE
CALIFORNIA'S DIGITAL DIVIDE
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU MICHELLE SAY NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF THOSE. ALL
MEMBERS WERE THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE A ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY ONE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NINETY FOUR SB FORTY
ONE CORPORATE. SENATE BILL
FORTY ONE BY SENATOR UMBERG AND
OTHERS BACK LETTING THE PRIVACY
MR GABRIEL. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ON BEHALF OF SENATOR ON
BURKE I RISE TO PRESENT SB
FORTY ONE AND THE GENETIC
INFORMATION PRIVACY ACT THIS
BILL WOULD STRENGTHEN CONSUMER
CONTROL OVER THE GENETIC
MATERIAL. THEY PROVIDE TO
DIRECT TO CONSUMER TESTING
COMPANIES SB FORTY ONE WOULD
REQUIRE A COMPANY TO OBTAIN
CONSUMER CONSENT BEFORE USING
THIS DATA FOR ANY PURPOSE THIS
MEASURE WILL CODIFY BRYCE
PRACTICES AND GIVE CALIFORNIANS
CONFIDENCE THAT THEY CAN
PROVIDE GENETIC DATA TO THESE
COMPANIES WITHOUT WERE HAVING
TO WORRY THE THIRD PARTIES
MAKES BLIGHTED. THIS BILL
SUPPORTED BY CONSUMER AND
PRIVACY ADVOCATES RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS AND LEADERS WITHIN
THE GENETIC TESTING INDUSTRY
RECENT CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS
HAVE REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU RISK APRIL SAME
NOTIFICATION DEBATE. CLERK WILL
OPEN RURAL. THAT A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE TO DECIDE ABOUT.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE WHAT I
THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS THIS IS
FILE ITEM NINETY FIVE SB FIFTY.
CORKERY SENATE BILL FIFTY BISON
RIDLEY MON AND OTHERS THAT WILL
BE TO EARLY LEARNING AND CARE
MISTER MCCARTY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AT THIS MEASURE IS A
FOLLOW UP TO OUR AMAZING STATE
BUDGET RELATED TO EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANDING ACCESS TO A
PRE K. AND CHILD CARE- THIS C.
SENSUALLY WILL EXPAND.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARENTS AND
PROVIDERS TO SEAMLESSLY GET OUR
YOUNGSTERS IN OUR STATE
SUBSIDIZED PROGRAMS WILL MAKE
CHANGES FOCUSING ON INCREASED
ELIGIBILITY IN ACCESS AND
FRANKLY MAKE IT EASIER FOR
FAMILIES TO ENROLL AND STAY
ENROLLED IN OUR STATE
SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE PROGRAMS
AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS ASPEN
ARRIVAL. THANK YOU. THANK
GOODNESS MCCARTY SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CORP LIBERAL. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF UP I. SEVENTY TWO. NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. WE
ARE GOING TO PASS A RETAINER
FILE ITEMS NINETY SEVEN AND.
NINETY EIGHT- I'M JUST
FOLLOWING DIRECTIONS UP HERE
OKAY. WE'RE FILE ITEM NINETY
NINE. THIS IS SB SIXTY NINE
CORRECT. SENATE BILL SIXTY NINE
BY SENATOR MCGUIRE AND ACKLIN
IN THE TRANSPORTATION DR WOULD
YOU MAIL THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS THIS IS A FOLLOW UP
BILL TO THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ACT THAT SET THE STAGE
TO TRANSITION TO A THREE
HUNDRED PLUS MILE MOSTLY
DILAPIDATED INOPERATIVE RAIL
LINE IN MY DISTRICT IN A WORLD
CLASS RAIL SYSTEM THAT RUNS TO
SOME A WHILE THIS MOST SCENIC
LANDSCAPES IN THE UNITED
STATES. BEEN GREAT PROGRESS ON
THIS HISTORIC PROJECT THE TO
YOUR STATE LED AUDIT IS
COMPLETE MAJORITY OF DATA'S
BEEN PAID ASSETS HAVE BEEN
TRANSFERRED IN THE FORMER WIND
DOWN OF THE NORTH COAST REAL
AUTHORITY IS WELL UNDER WAY SB
SIXTY NINE TRANSITIONS AND C.
R. A. INTO THE GREAT REDWOOD
TRAIL AGENCY. WHICH WILL ASSUME
ALL REMAINING ASSETS IN
RESPONSIBILITIES AND COMPLETE
THE PROCESS OF PLANNING AND
BUILDING THEIR PORTION. OF THE
TRAIL THROUGH MENDOCINO TRINITY
AND HUMBOLDT COUNTY'S. CHAU
BECOME THE LONGEST RAIL TRAIL
IN AMERICA. IS A WIN WIN FOR
THE STATE AND NORTH COAST
COMMUNITIES SB SIXTY NINE HAS
RECEIVED BROAD PIPE. BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. DAVID EDWARD C.
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. GLOBAL
CHARITABLE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES PASSERINE
CAMP OUT OF ONE HUNDRED THROUGH.
ONE OH TWO. THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE OH THREE. FILE ITEM ONE OF
THREE SB TWO FORTY ONE. CORRECT
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR- BURKE AND ACT LEADING
TO CIVIL ACTIONS MR STONE.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SB TWO FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR- BURKE IS A BILL TO
ADDRESS A NUMBER OF THE ISSUES
WITH THE COURTS AND THE COURT
PROCESSES THAT HAVE COME UP
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC. THIS IS A
BILL THAT WILL ALLOW FOR REMOTE
HEARINGS AND CLEANS UP A NUMBER
OF THE ASPECTS NEEDED RIGHT NOW
TO BE ABLE TO MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD. THIS IS SUPPORTED BY
THE JUDGES AND BY THE DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS AND BY. PLAINTIFFS
ATTORNEYS IT'S SUPPORTED BY.
REPORTERS AND BY INTERPRETERS
S. C. A. YOU HAD SOME STRUGGLES
WITH THIS BUT BT HAVE RECENTLY
GONE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL THEY
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. SO RIGHT NOW THERE
IS NO OPPOSITION THIS IS THE
WAY THAT THE COURTS NEED. ED
GUIDANCE FROM US TO MOVE
FORWARD SB TWO FORTY ONE IS
THAT GUIDANCE FROM US AND I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
MISSED SOME. SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. SEVERAL MEMBERS VOTERS AT
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF. THE WELL. ZERO SHY THAT I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WHERE IT FIVE
OUT OF ONE OH FOUR SB TWO FORTY
TWO CORKERY SENATE BILL TWO
FORTY TWO BY SENATOR NEWMAN AND
OTHERS NOT GOING TO HEALTH CARE
MYSTERY OF US THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- SO DURING A FUTURE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY THIS
LEGISLATION SB TWO FOUR TWO.
WOULD REQUIRE HEALTH INSURERS
TO REIMBURSE HEALTH CARE- SO
PROVIDERS FOR COSTS RELATED TO
THE PROCUREMENT OF CRITICAL
SAFETY SUPPLIES SUCH AS PP AN
INFECTION CONTROL MATERIALS.
DURING THE COPA NINETY PANDEMIC
SPENDING ON P. B. E. INCREASED
50% IN SOME CASES GREATER THAN
50% FOR PROVIDERS EVEN AS
PATIENT VOLUME AND REVENUE
DECREASED SMALL AND MEDIUM
SIZED- THE PRACTICES. WERE
FORCED TO LAY OFF STAFF OR EVEN
CLOSE OUR OPERATIONS THIS BILL
RESOLVE THAT ISSUE BY ENSURING
THAT- THESE CLINICS. THE PP AND
RELATED COSTS ARE COVERED BY
INSURANCE RECENT AMENDMENTS ARE
REMOVED OPPOSITION FROM
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLANS
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS REAVIS.
SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION DEBATE
FOR POPULAR ALL. HE SAID ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AT ABOUT.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FORTY FIVE KNOWS NINE. THE
MEASURE PASSES PAST RETAIN A
BOTTOM ONE OH FIVE THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE OF SIX. S. B. TWO
SIXTY THREE CORRECT SENATE BILL
TWO SIXTY THREE BY CENTER RUBIO
AND OTHERS FACULTY TO HELP REAL
ESTATE. MS GARCIA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS SB TWO
SIXTY THREE WILL HELP AND THE
HOME OWNERSHIP GAP FOR PEOPLE
OF COLOR IN CALIFORNIA VERY
CRYING REAL ESTATE
PROFESSIONALS TO TAKE IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING AS PART OF THEIR
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR GARCIA SEEN
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS REPRESENTATIVE OF.
THE BURKE WELL. THE CLOSER ROLE.
HOWEVER I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE OF SEVEN SB TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN. CORPORATION SENATE BILL
TWO EIGHTY SEVEN BY CENTER
GROVE AND ACCLIMATE TO VEHICLES
MR LOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
SPEAKING COLLEAGUES SB TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN FOCUS ON THE
CONSOLIDATION OF RECREATIONAL
TRAILERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. SENIOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM SEVERAL OF
THE ROLE. THAT OF THOSE. ALL
MEMBERS LETTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. CLARK
WELL. CLOSER ALL TYLER I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO TOGGLE BACK TO.
CONCURRENCE. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO THE CONCURRENCE
FILE. WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
FIVE ALIVE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO THIS
IS AB. THREE THIRTY THREE.
ACCORDING ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THIRTY THREE BY FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KAMLAGER ANAK
LEADING THE CRIMINAL GANGS DR
WEBER EMAIL. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB THREE THREE
THREE THE STEP FORWARD ACT BY
SENATOR COM LONGER WHICH SEEKS
TO BRING DUE PROCESS TO OUR
GANG ENHANCEMENT STATUTE. OUR
STATE GANG ENHANCEMENTS ARE
ROCKED WITH PROSECUTORIAL OVER
REACH. IF THAT OVERREACH WASN'T
SO WIDESPREAD WE WOULDN'T BE
HERE TODAY. AND THIS BILL WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN INCLUDED IN THE
VERY FIRST ROUND OF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR REFORM BY
THE CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE ON THE
REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE.
LET'S START WITH THEM DATA.
GANG ENHANCEMENTS ARE USED
DISPROPORTIONATELY AGAINST
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND HAVE
RESULTED IN HARMFUL SYSTEMIC
CRIMINALIZATION OF INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES CULTURES AND
COMMUNITIES. 92% OF PEOPLE WITH
GANG ENHANCEMENTS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR. NOTABLY
THERE IS NO EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE
THAT GANG ENHANCEMENTS HAVE
BEEN EFFECTIVE AT REDUCING
CRIME OR PROTECTING COMMUNITIES.
BUT THERE IS DATA THAT SHOWS
THAT LONGER SENTENCES DO NOT
MAKE US SAFER. OUR GANG
ENHANCEMENT STATUE HAS VAGUE
DEFINITIONS WEEK SANDERS
APPROVED AND ARE PERHAPS THE
MOST RACIALLY DISCRIMINATORY
PART OF OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. AB THREE THREE THREE IS
MERELY A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. WE ABSOLUTELY MUST
GO MUCH FURTHER IF WE WANT TO
PRESERVE ANY SENSE OF JUSTICE
AND OUR CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM.
AT ITS CORE THIS BILL IS REALLY
ABOUT DUE PROCESS. IT IS TIME
FOR US TO STOP RELYING ON
ARCANE AND HARMFUL TOOLS LIKE
FEAR BIAS. AND STEREO TYPES AND
DEMAND THAT PROSECUTORS PROVE
THE CHARGES THAT THEY LEVY
AGAINST SOMEONE. AB THREE THREE
THREE MAKE CHANGES TO THE LAW
THAT WILL REDUCE PROSECUTORIAL
OVERREACH BY MAKING THE
STANDARDS FOR APPLYING A GANG
ENHANCEMENT EVER SO SLIGHTLY
MORE RIGOROUS. THIS BILL DOES
NOT MAKE THE APPLICATION OF
GANG ENHANCEMENT IMPOSSIBLE. I
WILL RESTATE THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT MAKE THE APPLICATION
OF GANG ENHANCEMENT IMPOSSIBLE.
RATHER IT REQUIRES THAT
SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE BE PROVIDED
IN ORDER TO PROVE THAT THE
UNDERLYING OFFENSE WAS ACTUALLY
COMMITTED ON BEHALF OF THE GANG.
THE SENSIBLE CHANGES WILL
ENSURE THAT GANG ENHANCEMENTS
ARE APPLIED TO ONLY THEMOST
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT OFFENSES.
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS THE AUTHOR HAS TAKEN
SEVERAL AMENDMENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE. SOME
TAKEN DIRECTLY FROM THE
OPPOSITION AND OTHERS THAT
REPRESENT A MIDDLE GROUND TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CORE
CONCERNS STATED BY THE
OPPOSITION. IN THE SENATE SHE
HAS ADDED BACK THE PREDICATE
OFFENCE OF BURGLARY. QUALIFIED
ELIMINATES THE DEFINITION OF
QUOTE BENEFIT MORE THAN
REPUTATIONAL BY PROVIDING A
LIST OF EXAMPLES OF WHAT A
COMMON BENEFIT THAT IS MORE
THAN REPUTATIONAL MAY INCLUDE.
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE NOT
ACCEPTED FOR THOSE THAT WERE
VAGUE AND RAISE VALID CONCERNS
THAT WOULD HAVE WATERED THE
BILL DOWN TO SUCH AN EXTENT.
THAT WOULD NO LONGER RETAIN ITS
ORIGINAL INTENT. LET ME BE
CLEAR. ONCE AGAIN AB THREE
THREE THREE DOES NOT END GANG
ENHANCEMENT. IT DOES NOT IMPACT
THE LIVES OF GANG ENHANCEMENT
AND IT DOES NOT PREVENT STREET
LEVEL POLICE INVESTIGATIONS.
IT'S SIMPLY ASK PROSECUTORS TO
PROVE THE GANG CHARGES BROUGHT
AGAINST SOMEONE. IN OTHER WORDS
IT ASKED PROSECUTORS TO DO
THEIR JOB. THE SAME ARGUMENTS
USED PRIOR TO PROVE A GANG
ENHANCEMENT CAN STILL BE USE SO
AS LONG AS THEY ARE GERMANE TO
THE CHARGE. BY ADDRESSING
SEVERAL DAMAGING EFFECTS OF
QUOTE GANG EVIDENCE AND QUOTE
AND TRY AT TRIAL AND NARROWING
THE APPLICABILITY OF SUCH
EVIDENCE. AB THREE THREE THREE
TAKES AN IMPORTANT STEP FOR IT
AT I'M DOING SOME OF THE HARM
CAUSED BY CURRENT GANG
ENHANCEMENT STATUES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR
WERE MISTER KALRA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE THREE
THIS STEP TOWARD ACT BY SENATOR
TOM LOGGER. OF N. AS OUR
COLLEAGUE SAN DIEGO STATE IS ON
A CALM WATER. SPENT A LOT OF
ENERGY AND TIME TO MAKE SURE
THAT APPROPRIATE AMENDMENTS
HAVE BEEN MADE OF THE THAT-
INSURE. THAT THIS IS GOING TO
CLAMOR PROCESS BUT ALSO THAT
THE BILL. IS STILL MEANINGFUL
IN TERMS OF ITS GOALS. WE KNOW
THAT BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED. BY
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
NOWHERE. IS THAT MORE APPARENT.
THEM OF GANG ENHANCEMENTS. OUR
CURRENT GAME HAS TO STATUTES
HAVE BIG DEFINITIONS WEEK
STANDARDS APPROVED. WHAT'S THE
MOST RACIALLY DISCRIMINATORY
PART. OF OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM I'VE SEEN IT FIRSTHAND
DURING MY TIME AS A PUBLIC
DEFENDER. AND AS OP WE POINTED
OUT BY A COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO 92% OF PEOPLE GETTING HAS
TO CALIFORNIA. OF COLOR AND
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO EMPIRICAL
EVIDENCE THAT GANG ENHANCEMENT
LAWS ARE EFFECTIVE IN CURBING
VIOLENCE OR MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER. BY
ADDRESSING SEVERAL DAMAGING
EFFECTS OF GETTING EVIDENCE THE
TRIAL AND NARROWING THE
APPLICABILITY OF SUCH EVIDENCE
AB THREE THIRTY THREE TAKES AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARD UNDOING
SOME OF THE HARM CAUSED BY
CURRENT. GAME HAS BEEN STATUTES
AB THREE THIRTY THREE IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD TOWARDS
A MORE EQUITABLE JUSTICE SYSTEM
WHICH STILL IS ALLOW. A ALLOWS
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO DO THEIR
JOB THE KEEPING OUR COMMUNITY
SAFE OUR RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON SEVEN
AMENDMENTS. THE FAMOUS KALRA
MISTER BRYANT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES. GOT A
RUNNING JOKE THE BLACK CAUCUS.
WILL BE THREE OF US IN THE
HALLWAY. OR THREE OF US IN THE
MEMBERS LOUNGE OR THREE WAS AT
THE AIRPORT WHEN YOU GET ON A
PLANE. AND WE'LL JOKES. WATCH
OUT WE WILL GET IN TROUBLE. IT
WAS A FUNNY JOKE BECAUSE IN
THIS BUILDING WILL LEGISLATIVE
MISTAKE WITH LEGISLATIVE. BUT
THAT JOKE IS ROOTED IN THE
REALITY IN OUR COMMUNITY. AND
THAT REALITY IS THAT IF YOU
LIVE IN A GANG INJUNCTION ZONE.
AND THREE OF YOU ARE ON THE
CORNER. YOU CAN BE PICKED UP.
AND YOU CAN BE PUT ON THE GAME
DATABASE. AND THEN YOU CAN HAVE
GANG ENHANCEMENTS GOING ON TO
EVERY SINGLE MISTAKE THAT YOU
MAKE FOR THE REST OF YOUR LIFE.
WHERE YOU'RE FROM AND WHAT YOU
LOOK LIKE. MCCAMLEY FROM SAN
DIEGO SAID THAT GANG
ENHANCEMENTS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY USED. ALL
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. I WOULD
ARGUE THAT THE DATA BEING
NINETY TWO PERCENT. GETTING
ENHANCEMENTS ARE ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY USED ONLY ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. IT'S A
RACES FEATURE OF OUR CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM THAT IS ROOTED. IN
A VERY COMPLICATED HISTORY OF
BLACK BROWN PORN INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES. AND WHAT THIS BILL.
DOESN'T DO. IS SOMETHING I
THINK WE SHOULD TALK ABOUT IN
THE FUTURE WHICH IS GET RID OF
GANG ENHANCEMENTS ALL TOGETHER.
ALL IT DOES IS RAISE THE
THRESHOLD. THAT PROSECUTORS
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE PLANE
THAT I BELONG TO A GANG AND
THEN I WAS IN A BLACK
LEGISLATOR IN HIS DISTRICT AND
WITH THREE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY AND AGAIN IT HAPPENS
ALL. THE WE GOTTA BE MINDFUL WE
PASS THIS BILL OUT OF THIS BODY
ALREADY. WE SENT TO OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE THEY
SENT IT BACK TO ITS MARKET
CURRENT. LET'S DO THE RIGHT
THING FOR THE TO THE GOVERNOR.
MR STONE. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
REMEMBERS HIS BODY TALKS QUITE
A BIT. ABOUT HOW WE CAN ROOT
OUT SOME OF THE SYSTEMIC RACISM
BUILT INTO. THE STATUTES AND-
PROCESSES THAT WE HAVE. GETTING
ENHANCEMENTS IS A VERY VERY.
CLEAR OPPORTUNITY TO TRY AND
GET AT THE HEART OF IT. THE
DATABASE THAT IS USED TO
COMMUNITIES THAT. GETTING HAND
SPENCER USED IN. ARE GREAT
EXAMPLES. OF THE DIS. FUNCTION
OF THE WAY THAT THE SYSTEM HAS
BEEN SET UP. WELL DOCUMENTED
PROBLEMS WITH WITH THE DATABASE
PEOPLE ON IT WHO'S NEVER SHOULD
OFFEND PEOPLE WHO CAN'T GET OFF
OF IT AND THOSE THAT DRIVES
SOME OF THE ENHANCEMENTS WE
HAVE GOT. TO DRILL DOWN INTO
OUR STATUTORY PROCESSES AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
JUSTICE ON AN EQUITABLE LEVEL.
THE POLICE YOUTH IN MY
COMMUNITY WHO DEAL WITH GANGS
QUITE A BIT AND ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT GANGS THEY
KNOW. THAT THOSE COMMUNITIES
ARE FRUSTRATED WITH THE
INEQUITABLE APPLICATION OF OUR
LAWS GANG ENHANCEMENTS ARE A
KEY INEQUITABLE APPLICATION OF
OUR LAWS. AND THEY DON'T END UP
WITH SAFER COMMUNITIES THEY
CREATE MORE STRIFE ECONOMIC
STRESS AND OTHER STRESSES IN
THE COMMUNITIES THEN THEY
BENEFITS. THIS BILL IN FACT
DOES NOT GO ANYWHERE NEAR AS
FAR AS THE PENAL CODE REVISION
COMMISSION ASKED TO GO AND MANY
OF US ON THIS FLOOR TODAY THINK
THIS BILL DOES NOT GO. REALLY
AS FAR AS IT NEEDS TO GO BUT I
APPLAUD THE SENATOR FOR WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND WORKING
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS
TO TRY TO CRAFT SOMETHING THAT
CAN MOVE THAT HOPEFULLY DOES
MOVE. TODAY WITH YOUR
CONCURRENCE IN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS THIS BILL HAS BEEN
NARROWED DOWN TRYING TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES THAT THE OPPOSITION
HAVE WITHOUT ACTUALLY GETTING.
WHAT THIS BILL IT IS
A MINOR STEP FORWARD BUT A STEP
FORWARD THAT IS NECESSARY I ASK
FOR YOUR IBM. MISS BURKE QUE
HAN YOUR REDLANDS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER WHEN THIS BILL
WAS ON OUR FLOOR FIRST TIME. I
STOOD UP AND I SPOKE ABOUT WHAT
IT MEANS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM TO WORK. THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS FOUNDED ON
THE NOTION THAT SOMEBODY WHO IS
FOUND GUILTY IS FOUND GUILTY
BEYOND ANY REASONABLE DOUBT. WE
MAKE THE JUROR OF PROSECUTORS
HARD INTENTIONALLY WE DO NOT
WANT TO TAKE FREEDOM AWAY FROM
INDIVIDUALS. IN LESS WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY SURE THEY'VE
COMMITTED THE CRIME WITH WHICH
THEY ARE CHARGED. THEIR
INNOCENT TILL PROVEN GUILTY.
AND YET WE HAVE THIS ELEMENT OF
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IN
THE GANG ENHANCEMENT. IN WHICH
WE ARE WILLING TO TAKE AWAY. AT
TIMES MORE THAN A DECADE OF
SOMEONE'S LIFE WITHOUT MEETING
THAT LOFTY BURDEN. MEMBERS I
DON'T KNOW ANYBODY ON THIS
FLOOR WHO BELIEVES IN THE
AMERICAN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. CAN BELIEVE THAT IS
JUST OR RIGHT. THIS IS A SIMPLE
BILL THAT SAYS IF YOU ARE
TAKING SOMEONE'S YEARS AWAY
FROM THEM YOU ARE DENYING THEM
THE FREEDOM THEY DESERVE DUE
PROCESS. AND ALL OF US TOOK AN
OATH TO UPHOLD THE CONSTITUTION
AND I BELIEVE THAT IS WHAT WE
ARE DOING HERE TODAY. BY
ENSURING THE DUE PROCESS IS IN
THAT. BUT I WANT TO ADD AS WELL
WE'VE HEARD FROM SEVERAL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WHICH IS NOT ONLY
WITH THIS BILL REASONABLE WHEN
IT PASSED THROUGH FIRST TIME IN
ENSURING THAT. BUT THE AUTHOR
IS GOING FURTHER SHE IS FURTHER
AMENDED THE BILL SINCE WE SAW
THE FIRST TIME. MANY OF US
HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION WE
COULD NEVER MEET THE STANDARD
REPUTATIONAL HARM. AND IN THE
NEW VERSION OF THE BILL SHE
CLARIFY SPECIFICALLY THE MANY
OF THE INSTANCES THAT ARE
PROSECUTORS WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT QUALIFIES REPUTATIONAL
HARM. SHE HAS ENSURED THAT
WHERE A GANG ENHANCEMENT MAY BE
APPROPRIATE IT CAN BE POSSIBLE.
IF THE PROSECUTOR MEETS THE
BURDEN THE BURDEN THAT THEY
SHOULD MEET EVERY SINGLE TIME
THEY DENY SOMEONE THEIR
FREEDOM. AND WITHOUT ASTER I
VOTE. MISTER OF MEMBERS OF
YOU'D LIKE PARTICIPATE PLEASE
YOUR MICROPHONES NOW. MS
BERNARD AFTER RECOGNIZE. YES
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I ROSE A
COUPLE MONTHS AGO AND ASKED US
TO GIVE THE SENATOR. TIME TO
WORK ON THIS BILL AND ADDRESS
THE ISSUES OF THE OPPOSITION.
SHE'S NOT TO ADDRESS ALL THE
ISSUES OF THE OPPOSITION BUT
SHE HAS ADDRESSED THE IMPORTANT
ONES I LIKE TO REFER TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ARANDA. THERE IS
THE FAIRNESS OF SYSTEM THAT WE
HAVE TO ENSURE AND IF WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE AWAY YEARS OF
PEOPLE'S LIFE. I THINK IT'S-
IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT
PROSECUTORS NEED TO PROVE THAT
THERE'S A CRIMINAL STREET GANG
EXISTS. AND THAT THIS PERSON
WAS A PART OF IT IN ORDER TO
GET A ST GETTING ENHANCEMENT. I
FEEL LIKE SHE'S DONE WHAT SHE
NEEDED TO DO I UNDERSTAND THE
OPPOSITION WILL NOT BE HAPPY
WITH ANY AMENDMENTS. THAT WILL
CHANGE THIS BUT I THINK SHE'S
DONE HER DUE DILIGENCE SHE'S
AFTER. SHE'S DONE WHAT I AFTER
TO DO AND WITHOUT- DR- I CAN
NEVER SAY NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ON THE
ITEM DR WEBER YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'D
LIKE TO THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO STOOD UP AND
ADDRESSED AND SPOKEN. IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TODAY-
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES STATED. WE TOOK A VERY
BOLD STEP A FEW MONTHS AGO BY
PASSING AND GETTING THIS BILL
OFF THE FLOOR AND SENDING IT TO
THE SENATE. LET'S CONTINUE BY
VOTING AND I AM SENDING IT TO
THE GOVERNOR SO THAT HE CAN
SIGN IT INTO LAW. AND WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU. WITH THAT
PURPLE OF NARAL. WHAT IS THAT
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THOSE. ALL MEMBERS ARE
DESIRABLE.
DR WEBER. MOVES A
CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
BACK TO THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE. WE'RE GOING BACK
TO SENATE THIRD READING. IN THE
PREVIOUS FILE ORDER FILE ITEMS
ONE AWAY TO ONE OH NINE PASS
AND RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE TEN. SB THREE TEN CORKERY
SENATE BILL THREE TEN BIASA
RUBIO AND OTHERS GENETICALLY
THE PUBLIC HEALTH THIS BURKE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY
I AM PROUD TO PRESENT SB THREE
TEN A CRITICAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT WILL HELP SAVE
THE LIVES OF CANCER PATIENTS
ACROSS THE STATE. THIS BILL
CREATES A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM
THAT ALLOW CANCER PATIENTS TO
DONATE THEIR UNUSED MEDICATION
TO PATIENTS IN NEED THROUGH
THEIR CERTIFIED PHYSICIAN
RECENT AMENDMENTS WERE IN
RESPONSE TO THE CONCERN FROM
THE BOARD OF PHARMACY AND
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR SEEING NO
DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM. PURPLE OF MORAL ALL
MEMBERS. IS THAT A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS REPRESENT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS AT ABOUT. WELL
THOSE ARE ALL TIED UP I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
ELEVEN. SB THREE THIRTY EIGHT.
THIS IS MISS CARILLO CORKERY
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY EIGHT
BY SOONER GONZALEZ AND OTHERS
ARE NOT GOING TO PRIVATE
EMPLOYMENT. MYSTERY L. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR LENA GONZALEZ
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL THREE
THREE EIGHT WHICH WILL HELP
PROTECT THE CENTRAL FRONT MY
TRUCK DRIVERS AT CALIFORNIA
PORTS. PORT TRUCK DRIVERS HAVE
BEEN A TORY ASLI EXPLOITED BY
BAD ACTORS IN THE TRUCKING
INDUSTRY THESE BAD ACTORS
ROUTINELY MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS
TO CUT COSTS WRONGFULLY EXCLUDE
WORKERS FOR MINIMUM WAGE
WORKERS COMPENSATION AND THE
RIGHT TO JOIN A UNION. SB THREE
THREE EIGHT ADDRESSES THIS
ONGOING PROBLEM BY ADDING
TRUCKING COMPANIES TO AN
EXISTING JOINT LIABILITY BAD
ACTOR LIST OF THOSE COMPANIES
ROUTINELY MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS
IN ADDITION PRIOR TO BEING
REMOVED OFF THE LIST SB THREE
THREE EIGHT WILL ALSO REQUIRE A
BAD ACTOR COMPANIES TO
CERTIFIED AND PROVIDE PROOF. TO
THE DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT THAT THEY HAVE
FIXED THE UNDERLYING PROBLEM
THAT PUT THEM ON THE BAD ACTORS
LIST IN THE FIRST PLACE I HAVE
WORKED WE HAVE WORKED CLOSELY
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND STATE
AGENCIES TO ENSURE THAT THIS
BILL IS. IMPLEMENTABLE AND
NARROW ENOUGH TO APPLY TO ONLY
AND TRULY THE BAD ACTING
COMPANIES TRUCK DRIVERS ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO ARE
CRITICAL PLAYERS IN SUPPORTING
THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND THEY
DESERVE STRONGER PROTECTIONS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB THREE THREE EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISS CARRILLO. SEEING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON ADAM
FOR CLUB THE ROLE. IS THAT A
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A- ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY TWO NO SIXTEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES. YEAH WE'RE
GOING TO PASS A RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM ONE TWELVE. SEPARATELY ON
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTEEN PASS
RETAIN A BOTTOM ONE FOURTEEN.
WE'RE FILE ITEM ONE FIFTEEN. S.
B. THREE EIGHTY NINE CORRECT
SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY NINE
BY SENATOR DODD AND OTHERS
NEIGHBORHOODS ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES THIS PARA QUE HAN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS IS A REALLY GOOD
BELL BY OUR COLLEAGUE SENATOR
DODD THIS EXTENDS THE ABILITY
TO SELL COCKTAILS THAT ARE
SMALL BUSINESSES AND
RESTAURANTS HAVE HAD DURING
THIS PANDEMIC IS YOU KNOW
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO SELL BOTH
PRE PACKAGED ALCOHOLIC DRINKS
AND PRIMAS DRINKS TO CUSTOMERS
AS PART OF THEIR TO GO MEALS
ORDER. THIS IS BEEN A LIFELINE
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES AND WE ARE
MERELY EXTENDING THAT PRIVILEGE
FOR FIVE YEARS I WANT TO KNOW
THAT THE BILL INCLUDES MANY
SAFEGUARDS THAT WERE- THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO ENSURING THAT WE
DO NOT SEE AN INCREASE IN DRUNK
DRIVING INCLUDING REQUIRING
THAT THE CONTAINER BE SEALED IN
A MANNER THAT IS DESIGNED TO
PREVENT CONSUMPTION WITHOUT THE
BREAKING OF THE SEALS SO THAT
ONE CAN MAKE IT HOME AND THEN
ENJOY THEIR COCKTAIL. IT ALSO
REQUIRES CONTAINERS WE CLEARLY
LABOR OR OTHERWISE IDENTIFIED
AS CONTAINING ALCOHOL NOTHING
IN THE BILL AFFECTS ANY CURRENT
PRIVILEGES AS IT RELATES TO
BEER AND WINE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OUT. THANK
YOU IS BETTER CARE C. NO.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM. COOK LIBERAL. ZERO ALL
MEMBERS REPRESENTATIVE OF. ALL
MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE I SEVENTY
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PASS RETAIN A PILOT OF ONE
SIXTEEN ONE SEVENTEEN. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN. SB.
FOUR THIRTY THREE. CORKERY
SENATE BILL FOR THIRTY THREE BY
SENATOR ALAN AND ACTIVE IN THE
COASTAL RESOURCES. MISPRISION
ARMS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AT MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATOR ALAN SB FOUR THIRTY
THREE. THIS BILL WILL IMPROVE
THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION'S ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT AND ENFORCE THE
COASTAL ACT DESPITE BEING THE
LEAD AGENCY TASKED WITH
IMPLEMENTING THE COASTAL ACT
BECAUSE THE COMMISSION HAS
HISTORICALLY HAD LIMITED
ABILITY TO ACTUALLY ENFORCE THE
LAW. FOR EXAMPLE WHEN A
DEVELOPER FAILS TO COMPLY WITH
PERMIT CONDITIONS- UNDERTAKES
AN PERMITTED ACTIVITIES THE
COMMISSION HAS LITTLE RECOURSE
CASES REMAIN UNRESOLVED FOR
YEARS ALLOWING ONGOING DAMAGE
PUBLIC RESOURCES AND COSTING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN STAFF TIME AND
RESOURCES. S. B. FOR THIRTY
THREE WILL ENABLE THE COASTAL
COMMISSION TO ENFORCE PENALTIES
AGAINST COASTAL ACT VIOLATIONS
WHILE ALSO ENSURING ADEQUATE
RECOURSE FOR ALLEGED VIOLATORS
AT THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND DIE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU PENSIONER
SENIOR DEBATE. FOR CONTROL ALL
MEMBERS. WE DESERVE IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL TYLER I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ONE
NINETEEN S. B. FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT AGUIAR-CURRY SENATE BILL
FOR SEVENTY EIGHT BY CENTER
WIENER AND OTHERS MACKLIN
HOUSING. THIS CARILLO YOUR MAIL
BUT- THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR WIENER
SB FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT IS A VERY
TECHNICAL BILL THE ONE THAT
WILL BE WILL HAVE A POWERFUL
IMPACT TO CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
SHORTAGES IN THE COMING YEARS
TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL DOESNOT
CHANGE THE SOUND DENSITY OF ANY
PARCEL NOTICE THAT REQUIRE
CITIES TO REZONE ANY OF THEIR
LAND. IT ALSO DOES NOT CHANGE
THE APPROVAL PROCESS IN ANY WAY
OR CHANGE ANY OTHER OBJECTIVE
STANDARDS SUCH AS HEIGHT
REQUIREMENTS SET BACKS OR
DESIGN STANDARDS BY ADDRESSING
SEVERAL OF THE ISSUES ARE
RELATED TO THE BILL AS BEFORE
SEVENTY EIGHT WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO BUILD DENSER
MULTI UNIT MISSING MIDDLE
MIDDLE INCOME HOUSING HELP
YOUNG FAMILY STAYING CALIFORNIA
AND LESSEN THE PROPELLANTS OF
HOMELESSNESS AND EVICTION AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS CARRILLO
C. NOTIFICATION OF A CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL. OUT OF THEM. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO THEM. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL TYLER
EYES FORTY EIGHT THOSE NINE
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY SB. FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT. KERKORIAN SENATE
BILL FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR RUBIO AND OTHERS NOT
WITHIN AN ACADEMIC TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. MS GONZALEZ
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT BY CENTER
RUBIO MAKES NECESSARY CHANGES
TO TEACHER TRAINING THAT WILL
LEAD TO BETTER READING
COMPREHENSION OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH
DYSLEXIA. AT SB FORTY EIGHT-
PRESERVE CALIFORNIA'S HIGH
STANDARDS FOR TEACHER
PREPARATION AND INCREASE
TEACHER DIVERSITY ALL WHILE
PREPARING EDUCATORS TO
EFFECTIVELY TEACH READING
COMPREHENSION AND MEET THE
NEEDS OF ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL THAT
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MISS GONZALEZ SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION DEBATE. HARPAL RURAL.
IS THAT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VETERANS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRABLE. WELL CLOSER
ALL TIED UP I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO. DEVONSHIRE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY ONE SB
FIVE FIVE TWO. CORKERY SENATE
BILL FIVE FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AND OTHERS MAC
LEADING TO WATER. THIS FRIEDMAN.
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR HERTZBERG
PERCENT SB FIVE FIFTY TWO AND
THE LAST DROUGHT THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS LOST RUNNING WATER
FOR EXTENDED PERIODS OF TIME
THIS WAS IN MAINLY LOW INCOME
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES WERE
WATER SYSTEM SERVICE LESS THAN
ONE THOUSAND CONNECTIONS.
BOTTLED WATER HAD TO BE
DELIVERED TO IMPACTED
HOUSEHOLDS IN TYLER COUNTY AND
EACH RESIDENT WAS ALLOCATED
HALF A GALLON OF POTABLE WATER
PER DAY. RESIDENTS HAD TO DRIVE
TO PORTABLE SHOWERS SINKS AND
TOILETS SET UP IN THE COMMUNITY
BUT WE HAVE A CHANCE TO PREPARE
NOW BEFORE WE REACH THE POINT
OF ANOTHER HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I
PASSED SB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
TO CREATE A FOUNDATION FOR LONG
TERM IMPROVEMENTS TO DROUGHT
PLANNING AND WATER CONSERVATION
FOR CALIFORNIA'S URBAN
AGRICULTURAL WATER SUPPLIERS.
THE MEASURE BEFORE YOU TODAY
BUILDS ON OUR PREVIOUS EFFORTS
HERE THE LEGISLATURE BY
IMPROVING THE LOCAL DROUGHT
PLANNING AND EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS FOR OUR SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS. THIS BILL GIVES
CALIFORNIA A CHANCE TO CHANGE
COURSE BEFORE MOST VALUABLE
RESIDENTS AGAIN HAVE TO
EXPERIENCE LIFE WITHOUT RUNNING
WATER. WITH THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS ALL OPPOSITION IS
BEEN REMOVED AND AYE ORIGIN AYE
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU. MISTER
MATHIS YOUR RECOGNIZE. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- I
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL-
BUT I DO WANT TO CORRECT ONE
THING- THOSE. RURAL COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY THE ONES OF MY
DISTRICT- WE STILL DON'T HAVE
WATER AND- ONE OF THE BIGGEST
THINGS THAT COULD HELP US IS
MORE WATER STORAGE AND SADLY
OUR BUDGET. DOES NOT HAVE ONE
PENNY GOING TOWARDS THAT- WE
NEED THIS WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
CAPTURE THIS WATER BUT WE HAVE
TO HAVE SOMEWHERE TO PUT IT. TO
CAPTURE CELL I ASK YOU FOR YOUR
RIVAL BUT WE DO HAVE MORE WORK
TO DO. THANK YOU. THANK REST
MATHIS SEE NO ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM PURPLE OF MORAL. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AT ABOUT. WELL. ZERO
TELL YOU WHAT I SIXTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES. I
WANT OF PASSED RETAIN A BALANCE
ONE TWENTY TWO AND ONE TWENTY
THREE. PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY FOUR. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY FIVE SB.
FIVE NINETY SIX. BARBARA SENATE
BILL FIVE NINETY SIX BY CENTER
BECKER AND OTHERS NOT WITHIN
THE GREENHOUSE GASES MISTER
MURATSUCHI. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M PRESENTING SP FIVE NINETY
SIX BY SENATOR BACKER. THIS
BILL DIRECTS THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT
A STRATEGY FOR TRANSITIONING
THE CEMENT INDUSTRY TO NET ZERO
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE WITH INTERIM
TARGETS TO MAKE SURE WE SEE
PROGRESS ALONG THE WAY. CEMENT
AND CONCRETE MADE FROM IT. OF
COURSE ARE VITAL TO OUR
ECONOMY. THE CEMENT
MANUFACTURING IS ALSO THE
LARGEST SOURCE OF INDUSTRIAL
EMISSIONS IN THE STATE AFTER
OIL AND GAS AND IT REPRESENTS
7% OF GLOBAL CARBON DIOXIDE
EMISSIONS. GETTING THE CEMENT
INDUSTRY TO NET ZERO WOULD BE A
BIG WIN IN OUR EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS TO FIGHT CLIMATE
CHANGE. THE CEMENT INDUSTRY
RECOGNIZES THE NEED TO CHANGE
AND HAS COMMITTED TO GETTING TO
KNOW ZERO BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED. BY THE
CEMENT INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AS
WELL AS ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WITH NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. MISTER
FLORIDA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS PARTICULAR BILL M. S. B.
FIVE NINETY SIX I SUPPORT IN
NATURAL RESOURCES AND- FOR A
LONG TIME WE'VE BEG INDUSTRIES
TO COME TO THE TABLE AND WORK
WITH THE- ELECTED BODY ON HOW
TO CHANGE. POLICY HOW TO CHANGE
THEIR INDUSTRY- KEEPING THEM
ENGAGED. I'LL TELL YOU THE
CALIFORNIA AND NEVADA CONCRETE
SOLUTION DID THAT AND THEY
DESERVE A TON OF CREDIT FOR IT.
THEY CAME TO THE TABLE THEY
WORK HARD. THERE'S THINGS THAT
THERE'S GOING TO COST THEM
MONEY BUT THEY'RE WILLING TO DO
IT. I WAS PROUD TO SUPPORT
NATURAL RESOURCES I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT ON THE FLOOR ENCOURAGE
AND I HOPE. THANK GOODNESS FOR
SAYING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. CLARK WELL OVER
THERE ALL. ESERVER. ALL MEMBERS
ARE DESIRABLE. EACH ALL MEMBERS
WILL RESERVE THE- CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TYLER I SIXTY TWO NO
ZERO SEVEN HER PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY SIX. SB.
SIX OH SIX. COOKERY SENATE BILL
SIX OH SIX BY CENTER GONZALEZ
AND OTHERS MACKLIN IN
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY MISTER
KALRA. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
SENATE BILL SIX OH SIX PLACE
SUNDERLAND GONZALEZ DIRECTLY
ADDRESSES SOME OF THE WORST
EMPLOYERS ABUSES SEEN DURING
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
AND PUTS IN PLACE TO WORK
PROTECTIONS WILL REMAIN JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS THE PANDEMIC WINDS
DOWN. SB SIX OH SIX CODIFIES
PARTS OF THE EXISTING FEDERAL
OSHA POLICY FOR AGREE JUST
VIOLATIONS. GIVING CAL OSHA THE
AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE ADDITIONAL
PENALTIES ON EMPLOYERS FOR
WILLFUL VIOLATIONS FOR WORKERS
HAVE BEEN KNOWINGLY HARMED. BY
A FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH HEALTH
AND SAFETY LAWS. SB SIX OH SIX
ALSO BUILDS OFF FEDERAL OSHA'S
CORPORATE WIDE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT A POLICY BY PROVIDING
CAL OSHA WITH THE AUTHORITY TO
ISSUE AN ENTERPRISE WIDE
CITATION. THE REPLIED ALL
LOCATIONS UNDER COMMON
OWNERSHIP WHEN AN EMPLOYER'S
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
DIRECTLY VIOLATE HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS. THE AUTHOR
HAS WORKED CLOSELY WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND IS TAKEN
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS TO
CLARIFY LANGUAGE AND ADDRESS
MANY OF THEIR CNCERNS. AS
CHAIR THIS ON THE COMMITTEE ON
LABOR EMPLOYMENT I'VE HEARD
FIRST HAND HOW CAL OSHA HAS
BEEN INUNDATED WITH MORE WORKER
SAFETY COMPLAINTS. THEN THERE'S
SPECTER'S CAN HANDLE. SB SIX OH
SIX PROVIDES CAL OSHA WITH THE
NECESSARY TOOLS TO MAXIMIZE THE
USE OF THEIR LIMITED RESOURCES
SO THEY'RE ABLE TO RESPOND MORE
EFFECTIVELY TO HEALTH AND
SAFETY VIOLATIONS BY LARGE
EMPLOYERS. THAT PUT WORKERS
LIVES AT RISK. THIS BILL
ADDRESSES HAZARDS AND WORKPLACE
SAFETY NEEDS THAT PREDATE THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC THAT'S
A SURE WE PRIORITIZE THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF OUR WORKFORCE AS
WE MOVE TOWARDS ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. THANK YOU IN
RESPECTFULLY ASK. RIVAL SB SIX
OH SIX. THANKS KALRA SAY
NOTICED OF A CLUB OF THE ROLE.
IS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE IS THAT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. BURKE WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE UP EYES FORTY
TWO NO SEVENTEEN THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
BACK. THE VERY TOP OF THE
CONCURRENCE FILE WITH FILE A
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE. FOR
MOVING BACK TO CONCURRENCE THIS
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE. AB ONE
EIGHTEEN CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE EIGHTEEN BY FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KAMLAGER AND
OTHERS MACALINTAL EMERGENCY
SERVICES MISTER K. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB ONE EIGHTEEN
IS BACK ON FROM CURRENT SENATOR
CONGER WORKED WITH THE
RESPONSIBLE STATE AGENCY AND
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON THIS
MEASURE AND IT HAS NOW BEEN
MOVED FROM THE TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AS THE AGENCY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE GRANT
PROGRAM RATHER THAN THE OFFICE
EMERGENCY SERVICES IT ALSO
MAKES OTHER TECHNICAL
CLARIFYING IN NON SUBSTANTIVE
CHANGES I ASK FOR YOUR- AYE
VOTES. ON ONE EIGHTEEN. THANK
YOU FOR CARE SEE NOTE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM CORPORAL OF THE ROLE. IS
THAT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
PRESENTABLE. WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE
TO TAKE A FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR. A. B.
FORTY EIGHT. CORRECT SOME
PEOPLE FORTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
AND OTHERS NOT GOING INTO LAW
ENFORCEMENT MS GONZALEZ THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER SPEAKER FOR
LETTING ME BRING UP MY BILL- AB
FORTY EIGHT. I KNOW IT'S NOT
YOUR FAULT IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE VOTE THE- WORK WE
DID IN THE SENATE- ENDED UP
WHERE POOR I CAN THE POLICE
CHIEFS ARE NOW OFFICIALLY
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL AND I HOPE
YOU WILL ONCE AGAIN VOTE FOR
THIS- TO ENSURE WE HAVE
STANDARDS RELATING TO RUBBER
BULLETS. THANK YOU MISTER TELLS
MR LACKEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MUST
RISE ONCE AGAIN AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. WELL AND I'M
ACTUALLY SPEAKING BASED ON. MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE DEALING
WITH THESE- DIFFICULT DYNAMIC
SITUATIONS. DEMONSTRATIONS
OFTEN TURN INTO CHAOTIC
SOMETIMES VIOLENT. IN JUST A
BLINK OF AN EYE. IN THESE
SITUATIONS IT'S LAW ENFORCEMENT
SOLE DESIRE TO KEEP THINGS SAFE.
USEFUL AN ORDERLY. WE SHOULD BE
CAUTIOUS ABOUT LIMITING THE
TOOLS THAT THEY HAVE TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT VERY MISSION.
AND THIS BILL STRIPS THEM OF
THOSE VERY VERY USEFUL TOOLS
AND I ASK THAT YOU REJECT THIS.
AMIS LUCKY MR SMITH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I TO RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB FORTY EIGHT.
WE ALL KNOW THAT POLICING IT'S
AN EXTREMELY DYNAMIC PROFESSION.
THERE'S NO TWO SITUATIONS THAT
ARE THE SAME. BECAUSE OF THIS
PLEASE USE THE NUMBER OF TOOLS.
TO RESOLVE SITUATIONS WITHOUT
THE USE OF LETHAL FORCE.
INCLUDING BATTICALOA COULDN'T
CONNECTICUT PROJECTILES AND OR
TEAR GAS. BY LIMITNG THE USE
OF THESE NON LETHAL TOOLS AND
IMPLEMENTING A STRICT SET OF
CRITERIA FOR THEIR USE. WE'RE
GIVING OUR POLICE OFFICERS LESS
TOOLS DEMONSTRATIONS BECOME
UNLAWFUL AND OUT OF CONTROL. WE
KEEP DE FUNDING THE POLICE WE
KEEP TAKING THEIR TOLL AS A WAY
TO KEEP US SAFE. RATHER THAN
LIMITING THOSE NON LETHAL
RESOURCES TO OUR POLICE
OFFICERS. WE SHOULD MAKE SURE
THAT ALL OF OUR OFFICERS ARE
TRAINED AND PREPARED TO DEAL
WITH THESE SITUATIONS AS THEY
ARISE I URGE A NO VOTE. SEEING
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. MS
GONZALEZ YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU I AM I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT THE USE OF OUR WALLETS AND
EVEN- CHEMICAL AGENTS CAN STILL
BE UTILIZED IN SITUATIONS WHERE
THINGS ARE OUT OF CONTROL BUT
THIS PROVIDE STANDARD STATEWIDE
STANDARDS AND WE WORKED HARD
WITH IRA PORAC IN THE POLICE
CHIEFS TO GET TO A POINT OF
BEING NEUTRAL BECAUSE ALTHOUGH
THESE ARE CONSIDERED LESS THAN
LETHAL. I AM. FORCE BASICALLY
THEY'RE THE STUDY SUGGESTS THAT
THEY ACTUALLY CAN BE LETHAL AND
HAVE BEEN LETHAL IN THE PAST
AND IN FACT IF SOMEBODY LOSES
AN EYE. OR A GROWING AREA
OBJECT- BECAUSE OF THESE IT IT
IT AFFECTS OUR ENTIRE LIFE
THESE ARE INNOCENT BYSTANDERS
AND SO WE NEED TO HAVE
STANDARDS WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT PROTESTERS WHO- ARE JUST
EXERTING THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHT HAVE SOME PROTECTIONS AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES I
RESPECT LAST NIGHT ABOUT. A
WITH THAT CORPORAL OF THE ROLE.
IS THERE A VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ADEBAYO. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE TELLURIDE'S FORTY
EIGHT NO SEVENTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS PARKING CURTIN.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING AHEAD IN
THE FILE THE CONCURRENCE FILE
THE FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE. THIS
IS FILE ITEM. TWENTY NINE. AB
TEN FIFTEEN. CORRECT SOME
PEOPLE TEN FIFTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO AND OTHER
SNACK WITHIN HEALING ARTS THIS
RUBIO THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB TEN FIFTEEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE CODIFYING
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE STATE
AUDITOR REGARDING THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MAYES RUBIO
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WITH IS THAT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A
VOTE. WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A
I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY. AB
TEN THIRTY FIVE CORPORATE
SINGLETON THIRTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS AND OTHERS
MACKLIN IN THE TRANSPORTATION
MISTER SALAS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TEN THIRTY FIVE IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE SENATE AMENDMENTS
WERE TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING IN
NATURE RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
C. NOTIFICATION OF A CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. IS THAT A VOTE
ALL MEMBERS THAT IS OUT OF
THOSE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU VOTE I
SIXTY NINE OH ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN THIS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE AB TEN
FIFTY SEVEN CORKERY. SOME
PEOPLE TEND FIFTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
AND OTHERS SNACK LEADING TO
FIREARMS THIS FEATURE IN OURS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AT TEN FIFTY SEVEN IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE- THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT BOTH
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPAD.
C. NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE. FOR
CORPORATE. IS THAT A VITAL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRABLE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLE TYLER I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN THIS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY ONE COVERAGE ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
AND OTHERS MAGICALLY TO CRIMES.
MS GARCIA THANK YOU MEMBERS AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY ONE ELIMINATE
THE SOUTH OF EIGHT EXCEPTION
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR SEAH. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE A CLUB IN THE
ROLE. SENATE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE ABOUT TWELVE TWELVE.
CLOSE ROLE TYLER AT I. SEVENTY
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE ARE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR. FILE
ITEM THIRTY FOUR IS AB TWELVE
SEVEN CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
OH SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AKELA WEBER AND OTHER SNACK
WHEN TO PUBLIC HEALTH DR WEBER
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE OH SEVEN
IS BACK ON FROM CURRENT
AMENDMENTS AND SENATE WE CHANGE
THE COMPOSITION OF THE TASK
FORCE AND REMOVE THE MANDATE
PREVIOUSLY PLACED ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK GOD WEBER
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. IN THIS
ARTICLE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS FOR
DESIRABLE. FOR TWELVE. CLOSE
ROLE TIVER I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FIVE
THIRTY FIVE AB TWELVE EIGHTY
THREE CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE EIGHTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE ACKLAND FOSTER
CARE MR STILL. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS A BILL
THAT WE DO EVERY YEAR
ADDRESSING IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES OF THE CONTINUING CARE
REFORM WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS THE ADMINISTRATION
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE.
ADDING SOME THINGS THE
MINISTRATION WANTED STATUS WELL
AS CHATTERING OUT AMENDMENTS I
ASK YOUR CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MICHELLE
C. NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL FEDERAL TIED ABOUT I.
SIXTY NINE OH ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN. FIVE
THIRTY SIX IS AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SIX CORKERY SOME PEOPLE
THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA AND OTHER SNACK
LATER PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES DR
REGULAR. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SIX IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. C. NOTIFICATION TODAY.
FOR CORPORATE. IS THAT A VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. WELL HOUSE ROLLTIDE I.
SEVENTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS OR CONCURRED IN THIS
IS FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN. AB.
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE.
PERFORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY AND
ACCORDING TO HOUSING MR DALY
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL WILL REDUCE
THE COST OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BY ALLOWING DEVELOPERS TO
RECEIVE EIGHT CD LOAN FUNDS
DURING THE CONSTRUCTION PERIOD.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS AUTHORIZE
A CD TO REQUIRE THAT UP 210% OF
A LOAN AMOUNT BE RETAINED UNTIL
CONSTRUCTION IS COMPLETED I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK GOODNESS DALY CITY
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. CARCLUB
LAURENT. ZADOROV EVERSON'S OUT
OF THOSE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THAT A VOTE. WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY NINE OH
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS. PARKING
CURTIN. WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE. THIS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE AB
FIFTEEN EIGHTY NINE. CROCKERY
SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN EIGHTY NINE
BY THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION AND
ACCOLADES ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
MR FRAZIER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY NINE
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE FROM
THE SENATE ACTS RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. DAVIS
FRAZIER ST NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE. IS
THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THAT A VOTE. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU WHAT I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. ON
THE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
FILE ITEMS FORTY AND FORTY ONE
PASS. AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS I AM
PREPARED TO LIVE TO CALL ON DR
WEBER'S ITEM THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO. AB THREE THIRTY
THREE AND THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE. WELL. CLOSER ROLE. TALLY
THE VOTE HIGHS FORTY ONE KNOWS
TWENTY FIVE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONFERRED IN. MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING BACK TO PICK UP A
COUPLE OF ITEMS EARLIER IN THE
CONCERNS FILE. THIS IS
CONCURRENCE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
NINE AB FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO
CLOBBERING ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS MEDICALLY TO
HEALING ARTS MR LOW THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES THIS IS THE CENTS A
BILL FOR THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CORPORAL. IS THAT A
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AND
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. WELL. CLOSE ROLE
TELEVOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS. ARKAN CURTIN
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE
CORRECT. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG AND OTHERS
NOT GOING TO VEHICLES MR FONG.
I THANK YOU MR SPEAKER MEMBERS.
AB THREE A MEASURE TO ADDRESS
THE GROWING PROBLEM OF ILEGAL
SIDESHOWS A LINK TO LEGAL
STREET RACING IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE SINCE THE ASSEMBLY
LAST SAW THIS BILL I AM PROUD
TO REPORT THAT AB THREE HAS
TAKEN SEVERAL IMPORTANT
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
OF THE ACLU. AND CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION
WHO ARE FORMALLY REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION SENTIMENTS THERE THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL TO APPLY
DIRECTLY TO SIDE SHOWS IT'S
REQUIRE COURTS TO CONSIDER
ADDITIONAL FACTORS THAT WOULD
RESULT IN UNDUE BURDEN BEFORE
ISSUING A LICENSE SUSPENSION. I
WANT TO GIVE A SPECIAL THANK
YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES IN
GLENDALE THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY AND WOODLAND HILLS FOR
THE CO AUTHORSHIP AND
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. THIS BILL PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY THROUGH THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEES AND WAS A SPECIAL
CONSENT ITEM ON THE SENATE
FLOOR I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
BOTH. DAVIS FOR THIS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THREE MEMBERS JUST A FEW WEEKS
AGO IN BURBANK. THREE YOUNG
PEOPLE. JUST STARTING THEIR
LIVES RANGING FROM NINETEEN
YEARS OLD THE TWENTY THREE
YEARS OLD WERE KILLED. THEIR
CRIME. THEIR CRIME WAS DARING
TO MAKE A LEGAL LEFT HAND TURN
AT NIGHT. ON A STREET THAT
SUBJECTED TO STREET RACING IN
MY COMMUNITY. THEY HAD NO
CHANCE. THE CARS THAT HIT THEM
WE'RE DRIVING PROBABLY IN
EXCESS OF NINETY MILES AN HOUR.
THERE IS NOTHING THAT THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE COULD HAVE DONE
BUT THEY'RE PROMISING LIVES
WERE CUT SHORT DEVASTATING
THEIR FAMILIES AND DEVASTATING
OUR COMMUNITIES. NOW UNDER
CURRENT LAW TWO CARS RACING
SIDE BY SIDE CAN BE CHARGED
WITH STREET RACING AND SUBJECT
IT TO THE CURRENT LAW. BUT IF
YOU CHOOSE TO RIDE YOUR CAR AND
RACE A STOPWATCH YOU'RE NOT
SUBJECT TO THE SAME LAW. WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT BRINGS
THOSE TWO EQUALLY EGREGIOUS AND
RECKLESS ACTIVITIES INTO
COMPLIANCE UNDER THE SAME
STATUTE. THIS IS SENSIBLE. THIS
IS NEEDED. AND I APPLAUD MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
WOULD URGE ALL OF YOU TO VOTE
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
MISTREATMENT SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THAT OF A- ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AT ABOUT. WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MISTER CHOW YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAULA QUE
HAN PLEASE MOVE ITEM ONE FORTY
THREE SB THIRTY SEVEN CORTESE
TO THE AN ACTIVE FILE. THE
CLERK WILL NOTE. MEMBERS WE
WANT TO TAKE UP AN ADDITIONAL
ITEM ON THE CONCURRENCE FILE
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN.
FILE ITEM SEVEN. AB NINE NINETY
FIVE MR SANTIAGO. THE CORPORATE
SOME PEOPLE NINE NINETY BY
SIMPLY RIVER SANTIAGO AND OTHER
SNACK FOR THE PRISONERS MR
SANTIAGO. THANK YOU SPEAKER AB
NINE NINETIES BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE. AMENDMENTS ALLOW
VIDEO ONLY I'D VISITATIONS TO
CONTINUE VIDEO ONLY VISITATION-
THE- THE FACILITIES WHERE OUR
CAR STREET WHERE CARS THREE
PEOPLE IS- HARBIN CARTRIDGE.
THIS WILL THIS BILL REALLY
AIMS. TO SEEK FAMILY UNITY SO
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATED
HAVE THE RIGHT OFFER
VISITATIONS I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SPEAKERS BUCKLEY OUT FIVE
OF. THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
SANTIAGO C. NOTIFICATION TODAY.
CLERK WILL OPEN. THAT IS ITEM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
YEAH. ALL MEMBERS THAT IS THERE
TO VOTE. WELL. CLOSER ROLE
TELLURIDE'S FORTY SEVEN KNOWS
FIFTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONVERTED.
MEMBERS MISTER KALRA
AS A PARENT IS PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM SEVENTY
TWO SB FIVE SIX SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
EITHER TO GO. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT. ON MEMBER SAID
HE DESERVED BOTH. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE ICE
FORTY ONE NEWS TWENTY TWO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO IT BE
SENATE THIRD READING FILE AND
TAKE A FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. SB SIX OH SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
SIX OF SEVEN BY CINNAMON AND
OTHER SNACK OF IN THE BUSINESS
OF PROFESSIONS MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR. HELLO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES SB
SIX OH SEVEN IS OMNIBUS BILL TO
HELP IMPROVE EFFICIENCIES AND
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MR LOS SEEING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS. OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
IT. WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTEEN KNOW
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY EIGHT SB SIX OH NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
SIX OH NINE BY SOONER TODD
OVERNIGHT WITH THE CONFERENCE
DR EMILY RECOGNIZE THE MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
SENATE BLL SIX OH NINE WHICH
GRANTS INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING IN ADULT
EDUCATION OR CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION ACCESS TO CALFRESH
BENEFITS THANK YOU MEMBERS ON A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU DR AMY LESSING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER CLERK WILL OPEN. THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ALL
VOTE DESERVE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY TO THIRTY VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THAT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE UP IN FILE ORDER ON THE
SENATE THIRD READING FILE TO
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT. SB. SIX
SIXTY FOUR. THIRTY THREE SENATE
BILL SIXSIXTY FOUR BY CENTER
ALLAN AND ASHLEY THE HOSPICE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB SIX SIXTY FOUR WHICH
IMPOSES A TEMPORARY MORATORIUM
ON NEW HOSPICE LICENSES UNTIL
ONE YEAR AFTER THE COMPLETION
OF A STATE AUDIT ON THE STATE'S
HOSPICE LICENSURE OVERSIGHT.
COLLEAGUES J. LIKE THIS YEAR
EARLIER THIS YEAR- APPROVED AN
AUDIT REQUEST TO IDENTIFY
DEFICIENCIES AND RECOMMEND
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE HOSPICE
LICENSURE AND OVERSIGHT PROCESS
AND IN OUR STATE. THERE'S
CONCERNS THAT CURRENT
REGULATIONS FAILED TO ADDRESS
THE DRAMATIC INCREASE IN THE
LICENSING OF HOSPICE CARE
PROVIDERS SOME OF WHICH SEEM TO
BE UNDERMINING THE QUALITY OF
PATIENT CARE NOW WHILE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S AGING
POPULATION IS GOING TO BE ON
THE INCLINE IT'S GOING TO
INCREASE FROM THE CURRENT
FOURTEEN PERCENT. OF THE
POPULATION 225% OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION IN NEARLY FIFTEEN
YEARS AND THESE PROGRAMS ARE
GOING TO BE NECESSARY TO MEET
THOSE NEEDS WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE GOING ABOUT THE
RIGHT WAY. IN MAKING SURE THAT
THE NEW ONES ARE GETTING SET UP
APPROPRIATELY WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER NECESSARY ADMINISTRATOR
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'LL
RELATE TO WITH ALL OF US WE'VE
HAD WONDERFUL EXPERIENCES WITH
HOSPICE. AND THE DIGNITY THE
END AND SELF ESTEEM THAT
PROVIDES OUR LOVED ONES. NO
THIS IS A UNIQUE SITUATION THAT
IN THIS AREA IN THE AREA OF LOS
ANGELES THERE WAS SEVERE
PROBLEMS WITH FRAUD AND IT'S
BEEN DOCUMENTED. BUT THIS IS A
HEAVY HANDED APPROACH WHEN WE
LOOK AT WHAT IT DOES IT'S A
MORATORIUM ON LICENSURE GOING
FORWARD. FOR MANY YEARSWELL
IT'S ACTUALLY. UNTIL A YEAR
AFTER THE AUDIT IS A PROVIDED
OR TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN I
BELIEVE- GOING FORWARD- THAT IS
UNBELIEVABLE. IN MY AREA ALONE
WE HAVE A DESPERATE NEED FOR
LICENSED HOSPICE PROVIDERS.
THERE'S A SHORTAGE THIS IS
CREATE ANOTHER SHORTAGE
COMPOUNDED WE'VE HAD FRAUD AND
OTHER AGENCIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T STOP AND
PROVIDE A MORATORIUM WE FIX IT
AS WE GO BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE SO
DEPENDENT ON THESE SERVICES. NO
ONE OF THE THINGS WE DO WHEN WE
COME UP TO SACRAMENTO IS WE
PROVIDE. WITH OUR CONSTITUENTS
I PROMISE OF WILL DO NO HARM.
THIS IS HARMFUL THIS HURTS THE
ABILITY FOR PATIENTS TO HAVE
THE DIGNITY AND SELF ESTEEM
THAT THEY DESERVE IN THE LATTER
PART OF THE LIFE AND THE CARE
FOR THE FAMILIES THAT. ARE
PROVIDED. I KNOW THIS THIS BILL
WE GET THROUGH BUT I'M HOPING
THAT WE CAN. LOOK FORWARD TO.
MAKING SURE THAT OUR FAMILIES
ARE PROVIDED FOR AT THE END OF
THEIR LIFE. AS THEY DESERVE
THIS IS A HEAVY HANDED APPROACH.
AND I'M HOPING THAT WE CAN CURE
IN THE NEXT SESSION- TO SOME
KIND OF RESOLVE. I'M GONNA LAY
OFF THIS BILL BECAUSE I FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD HAVE HAD
A BIGGER DISCUSSION ABOUT
TAKING CARE OF THE PEOPLE AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEIR- THEY
WERE MADE IMPORTANT IN OUR
LIVES. THANK YOU. CANISTER
FRAZIER SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISTER NAZARIAN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. SURE THANK YOU I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CONCORD- RELAYING HIS
CONCERNS JUST SO YOU KNOW- THIS
BILL DOES ALLOW NEW LICENSES
FOR AREAS WITHOUT A LOT OF
HOSPICE PROVIDERS IN AREAS WITH
SHORTAGES- AND ALLOWS LICENSES
THAT ARE ALREADY SUBMITTED FOR
REVIEW. AT CDPH COLLEAGUES WITH
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO ADDRESS
IS THE FACT THAT IN A TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN REPORT FROM
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FOUND
THAT NATIONWIDE. 87% OF HOSPICE
CARE PROVIDERS VIOLATED AT
LEAST ONE FEDERAL GUIDELINE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT NUMBER IS
NINETY FOUR PERCENT. 94% WE
NEED TO STEM SOME OF THESE
INCLUDE REOCCURRING ISSUES. AND
ADDRESS THEM SO THAT FEDERAL
DOLLARS AREN'T BEING WASTED WE
KEEP ON TALKING ABOUT FRAUD
WASTE AND ABUSE. THIS IS ONE
MEASURE WHERE WE TEMPORARILY
PUT SOMETHING ON HOLD REVIEW IT
MOVE IT FORWARD. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU. BURKE WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD
OF A. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE
HIGHS FIFTY SIX KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE WILL
TAKE A FILE ITEM NINETY TWO S.
B. FOR THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR BY SOONER
GONZALEZ AND OTHERS MEDICAL AND
COMMUNICATIONS TO CLEAR THEIR
ZERO STICK FOR COMPLETELY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THE MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I RISE TO
PRESENT S. B. FOR ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR GONZALEZ. THIS BILL NOW
CONTAINS PROVISIONS FOR
CONTINGENT NACHRICHT WITH AB
FOURTEEN AFTER OUR BILLS HAVE
BEEN NARROWED AND THE CONTENT
SPLIT INTO THESE TWO VEHICLES.
OF THE BILLS ARE NOW JOINED AS
ONE INSEPARABLE PACKAGE I WILL
SPEAK TO THE POLICY ON BOTH.
OVER THE PAST TEN MONTHS CENTER
GONZALEZ AND I WITH OUR TWO
DOZEN COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE CO
AUTHORED THE BILLS. HAVE
PROVIDED MODERNIZE STANDARDS
WHICH WILL BE UPDATED AS FCC
STANDARDS EVOLVED. TO ADOPT A
NEW SPEEDS AND TECHNOLOGY. AB
FOURTEEN NOW HAS A SUNSET OF
TEN YEARS ON THE EXISTING
SURCHARGE. AB S. PHARMACIES ME
SB FOUR NOW CONTAINS A CAP ON
THE ANNUAL COLLECTIONS BY THE
P. YOU SEE AT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION. WIRELINE
CUSTOMERS MOSTLY SENIORS. RURAL
AND LOW INCOME CONSUMERS WILL
ACTUALLY SEE A DECREASED V. AS
THE BILL REMOVES AN OVERDUE
LOOPHOLE IMPLEMENTED BY THE
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS.
MEMBERS WHEN THIS BILL PASSED
OUR HEALTH WITH SIXTY TWO BY
PARTISAN CONSUMERS TO MEET ONE
OF THE BY SIXTY TWO BY PARTISAN
BOTH THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION PER BOOK PROPOSED
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. THAT
AMOUNT WAS REDUCED TO SIX
BILLION ON THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL SB ONE FIFTY SIX. THE NEED
HAS NOT BEEN REDUCE COLLEAGUES
IT HAS INCREASED SINCE AB
FOURTEEN PASSED THIS HOUSE IN
MAY. WITH THE NEW LIMITS ON THE
THIRD CHARGE EXTENSION THESE
BILLS HAVE NEW CONSTRAINTS ON
THE MONIES TO BE COLLECTED IN
THE COMING YEARS. WHEN
OPPONENTS OF THIS LEGISLATION
ARGUED THAT THE MISSION HAS
SOMEHOW BEEN ACCOMPLISHED.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT THESE
WERE THE SAME PARTIES WHO
PROMISED TO SOLVE CALIFORNIA'S
CONNECTIVITY PRO PROBLEM. WITH
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. I DON'T
THINK ANY OF US. THINK THAT
THOSE PROMISES BASED ON THE
RULES RINA GAVE NEGOTIATED WITH
INDUSTRY WERE NEVER DELIVERED.
NOW THOSE COMPANIES CLAIM WE
NEED TO WORD SMITH NEW RULES
THAT ALLOW PARTICIPATION BY
LOCAL AND REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS
TRIBES IN COOPS TO FILL A HUGE
GAP THEY WILLINGLY LEFT. IN OUR
STATE. SO ASK YOURSELF HOW LONG
ARE WE GOING TO LEAVE LOW
INCOME IN SMALL TOWN
CALIFORNIANS BEHIND WELL WE
PLAY BY THEIR RULES THE PRIVATE
SECTOR IS STILL ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THESE GOVERNMENT
SUPPORTED PROJECTS BUT UNDER
THESE BILLS ARE CONSTITUENTS
WILL NOT HAVE TO WAIT FOR ONE
SET OF PLAYERS IN INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY TO DECIDE WHAT.
PENCILS OUT. WE HAVE AN
HISTORIC OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
GENERATIONAL INVESTMENTS IN THE
INTERNET SERVICES. TELEHEALTH
JOB TRAINING EDUCATION SMALL
BUSINESS PARTICIPATION AND THE
DIGITAL ECONOMY. THOSE THAT IS
CRITICAL TO THE LIFE AND
PROSPERITY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
POLITICS PLEASE JOIN ME IN IN
VOTING IN FAVOR REST BEFORE AND
ITS COMPANION AB FOURTEEN WHEN
RETURNS TO THE ASSEMBLY.
HOLLINGS HOW LONG DO WE WAIT.
SERIOUSLY HOW LONG ARE WE GOING
TO WAIT. HOW WE GONNA TALK
ABOUT IT WE ARE A STATE OF
DOERS. I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY. AND I THINK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. GIVE US AGUIAR-CURRY
MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER- I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR AND
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM LONG
BEACH FOR PUSHING THIS
BROADBAND BILL FOR TODAY. IT IT
IT WILL ADVANCE THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO CLOSING THE DID THE
VISUAL THAT THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
ALIGNED. WITH THE BUDGET THIS
BILL WILL HELP THOSE THAT NEED
IT THE MOST EXPRESSLY SMALL
BUSINESSES FAMILIES BY
INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION CAN
COLLECT. IT IS EXPRESSLY
IMPORTANT DURING THESE TIMES-
THAT EVERYONE IS CONNECTED TO
HIGH SPEED INTERNET LET ME
SIMPLY SAY THAT WE HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA'S COLLEAGUES WE HAVE
A CALIFORNIA THAT IS CONNECTED
AND WE HAVE A CALIFORNIA THAT
IS NOT CONNECTED. LET'S TALK
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA THAT IS
NOT CONNECTED THE CALIFORNIA IS
NOT CONNECTED BECAUSE THE
CALIFORNIA THAT HAS LEFT BEHIND
INTENT TO BE P. COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA THAT'S LEFT BEHIND
IS NOT CONNECTED IT TENDS TO BE
THE ONES THAT WILL WIN A
PANDEMIC. THOSE CHILDREN CANNOT
DO DISTANCE LEARNING BECAUSE
THEY CANNOT BE CONNECTED TO THE
INTERNET LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA THAT HAS BEEN LEFT
BEHIND- WHO CAN NOT. FUNCTION
LIKE EVERYONE ELSE DO WHERE
THERE IS LOOKING FOR A JOB
SEARCHING THE INTERNET FOR
OPPORTUNITIES. THEY ARE NOT
CONNECTED JUST IMAGINE IF YOU
YOURSELF. HAD NO CELL PHONE
SERVICE. YOU CAN'T CALL YOUR
LOVED ONES YOU CAN'T CONNECT TO
THE OUTSIDE WORLD WHAT IS THE
MATCH YOU ON A DESERT ISLAND
AND YOU HAVE NO FORM OF
COMMUNICATION WITH DOT THAT'S
THE REALITY THAT PEOPLE ARE
FACED WITH DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
IN CALIFORNIA THE FIFTH WORLD
ECONOMY THESE INDIVIDUALS FEEL
LEFT BEHIND AND LEFT OUT IN
MOST CASES THEY FEEL LEFT FOR
DEAD. AND SO THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE CAN RE
WRITES A NARRATIVE IN
CALIFORNIA THE MOVE ALL OF
CALIFORNIA FORWARD. WE CAN'T
WAIT UNTIL NEXT YEAR WE CAN'T
WAIT TWO YEARS WE HAVE TO DO
THIS NOW THE TIME IS NOW FOR US
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE RESOURCES
ARE THERE THAT'S WHY I'M
SUPPORTING. SB FOUR WE'VE HEARD
FROM MARK OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
WINTER WHO HAS LABORED ON TIME
AND TIME AGAIN WITH THE
COALITION- TO MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE OF EVERYONE- I'M
COMMITTED AND EVERYONE BROUGHT
TO A CONNECTIVE ITTY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON
SENATE BILL FOR. THANK YOU
MISTER GIPSON DOCTOR WOULD YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES
I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BEFORE. YOU KNOW I'VE FOR SEVEN
YEARS NOW I'VE BEEN ON THIS
FLOOR ADVOCATING FOR BROADBAND
ACCESS THIS IS AN ACCESS ISSUE.
IT'S AN ACCESS ISSUE FOR PEOPLE
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES IT'S AN
ACCESS ISSUE IN IN IN
COMMUNITIES LIKE LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM COMPTON RIGHT
REPRESENTS THERE. ARE CARS
EXCUSE ME CARSON- THIS IS AN
ACCESS ISSUE THIS IS THE
EXTENSION. OF A FEE NOT A NEW
FEE IT'S AN EXTENSION OF A FEE
MOST PEOPLE WON'T EVEN NOTICE
IT'S EVEN ON THEIR BILL IT'S
NOT SIGNIFICANT. FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL BUT IT IS
SIGNIFICANT FOR THE PROCESS
WHEN WE STARTED LOOKING WE LOST
OUR LOOKING AT THE AT THE
BUDGET BILL FOR- FOR BROADBAND
AND OTHER SUPPORTING BILLS THAT
GO A LONG WAY. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THE PUZZLE.
TO KEEP THIS GOING TO DELIVER
ON THE PROMISE. OF BROADBAND
FOR EVERYONE IN THIS STATE.
COLLEAGUES I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND ALSO TO
SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN WHEN IT
COMES BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD
STRUMMER'S YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THE MATTER. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TO
SUPPORT A S. B. TO END AB
FOURTEEN WHEN IT COMES BACK TO
OUR FLOOR. REASONS WHY IS
BECAUSE FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
HISTORY THIS INCLUDES THE
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES AND WE TALK ABOUT
RURAL COMMUNITIES MANY TRAVEL
RESERVATIONS LIVE IN THE
DEEPEST RURAL AREAS THAT STILL
DON'T EVEN HAVE ACCESS. TO
BROADBAND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE CLOSURES OF SCHOOLS DURING
THE PANDEMICS AND WE WENT TO
BROADBAND IN MANY PLACES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DO YOU KNOW
THAT MANY INDIAN RESERVATIONS
THE WAY THEY ACCOMMODATED THAT
WAS HAVING PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY DR BOOKS TO DIFFERENT
HOUSES THROUGHOUT THE
RESERVATIONS. THAT WAS THE WAY
THAT THEY HAD THE BROADBAND
THERE WAS NO WAY TO MOVE
FORWARD ON THE INTERNET THIS
FOR THE FIRST TIME WILL BRING
THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
FORGOTTEN ABOUT IT A LOT OF
THESE PIECES OF LEGISLATION FOR
THE FIRST TIME MOVING FORWARD.
THIS IS A BILL THAT NEEDS TO
MOVE FORWARD THESE ARE ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE TO NEED TO ADDRESS
BECAUSE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
BROADBAND FOR ALL IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA LET'S REMEMBER
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE AND
THE TRIBAL COMMUNITIES IN THE
TRIBAL FEDERAL INDIAN
RESERVATIONS. THERE ARE STILL
SO RURAL THAT MANY TIMES IT
TAKES TWO HOURS TO GET TO ONE
OF THE ONE OF THE MARKETS IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES THESE ARE
AREAS THAT WE'RE STILL TRYING
TO ADDRESS HERE AS A STATE
LEGISLATURE AND I WANT TO THANK
OF SENATOR GONZALEZ IN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CECILIA AGUIAR-CURRY FOR
BRINGING THESE ISSUES FORWARD.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
INCLUDING WE ARE INCLUDING ALL
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE SUPPORT
THESE TYPES OF BILLS THAT
STARTS TO BALANCE THAT APPROACH
OF EQUITY WE TALK ABOUT EQUITY
ALL THE TIME ON THIS FLOOR. BUT
NOW IN FRONT OF US WE HAVEN'T
EQUITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE IN
THE TRAVEL COMMUNITIES SHARE
ONE IT'S AN FOR. IT WON'T
TALKING ABOUT MOVING FORWARD
AND THAT'S BROADBAND ACCESS FOR
ALL OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SO I SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I
SUPPORT AB FORTY WHEN IT COMES
BACK. SO I ASK FOR YOUR ARE
VOTE BECAUSE FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN HISTORY WE'RE INCLUDING
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN LEFT ALL.
THANK YOU MYSTERONS MYSTERY OF
US YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AS WELL RISE IS VICE CHAIR OF A
THE CALIFORNIA LATINO.
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS ON YOU KNOW
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL FOR WHICH IS A TOP
ON THE PRIORITY FOR CAUCUS. I
WANT TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM LONG BEACH AND SO MANY OF
OUR COLLEAGUES ON THIS FLOOR
FROM. WINTERS IN COACHELLA I'D
TORRANCE AND LOS ANGELES AND
I'VE DONE WORK IN THIS SPACE.
AND THIS LEGISLATION. WILL GO A
LONG WAY TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
RESIDENT IN CALIFORNIA HAS
ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED BROADBAND.
IN PARTICULAR THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT OUR MOST
UNDERSERVED AND UNSERVED AREAS
OF THE STATE ARE. YOU SOME OF
OUR MOST- ARE DISADVANTAGED
AREAS CAN FINALLY ACCESS HIGH
SPEED INTERNET THROUGH GRANT
FUNDING. AS HAS BEEN EMPHASIZED
ALREADY BROADBAND IS NO LONGER
AN OPTION FOR HOUSEHOLDS TO
CONSIDER PURCHASING IT'S AN
ABSOLUTE NECESSITY IN OUR
SOCIETY. AND WITH THAT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LATINO
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MR THIS
MISTER SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER
THINKING MAN'S BIGGER NOT WE
BEGAN THE YEAR. TO TALK ABOUT
THIS IS THE YEAR THAT WE DO
BROADBAND. AND WHEN WE TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT WE THE BILL THAT
WE HAVE BEFORE US. THIS IS THE
PIECE A BIG PIECE OF GETTING
BROADBAND CONNECTION DONE
ACCOSTED CALIFORNIA. NOW I'VE
WE'VE TALKED AMONGST EACH OTHER
INDIVIDUALLY AND FOLKS SAY WELL
WE JUST DID SI BILLION IS NOT
ENOUGH. BUT YOU REALLY HAVE TO
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THAT SIX
BILLION WHAT'S- THERE WERE
THREE POINT TWO FIVE. FOUR WITH
CONSIDER THE MIDDLE MILE. AND
WE THINK ABOUT THAT THAT'S KIND
OF LIKE THE HIGHWAY. THE LOAN
LOSS PROGRAM. THAT THAT USE THE
OTHER SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION. THOSE ARE KIND OF THE
OFF RAMP IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
AND THEN THERE'S THE KIND OF
THE MEAT AND POTATOES OF WHAT'S
GOING TO GET US CONNECTED IN
COMMUNITIES AND THAT LEFT US
WITH ABOUT TWO BILLION. WE TAKE
A LOOK AT THE AMOUNT OF
APPLICATIONS CURRENTLY NOW THIS
U. P. LET'S NOT THIRTY SEVEN
APPLICATIONS. AND THEY'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO GROW. SO THE
MONIES WE PASSED WERE A STEP
TOWARD A BIG STEP BUT ONLY A IN
AN INVESTMENT ONLY A DOWN
PAYMENT FOR THE REAL WORK AHEAD
OF US. I WOULD BE GETTING THIS
PANDEMIC WE ALL KNEW THAT THE
INTERNET WAS IMPORTANT. BUT
WHAT WE SAW WE KIDS HAD TO GO
HOME AND DISTANCE LEARNING BUT
THEY DIDN'T HAVE INTERNET
ACCESS OR ADEQUATE INTERNET
ACCESS. IT WHAT WE SAW IN SOME
PARTS OF THE STATE. WITH
CHILDREN SITTING OUTSIDE OF A
FAST FOOD PLACES TO CAPTURE
INTERNET. WHAT WE SAW ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. WHAT WHAT
WAS THAT WAS THAT WHETHER
YOU'RE RICH OR POOR WE'LL URBAN.
THERE WAS THERE WAS A NECESSITY
FOR THE INTERNET JUST TO HAVE A
BASIC EDUCATION. AND THE MANY
WERE LEFT BEHIND. NOW SOME OF
US ARE FROM URBAN AREAS AND SO
WE'VE ALWAYS MADE THE CASE FOR
URBAN AREAS. BUT WE GOT TO
DRIVE UP AND DOWN THE STATE
BECAUSE KOGAN PREVENTED US FROM
GETTING ON PLANES WE REALLY
QUICKLY FOUND OUT THAT WE
COULDN'T HAVE. A LOT OF
TELEPHONE CONVERSATIONS UP AND
DOWN THE NINETY NINE UP AND
DOWN THE FIVE. AND I WAS AN
INCONVENIENCE BUT I COULD
IMAGINE LIVING. IN ANY OF THESE
AREAS AND NOT HAVING ANY WAY TO
CONNECT. ANYTIME OF THE DAY.
BUT WHAT WE ALSO FOUND IN URBAN
AREAS. I'LL TRY TO DISTANCE
LEARNING. IS THE IMPORTANCE OF
A TELEHEALTH REPORTS THE
CONNECT THE LOVED ONES THE
IMPORTANCE OF WHAT IT MEANT NOW
TO WORK FROM HOME. SO I WOULD
ARGUE THAT THIS THIS HAD HIT IN
IMPACTED LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. WORSE THAN ANY OTHER
COMMUNITIES BUT WHAT WE FOUND
OUT THAT IMPACTED EVERYBODY IN
CALIFORNIA. SO IF WE'RE GOING
TO GET THIS WORK DONE AND LET'S
BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT IT WE'VE
JUST BEGUN TO PUT A DOWN
PAYMENT. ON THE MONEY IS NEEDED
TO CONNECT. THIS WILL ACTUALLY
FULFILL THAT CONVERSATION THAT
WE BEGIN AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE- YEAR THAT SAID WE ARE
GOING TO DO BROADBAND INTERNET
CONNECTION FOR ALL. BECAUSE
WE'RE GONNA NEED A LOT MORE
WORK. AND WHAT THIS ALLOWS US
TO DO BECAUSE REMEMBER THE
FEDERAL FUNDS IN. TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE
TO COMPLETE CONNECTION TO EVERY
HOUSEHOLD EVERY SMALL BUSINESS.
AT EVERY MEDICAL FACILITY ALL
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
GET DONE THAT WE SET ARE SO
IMPORTANT. THAT WE WILL SAID IN
SPEECHES THAT EVERYBODY THAT IS
SO IMPORTANT THAT WE'VE ALL
TALKED ABOUT ON THE FLOOR
THERE'S STILL IMPORT. IF WE
DON'T GET THIS DONE. CONTINUE
THAT WORK FOR THE NEXT DECADE.
AND HOPEFULLY IF THIS GETS OUT.
AND A COMPANION BILL GETS OUT.
WELL NOT ONLY FULFILLED A DOWN
PAYMENT BUT WE WILL WE WILL
HAVE INVESTED TO TAKE CARE OF
ALL THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
SAID THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO US.
NOT I CAN'T EMPHASIZE ENOUGH
THAT IN OUR COMMUNITIES. M. AND
I'M GONNA LOOK AT LONGER BUT
THIS IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. WE WERE
DEVASTATED WITH THE INABILITY
FOR KIDS TO GET DISTANCE
LEARNING BECAUSE IT WAS JUST NO
CONNECTION. BUT THEY WERE ALSO
DEVASTATED WITH PEOPLE TO HAVE
THE INABILITY TO VISIT A
DOCTOR. OR NURSE. NOW WILL NEW
ABOUT TELEHEALTH. BUT PEOPLE
DIDN'T HAVE THE WAY TO DO IT. I
CAN'T EMPHASIZE ENOUGH. THAT
THAT THAT THIS IS PROBABLY ONE
OF THE MOST SINGLE IMPORTANT
THINGS THAT WE DO. AND THESE
COUPLE OF YEARS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH IS FINALLY TO
CONNECT EVERYONE. AND THIS IS
PART OF THAT SO I WOULD URGE A
YES VOTE. FOR THAT WE DON'T
FALL SHORT OF A DOWN PAYMENT
BUT WE ACTUALLY INVEST THE
MONEY THAT ARE NEEDED TO
FINALLY CONNECT CALIFORNIA- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANKS
SANTIAGO MISS AMERICA TWO G.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I-
WANT TO JOIN. TO URGE STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS MEASURE AS
WELL AS THE COMPANION BILL. WE
JUST HEARD FROM A OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES WHO I WORKED
WITH ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM COACHELLA. AND WE DID
SUCCEED IN. GETTING THE THREE
POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE MIDDLE MILE
INFRASTRUCTURE SO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW THE
TERMINOLOGY THE MIDDLE MILE
VERSUS THE LAST MILE I MEAN THE
MIDDLE MILE IS LIKE. IT'S LIKE
TO FREEWAYS THAT THE CONNECT
THE DIFFERENT REGIONS OF OUR
STATE BUT HOW DO WE CONNECT
FROM THE FREEWAYS TO THE
INDIVIDUAL HOMES THAT'S WHERE
THE LAST MILE COMES INTO PLAY
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS SO
TO WHAT. AGAIN ARE CALLING FROM
LOS ANGELES SAID YOU KNOW I
WOULD PUT IT THIS WAY THAT.
BROADBAND. CLOSING THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE IS THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ISSUE OF THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. IF YOU CAN'T CONNECT.
TO THE INTERNET CHILDREN ARE
EXCLUDED FROM THE CLASSROOM
FROM THE VIRTUAL CLASSROOM IF
YOU CAN'T CONNECT YOUR
WORKPLACE YOU ARE EXCLUDED FROM
YOUR WORKPLACE AND SO THAT'S
WHY EVEN THOUGH WE GOT THAT
SIGNIFICANT SIX BILLION DOLLAR
FUNDING IN THE IN THE BUDGET
THAT GOES TO THE OVERALL.
BROUGHT IN BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE THE BACKBONE OF
THE STATEWIDE- A BROADBAND
NETWORK BUT WE NEED THAT LAST
MY CONNECTION TO ACTUALLY GET
INTO THE HOUSEHOLD TO CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIGITAL DIVIDE SO LIKE
TO JOIN ALL MY COLLEAGUES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISS AMERICA T. MR
VOEPEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THE MATTER. COLLEAGUES I RISE
IN OPPOSITION AND NOT BECAUSE
IT'S NOT. NOBLE GOOD THIS BILL
AS A MATTER OF TIMING FOR ME.
SIMPLE TIMING I THINK IT'S A
GREAT BILL I'D LIKE TO SEE IT
GO NEXT YEAR. AND AS THE
HONORABLE. CHAIR OF BUDGET SAID
WE'VE GOT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. SO WHAT
I ASK IS PEOPLE WILL CONSIDER
THE TIMING. LET'S USE THE SIX
BILLION WE ALSO HAVE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY FROM
THE AMERICAN RECOVERY AND
RESCUE PLAN. LET'S LOOK AT THAT
MONEY WE ALSO HAVE A DRY
ENORMOUS I MAKE WORDS UP OKAY.
TRY NORMA'S SURPLUS NOW I ALSO
WRAP THIS UP WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND EVERYONE. THIS YOU CAN
CALL A TAX YOU COULD CALL THE
FEE BUT IT'S STILL A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
EXTENSION ON PEOPLE'S PHONE
BILLS RIGHT NOW THE PHONE BILLS.
LOADING THE MODEL NUMBERS HERE
TWENTY FIVE POINT 669% ARE
THESE FEES AND TAXES. AND THEY
IMPACT LOW INCOME PEOPLE OF
COLOR IT'S A EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
IMPACT ON YOUR POCKETBOOK. SO
THOSE ARE MY POINTS I ENCOURAGE
A NO VOTE. AND THEN NEXT YEAR
I'LL BE YES ALL THE WAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR VOEPEL
WITHOUT OBJECTION I THINK I.
NORMAN IS A WORD. MS CLARK
SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER A MEMBERS I
RISE TO SUPPORT S. B. FOR. BY
MY COLLEAGUE IN THE SENATE AND
ALSO TO SUPPORT- MY COLLEAGUES
HERE ON THE FLOOR WHO HAS
WORKED TIRELESSLY ON NOT ONLY
BROADBAND THIS YEAR BUT FOR
MANY YEARS. WE KNOW THAT WE'VE
HAD A HISTORIC INVESTMENT THIS
YEAR. AND WE KNOW THAT THOSE
DOLLARS MEANS SOMETHING WHEN IT
COMES TO CONNECTING NOT ONLY
STUDENTS AND CHILDREN BUT
ELDERS AND SENIORS AND
VULNERABLE AREAS THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN CONNECTED. BUT I DO WANT
TO CAUTION US AS I'VE BEEN
APPOINTED TO THE MIDDLE MILE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. THAT YES.
GAINING THESE FUNDS IN THE CAST
OF FUNDS IS IMPORTANT. FOR THAT
LAST MILE BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
DO MORE TO FOCUS ON THE P. YOU
SEE MAKING SURE THAT THEY MOVE
APPLICATIONS IN A TIMELY MANNER
THAT THEY ARE NOT HOLDING
APPLICATIONS FOR MONTHS AND
MONTHS ON END SO THAT IF WE ARE
GOING TO INVEST WE SEE THAT
INVESTMENT MOVING FORWARD AS A
FREE WAY IF WE ARE CLOGGED UP
BECAUSE OF TRAFFIC LITERALLY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO MAKE THESE
CONNECTIONS. THE LAST THING
THAT I WANT TO SEE. MEMBERS I
APOLOGIZE. BUT IS ANOTHER HIGH
SPEED RAIL SCENARIO WHERE WE
MAKE AN INVESTMENT AND WE DON'T
SEE THAT INVESTMENT COME
FORWARD. ALL OF US WERE STUNNED
WHEN WE SAW THOSE TWO YOUNG
GIRLS SITTING OUT IN FRONT OF A
TACO BELL. A PICTURE SPEAKS A
MILE THOUSAND WORDS. AND WE
KNOW THAT WE NEED THIS
CONNECTIVITY BUT LET ME BE
CLEAR AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER
EQUITY. ANY QUALITY ARE TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT MEANS WE
MUST INVEST IN THE AREAS THAT
ARE NOT CONNECTED FIRST. WE
MUST MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
CONNECTIONS GET MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE FUNDING WE HAVE AND
THAT THE P. YOU SEE IS
ACCOUNTABLE AND MOVE SWIFTLY
AND THAT'S WHY SUPPORT THIS
BECAUSE SIX BILLION IS A HUGE
INVESTMENT. BUT IT IS NO
INVESTMENT AT ALL IF WE CANNOT
MOVE THESE PROJECTS FORWARD IN
A TIMELY MANNER. I ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT SB FOUR. THANK YOU OF
COURSE OF A MR MAYS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I CAN GET THERE
ON THIS BILL I'M JUST NOT SURE
I CAN GET THERE ARE RIGHT NOW-
AND HERE'S HERE'S WHY- WE KNOW
THAT WE NEED A MORE ACCESS TO
BROADBAND ESPECIALLY IN OUR
RURAL AREAS BUT- WHEN WE WENT
THROUGH. OUR OF OUR BROADBAND
WORKING GROUP JUST A FEW WEEKS
AGO SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
COME UP OF HOUSE THE ALLOCATION
TO RURAL AREAS VERSUS URBAN.
AND COUNTIES LIKE SAN BENITO
COUNTY AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY
THEY ARE DESCRIBED AS URBAN I
COUNTIES WHEN IN FACT A BIG
CHUNK OF THOSE OF THOSE
COUNTIES ARE ACTUALLY RULE IN
THE LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL.
ABOUT A SAYS THAT THEY ARE
THEIR URBAN COUNTIES I'VE ASKED
FOR A BUSINESS PLAN IN FACT IT
WAS THE MEMBER FROM HAYWARD IN.
THAT HAD SAID THAT SHOWS THE
BUSINESS PLAN. IF ANYBODY IF
YOU OF LOOKING AT THIS BILL.
CAN READ IN THERE WHAT IMPACT
THIS IS GOING TO HAVE ON YOUR
DISTRICT I'D LOVE TO KNOW THAT
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHAT
IMPACT THIS IS GOING TO HAVE ON
MY DISTRICT I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE PARTS OF MY DISTRICT THAT
NEED. MORE BROADBAND A NEED-
THERE UNDERSERVED AND MANY
PEOPLE ARE UNSERVED AND WE NEED
TO GET FUNDS TO THEM WHEN YOU
BUILD THAT CAPACITY I THINK THE
QUESTION IS WHAT IS IT WHAT ARE
WE BUYING HERE. THERE IS A
SURCHARGE FINE I'M FINE WITH
THE SURCHARGE. I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT IT'S GOING TO BUY. SO IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT I CAN GET THERE I
JUST CAN'T GET THERE. RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYES MISSED
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER. COLLEAGUES I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF S. BEFORE AND THE
COMPANION BILL THAT WILL MOVE
FORWARD AND IN SUPPORT OF MY
COLLEAGUES- ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
DO A QUERY FOR. VOICING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
PRESIDENT OBAMA AS HE TALKED
ABOUT THIS THING CALLED
BROADBAND AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
BEING ABLE TO ENSURE THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO USE. BROADBAND TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
TO HOUSING TO EDUCATION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ID OUR PARTY AS
THE QUESTION WHEN WILL WE DO
THIS THE TIME IS NOW WE'VE BEEN
SUFFERING WITHOUT YOU FOR YEARS
FOR DECADES IF YOU WILL WITHOUT
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO BROADBAND
IT IS THE KEY TO OUR DIGNITY IS
IT IT IS THE KEY. TO ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE IT IS THE KEY TO
ACCESS TO HOUSING TO EDUCATION
TO EVERYTHING THAT WE STAND FOR
AND THIS CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY WHAT ARE WE BUYING WE
ARE BUYING DIGNITY NOW WE ARE
BUYING ACCESS NOW. AND I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE OUR
COLLEAGUES TO BE ABLE TO BE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS BONTA. MISTER CA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
MATTER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ALL OF THE POINTS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE. BY OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE STATED WHY.
THIS BILL IS SO CRITICAL. THERE
ARE SOME VERY- BASIC AND QUITE
FRANKLY I'M SERIOUS
IMPLICATIONS- IF THIS BILL THE
COMPANION BILL DO NOT PASS AND
MANY OF YOU HAVE ARTICULATED
WHAT THOSE ARE CHILDREN SCHOOLS.
BUSINESSES MAKING THEIR
TRANSACTIONS PEOPLE ACCESSING
HEALTH CARE- THAT IS SO
CRITICAL TO CERTAIN PARTS OF
THE STATE THAT ARE MEDICALLY
UNDER SERVED AND THE LST GOES
ON AND ON AND ON I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE. TO COLLEAGUES WHO
RAISED HER MIKE AND SAID. I CAN
SUPPORTERS BUT NOT TODAY. I
WANT TO TELL YOU THAT- WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COURAGEOUS
STANDS THERE ARE MANY ON THIS
FLOOR. WHO PROBABLY DO NOT DARE
TO RAISE OR MIKE AND ARTICULATE
WHY THEY DON'T SUPPORT THIS
BILL. IS IN THE FACE OF THE
CHILDREN SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
AND THOSE WHO ARE IN DIRE NEED
OF ACCESSING HEALTHCARE
SERVICES. AND NOT RECOGNIZING
THE WORK THAT HAS GONE INTO NOT
JUST THE BILL THAT WAS PASSED
PRIOR TO THE SUMMER BREAK BUT
THE SENSUAL COMPLIMENTS ON
POLICY AND INVESTMENTS TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS INTERNET
SERVICES FOR EVERYONE.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE WORK ISN'T A
ONE AND DONE. AND THAT THERE
ARE AREAS OF IMPROVEMENT THAT
WE BEGIN WORKING ON. TODAY
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THE ISSUE OF AFFORDABILITY FOR
SERVICES. WE'VE GOT SOME WORK
TO DO STILL IN THE FINING THE
RURAL AND URBAN AREAS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE DOLLARS ARE
INTENTIONAL. WHERE THEY ARE
INVESTED IN THAT WE GET THE
OUTCOMES THAT WE ARE ATTEMPTING
TO ACHIEVE. THAT WE MAKE SURE
THAT THE UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY
DEFINITIONS ARE ALSO CLEARLY
DEFINED. FOR THOSE SAME
PURPOSES THERE ARE MORE FEDERAL
FUNDS. THAT ARE POTENTIALLY
COMING OUR WAY TO ENSURE THAT
WE CAN. ADDRESS THE NEEDS THAT
THE LOCAL FOLKS ARE GOING TO
HAVE AS WE ARE EMPOWERING THEM.
TO TAKE ON RESPONSIBILITIES IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE STATE TO
DELIVER. BROADBAND SERVICES TO
THEIR AND OUR CONSTITUENTS AND
YOU KNOW ONE THING THAT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER IS THE NEED.
TO INVEST IN OUR PUBLIC HOUSING.
THE NEED TO INVEST IN OUR
PUBLIC HOUSING WHERE MANY BROWN
BLACK AND POOR WHITE FOLKS LIVE.
AND ENSURE THAT THEY TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS CRITICAL
SERVICE. MEMBERS WE DID THIS A
COUPLE YEARS AGO WE CALL THE
INTERNET FOR ALL. AND THAT WAS
THE SAME GROUP THAT- WORKED ON
SOME OF THIS WORK TODAY AND WE
KNEW THAT VAN. THAT THAT WAS
NOT ACHIEVING THE ULTIMATE GOAL.
WE BY THE GRACE OF A PANDEMIC
WE'RE BLESSED WITH SOME DOLLARS.
TO BE ABLE TO PUT FORWARD ON
WHAT BECAME ONE OF THE CLEAREST.
NEEDS THAT WE HAD. IN THE ONSET
OF THIS COLVIN NINETEEN SHUT
DOWN THAT REQUIRED US TO KEEP
OUR CHILDREN AT HOME CHANGE OUR
BUSINESS MODELS AND REALLY HOW
WE DO BUSINESS PERHAPS. FOR A
LONG LONG TIME TO COME. MY HOPE
IS THAT THOSE WHO DIDN'T RAISE
THEIR MIKE AND WILL HAVE BEEN
PULLING WITH THE IDEA OF NOT
SUPPORTING THE BILL STAYING OFF
THE BILL. THINK ABOUT THE
CHILDREN THAT YOU CONSTANTLY
TALK ABOUT ON THIS ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. THANK YOU CARE SO MUCH
ABOUT AND WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE CONNECTIVE ITTY
FOR THE PURPOSE OF A- GOOD
QUALITY EDUCATION. THANK YOU
THINK ABOUT THE OLD FOLKS WHO
LIVE IN CERTAIN PARTS OF THE
STATE THAT REQUIRE INTERNET
SERVICES TO ACCESS MEDICAL
ATTENTION. AND THAT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT YOU ALL CLAIM
TO REPRESENT AND ADVOCATE FOR.
ALSO HAVE THE ABILITY. TO
CONTINUE THEIR BUSINESS
TRANSACTIONS REGARDLESS OF A
WORLD PANDEMIC. WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TRULY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU DIG
DEEP INSIDE AND THINK ABOUT
THOSE FOLKS THAT I JUST
HIGHLIGHTED. AND REPRESENT THE
INTERESTS OF YOUR DISTRICT AND
NOT THE SPECIAL INTERESTS OF
SACRAMENTO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
GARCIA MISTER SATTAR YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. SO I OFFER A LITTLE
BIT OF A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
ON THIS ISSUE THIS ISSUE WE'RE
HAVING A DEBATE. IN THIS DEBATE
ISN'T ABOUT WHETHER IT'S GOOD
OR NOT. BECAUSE EVERYBODY IN
THIS ROOM. AGREES THAT IT'S
GOOD THE DEBATE IS HOW WE PAY
FOR IT. ARE WE GOING TO MAKE
THOSE VERY PEOPLE THAT WERE
SAYING ARE UNDERSERVED ARE WE
GONNA MAKE THEM PAY FOR THIS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
DOING. WE HAVE A WE HAVE AGAIN
THIRTY EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
AND I HEARD WE HAD A LITTLE
EXTRA MORTGAGE A LITTLE MORE
THAN THAT. THAT WE CAN MAKE
THESE INVESTMENTS WE HAVE A
BUNCH OF TRAILER BILLS TOMORROW
THIS CAN BE INCLUDED IN ONE OF
THOSE IF WE WANTED IT SO BADLY.
IT IS IMPORTANT. IT IS A
PRIORITY. OUR KIDS DO MATTER.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US AGREES
WITH THAT WHAT WE DON'T AGREE
WITH IS MAKING THEM PAY FOR IT.
WE NEED TO WE NEED TO USE THE
INVESTMENT. WE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE THE MONEY THAT WE
HAVE AND INVESTED IN THE THINGS
THAT ARE IMPORTANT. AND THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. SO FOR PETE'S
SAKE DON'T MAKE THEM PAY FOR IT.
WE PAY FOR WE'VE ALREADY PAID
FOR. WE HAVE THIRTY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS TO PAY FOR IT.
IT CAN BE DONE TOMORROW WELL
NOT NOW BUT- IF THAT WAS THE
PRIORITY IT COULD HAVE BEEN
FUNDED. THROUGH OUR OUR BUDGET
TRAILER BILL. AND WE DIDN'T DO
IT. SO THAT'S NOT THEIR FAULT
WE SHOULD BE SENDING THEIR
PARENTS A BILL AND BY THE WAY
EVEN THOUGH IT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE A LOT WHEN YOU START
ADDING UP ALL THE TAXES AND
FEES ON INTERNET. PRETTY MUCH
THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT ANYWAY SO
THEY WON'T HAVE BROADBAND. SO
THAT'S THAT'S THE REAL ISSUE IS
HOW DO WE PAY FOR IT. SO THAT
THEY CAN BE INCLUDED. SO THAT
IT DOESN'T MAKE THE CAR DRIVE
THE COST UP SO MUCH OF THEIR
PARENTS CAN'T EVEN AFFORD IT.
AND THEN THE ALL HAVE ACCESS TO
IT. WE NEED TO MAKE THAT OF
THAT INVESTMENT IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S PART OF
THE INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT'S WHAT
WE HAVE TO PAY FOR WITH THE
MONEY THAT WE ALREADY HAVE. SO
THAT'S WHERE I THINK THE DEBATE
REALLY SHOULD BE. AND INSTEAD
IT'S IT SOUNDS LIKE THE- WORK
WE'RE DEBATING THAT IF WE DON'T
WANT TO VOTE FOR THIS IT'S
BECAUSE WE DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
KIDS AND WE DON'T. REALLY WANT
TO ENTER THE BROADBAND BROUGHT
TO THEM WHEN THAT'S NOT TRUE AT
ALL. WHAT'S TRUE IS. HOW DO WE
PAY FOR WE HAVE THE MONEY. WE
SHOULD HAVE PUT THAT MONEY TO
WORK DOING EXACTLY THIS BECAUSE
THIS IS A PRIORITY FOR EVERYONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
FATTO SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU MAKE THOSE.
I'D LIKE TO THANK EVERYONE THE
SPOKE TODAY FOR AGAINST THE
BILL. AND AGAIN LIKE I SAID
BEFORE THE TIME IS NOW. YOU
KNOW- THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS THAT HAPPEN OUT OF
SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE THE YOU
DON'T MAY MAYBE THOUGHT ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WE HAD OUR CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND DO SOME
REALLY SUCCESSFUL PROJECTS THIS
PAST COUPLE YEARS. BUT THE
THING THAT I WANT TO KEEP
COMING BACK BECAUSE PEOPLE KEEP
THROWING IT IN MY FACE IS THE
SIX POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE EVER
DONE A INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT.
MANY OF YOU'VE DONE ONE. MAYBE
MAYBE SOME OF YOU HAVEN'T THEIR
EXPENSIVE. AND HOW YOU GO OUT
TO BID WHAT THEY ARE TODAY IS
NOT WHAT THEY'RE GOING INTO
BEING. SO THE SIX POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS TO ME IS JUST
THE START. JUST FOR INSTANCE TO
DAY THEY'RE SAYING YOU CAN NOT
GET FIBER. THE SUPPLY CHAIN IS
BROKEN MAYBE WE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT DOING A BILL ABOUT MAKING
FIBER HERE IN CALIFORNIA OR
WHATEVER THE CASE MIGHT BE A
FIVE FOR THE PRICE OF FIBERS
GOING TO GO UP THERE FOR THE
PRICE OF OUR PROJECTS GOING TO
GO UP. SO THAT IS WHAT WE HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT. LET'S NOT BE
LEFT HIGH AND DRY ALONG THE
WAY. YOU KNOW EXTENDING THE
EXISTING FEE WILL STABILIZE AND
MINIMIZE USER COST LONG TERM.
BECAUSE OTHERWISE USERS WILL
HAVE TO RELY HEREBY YEAR ON THE
STATE APPROVING IT THROUGH THE
GENERAL FUND. THAT OR CREATING
A NEW SURCHARGE IN THE FUTURE
TO PLAY CATCH UP ON THE UNMET
NEEDS. POLITICS LET'S NOT PLAY
THE GAME. LET'S DO RECKLESS TO
THIS IS JUST GET IT DONE. AND
ARE THERE GOING TO BE SOME OF
THE STEPS PROBABLY LET'S FACE
IT. BUT I'M TELLING YOU WE HAVE
A GROUP SUCH AS RC RC THAT WANT
TO START IMPLEMENTING THAT ARE
PUTTING TOGETHER IMPLEMENTATION
PLANS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW AS WE
SPEAK. WE'VE GOT GROUPS THAT
ARE ONE ENTREPRENEURS THAT ARE
LOOKING FOR US TO MOVE FORWARD.
WHERE PEOPLE ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
LOOKING AT WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO LET'S BE THE LEADER THERE'S
SOME RISKS WE HAVE TO TAKE.
WHEN I CAME ON TO THIS FLOOR I
KNEW I'D HAVE TO TAKE SOME
RISKS THAT'S WHAT THIS JOBS
ABOUT. SO LET'S NOT FORGET OUR
CONSTITUENTS PLEASE. LET'S NOT
FORGET ABOUT THE KIDS RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET. GO
THROUGH COBRA RIGHT NOW AND
THEY'RE TRYING TO GO THROUGH
CLASSES AND THEY CAN'T DO
INDEPENDENT STUDY RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
INTERNET AT HOME. AND THEY
DON'T QUALIFY FOR ABA UNTIL ALL
THE BILL PLATFORMS TAKING CARE
OF. EVERYBODY THIS IS AFFECTING
SO MANY PEOPLE. I CAN GO ON FOR
A LONG TIME AND YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN PASSION ABOUT IT. I DON'T
WANT TO LOOK BEHIND. WE NEED TO
DO IT NOW. S. RIVAL CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE A. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRED OF A. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRED ABOUT THIS
REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR.
OUR
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRTY VOTE THIS
REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR.
ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE A.
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A
SURPRISE PARTY FOR.
MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY MUSICAL.
MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NINETY SIX SB SIXTY TO THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE THIRD
READING FILE ITEM NINETY SIX SB
SIXTY TO. 62% OF THE RAZA AND
OTHERS NOT GOING TO EMPLOYMENT.
IF YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
I AM VERY EXCITED COLLEAGUES TO
INTRODUCE A BILL THAT- HAS BEEN
LITERALLY SAT ON MY DESK AT THE
END OF SESSION LAST YEAR AND WE
CAN BRING FORWARD IT IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT BILL- SB SIXTY TWO
EXPANDS AND STRENGTHENS
ENFORCEMENT OF WAGE THEFT IN
THE GARMENT MANUFACTURING
INDUSTRY ENSURING THAT
RETAILERS CANNOT USE LAYERS OF
CONTRACTING TO AVOID
RESPONSIBILITY UNDER THE LAW.
FASHION BRANDS HAVE CREATED
POVERTY WAGES THROUGH THE
UNREALISTIC PRICING OF GARMENTS
YET HAVE NO LEGAL LIABILITY FOR
THE EXPLOITATION WHICH OCCURS.
A REPORT BY THE UCLA LABOR
CENTER DOCUMENTED THAT THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY AS HAVING THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF WAGE THAT
VIOLATION BY INDUSTRY AND
SECOND HIGHEST BY OCCUPATION.
COMBINED WITH AN ARCHAIC SYSTEM
OF PAIN PIECE RATE BASED ON
UNATTAINABLE PRODUCTION TARGETS
MINIMUM WAGE IS ALWAYS OUT OF
REACH FOR THESE WORKERS. AS
SUBCONTRACTORS SKIRT THE LAW
THOUSANDS OF GARMENT WORKERS
ARE LEFT UNABLE TO RECOVER
STOLEN WAGES WHILE RETAILERS
CONTINUE TO PROFIT. TO ENSURE
RETAILERS ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
AND GARMENT WORKERS ARE MADE
WHOLE AND PROTECTED FROM WAGE
THEFT SB SIXTY TWO WELL LIMON A
PIECE RATE TO ENSURE WORKERS
ARE PAID WAGES FOR ALL OF THEIR
TIME SPENT WORKING WHILE STILL
ALLOWING FOR INCENTIVE BASED
BONUSES. AND EXPAND MY ABILITY
FOR WAGE VIOLATIONS CREATE A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION AS TO
THE IDENTITIES OF THE BRANDS
BASED ON GARMENT WORKERS
TESTIMONY AND EXPLICITLY
AUTHORIZES THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO INVESTIGATE
INSIGHT BRAND GUARANTORS. TO BE
CLEAR RECENT AMENDMENTS LIMIT
LIABILITY. FOR GRAND FOR BRAM
AGAIN TEARS TO ONLY WAGES NOT
DAMAGES AND PENALTIES. OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY FASHION INDUSTRY
BUSINESSES HAVE ENDORSED THIS
BILL AND ARE LEADING THE CHARGE
FOR AN ETHICAL WORKPLACE IN THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY. WE'VE ALSO
HEARD FROM THESE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS TO MAKE THE COUNTRY'S
MASK RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
FOR AS LITTLE AS TWO CENTS
APIECE. SB SIXTY TWO IS ALLEGE
THEY WOMEN'S PRIORITY BILL THAT
WILL ALLOW LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS PARTY BILL THAT WILL
ALLOW WORKING WOMEN TO REGAIN
MILLIONS OF STOLEN. DOLLARS IN
WAGES AND WILL HELP THEIR
FAMILIES THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
THE TAXPAYERS WHO HAVE
SUBSIDIZED THIS RAMPANT WAGE
THEFT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
GONZALEZ MISS GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AND I'LL THANK YOU I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY TWO
AS THE CHAIR THE LET'S SAY THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS THIS IS ONE OF
OUR TOP PRIORITY BILLS THIS
YEAR. I DON'T TALK ABOUT EVERY
OFF THE MODEM ON THE SEX AT
GARMENT WORKER FOR A REALLY
LONG TIME GROWING UP I AND IN
L. A. INSULT PIECEMEAL AS HOW
SHE EARNS HER LIVING FOR A LONG
TIME AND MEANT THAT OFTENTIMES
SHE WOULD BRING HER WORK HOME
THIS IS AFTER WORKING FROM SIX
IN THE MORNING TO FIVE PM EVERY
DAY. IT ALSO MEANT THAT PRESS
KIDS. WOULD PITCH IN WHERE WE
COULD TO HELP HER GET A WORK
DONE- BUT IT MEANT THAT YOU
COULDN'T ATTEND ANY OTHER
SCHOOL ACTIVITIES AND IF THERE
IS A PLAN CONFERENCE. THE FIRST
QUESTION WAS ARE YOU IN
TROUBLE. IN CELLS LIKE KNOWS
THAT GOOD BECAUSE I HAVE TIME
FOR YOU TO BINGE I WILL NOT
HAVE TIME TO GO TO GO TO
SCHOOL. SO TO SPEAK GIVE YOUR
BEFORE CARTER ME HOME TO ME
THANK YOU. ALONG THE WAY AND SO
IT'S NOT JUST FOR THE ODD OF
WOMEN MOSTLY WOMEN WHO ARE
WORKING. PERFECTLY BUT THEIR
FAMILIES BY THIS A PIECEMEAL
OUT THERE. IS A REALLY NEED TO
REFORM. THE WAY WE DO. THIS
WORK OUT THERE. I'M INCREDIBLY
PROUD OF THE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
BUSINESSES. MOSTLY WELL LED BY
WOMEN SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
BEING. WHO ARE LEADING THE
CHARGE FOR ETHICAL WORKPLACE.
INSISTING ABILITY IN THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY THEY'RE
ALREADY DOING A LOT OF WHAT
THIS BILL IS. ASKING US TO DO.
I'M ESPECIALLY PROUD OF THE
GARMENT WORKERS HAVE BEEN
LEADING THIS WAY FOR YEARS.
LAST MONTH THEY BOARDED BUSES
TO THE CAPITAL IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT AFTER LEVY LAUNCHES.
IN THEIR FACTORIES TO ADVOCATE
FOR THE RIGHT TO SIMPLY GET
MONEY THEY HAVE EARNED.
UNFORTUNATELY WITH THAT THAT IS
WIDESPREAD IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THE GARMENT WORKERS IN THE
STATE EXPERIENCE WHICH THAT
THAT AT ALARMINGLY HIGH RATE.
FORMER WORKERS MAY BE P. AND L.
A. OFTEN FOR JUST FOUR DOLLARS
OR FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR AND
SEVERAL OF OUR ROOM WORKERS
LOST THEIR LIVES AFTER. AT
THEIR WORKPLACE OUTBREAKS
OCCURRED IN NINETEEN THIS
INCLUDED A LOT OF MY NEIGHBORS
LITERALLY MY NEIGHBORS NEXT TO
ME WE'RE SICK WE'RE COMING HOME
WITH THE SICKNESS. ALONG THE
WAY AS THEY WERE BEING DOZENS
OF WORKERS THAT WE NEEDED TO
KEEP US SAFE AND PROVIDE THE P.
P. THAT WE NEEDED. NO ONE
SHOULD HAVE TO WORK FOR LESS
THAN MINIMUM WAGE. WHILE THE
MINIMUM WAGE IS HAS WRECKED HAS
RIGHTFULLY BEEN RISING
CALIFORNIA. TO KEEP UP WITH THE
COST OF LIVING. A SAMPLE OF THE
MAJORITY OF THE FORTY SIX
THOUSAND GARMENT WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET HOPE.
AREN'T JUST A THIRD OF THAT
MINIMUM WAGE TO PIECEMEAL AND
LACK OF BROWN ACCOUNTABILITY.
THESE WOMEN ARE THE BACKBONE OF
OUR PROSPEROUS FASHION
INDUSTRY. THAT IS GOING AN
ALLEY YET DESPITE THEIR
ESSENTIAL SKILL WORK. THIS
WOMAN ARE FACING SOMEWHERE
SWITCHED UP CONDITIONS TO
EUROPEAN IMMIGRANTS. WOMEN FOR
THE NINETEEN HUNDREDS. IT'S
LONGER WE DO THAT WE PASSED SB
SIXTY TWO. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LA AND MY
COLLEAGUE METHODICAL. FOR
WORKING ON THIS ON BEHALF OF
ALL THE WOMEN OUT THERE LIKE MY
MOM. THAT THE SACRIFICE IN ABU
SACRIFICE UP FOR A LONG TIME.
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE WITH BEST
FOR THEIR KIDS ALONG THE WAY
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA MISTER
CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND THE MEMBERS OF. YOUR TOOL
COMMENT ON MANUFACTURERS SOUGHT
AND I REGION WHO HAVE EXPRESSED
A GREAT CONCERN WITH THE SP
SIXTY TWO I. RISE SO TO SPEAK
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. ARE YOU
SYMPATHIZE SO WITH THE ARE
COMMON WORKERS SO WHO ARE NOT
PAID THE MINIMUM WAGE OVERTIME
AND OVER OR NOT THE PROVIDED A
SAFE WORKING ENVIRONMENT. WHAT
THE- WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
IGNORING. THE A ROOT CAUSE
SILVA PROBLEMS THAT EXIST IN
THE GARMENT INDUSTRY WHICH IS
THE I NEED FOR INCREASED
ENFORCEMENT OF EXISTING LAWS
AND EDUCATION FOR WORKERS AND
THE EMPLOYERS. ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA SUNDAY FOR LOSS.
NOTHING IN THIS. SB SIXTY TWO
ADDRESSES- THE BAD ACTORS IN
THE GARMENT INDUSTRY WHO CHOOSE
TO BLATANTLY IGNORE CALIFORNIA
SO ROBO START LABEL COURSE A
SPECIFIC TO THE GARMENT
INDUSTRY. SB SIX DID TO- WILL
ELIMINATE THE CONTRACTING IN
THE APPAREL INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA YES AND NO COMPANY
IT WILL NOT TAKE ON THE A
POTENTIAL LIABILITY OF WAR
HAVING TO PAY FOR. WAGES AND
THE OUR VIOLATIONS SO IT DID
NOT COMMIT OR PAYING THE
ATTORNEY'S FEES FOR ANOTHER
COMPANY SO LITIGATION. THESE
SAW EMPLOYERS ARE ARE ARE
ALREADY ARE SUFFERING FROM THE
FINANCIAL CRISIS OF THE
PANDEMIC AND- THIS BILL COULD
FORCE THEM OUT OF BUSINESS WHAT
WORDS MAKE THEM LEAVE A
CALIFORNIA LIKE MANY OTHERS I
HAVE DONE SO FAR. TOOL
MANUFACTURER ALL TOOL- THE
STATE'S WAR ON THE COUNTRY'S OF
BECAUSE IT IS NOT. THE ONE ON
THE RISK. I KNOW THIS BECAUSE
SO. OUR I READ THE FRONT PAGE
IN NEW. ARE SO SEVERAL TIMES IN
MY DISTRICT NOW WHAT DEEPLY
CONCERNED CALIFORNIA HAS SOUGHT
ELEVEN LABEL ALSO SPECIFIC TO
COMMENT THE- WORKERS UP TO
PROTECT THEIR WAGES UP AND
ENSURE SAFE WORKING.
ENVIRONMENTS WHAT WE SHOULD DO
IS ALL WORK TOGETHER TO
STRENGTHEN THOSE THE EXISTING
LAWS EXPOSE A BAD ACTORS AND A
KID. BUSINESSES ARE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THIS IS SUCH A JOB
KILLER AS WE'LL KNOW VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE
RISE OF PROFITABLE CO AUTHORED
SB SIXTY TWO. CURRENT WORKERS
HAVE FOUGHT TIRELESSLY TO
COMBAT WAGE THEFT A WORKPLACE
VIOLATIONS. THE GARMENT WORKERS
DON'T WANT OUR SYMPATHY. THEY
DEMAND AND DESERVE JUSTICE AND
DIGNITY. BORRACHOS IN
CALIFORNIA OFFER WORTH MORE
THAN TWELVE HOURS PER DAY IN
SIXTY TO SEVENTY HOURS PER WEEK
WHILE RECEIVING ONLY THIRTY SIX
DOLLARS PER HOUR WELL BELOW THE
STATE'S MINIMUM WAGE. ARM
INDUSTRY EMPLOYERS ARE OFTEN
FAILING TO PROVIDE WORKERS WITH
BASIC MINIMUM WAGE AND OVERTIME
PAY. WHICH TAKES A HEAVY
FINANCIAL TOLL WORKERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND UNDERMINE
THE RESILIENCE OF THE
COMMUNITIES. WHEN RESPONSIBLE
RETAILERS MANUFACTURERS
ENVIRONMENT CONTRACTORS ARE
FORCED TO COMPETE WITH
UNSCRUPULOUS GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYERS WHO VIOLATE THE LAW
THE RESULT IS A RACE TO THE
BOTTOM. THAT BRINGS DOWN
STANDARDS THROUGHOUT THE
INDUSTRY RESPONSIBLE RETAILERS
WAS SPONSORING A MANUFACTURER A
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE. IN
ITS PUREST SENSE. THIS BILL IS
SIMPLE WHOSE SIDE ARE YOU ON.
ARE YOU ON SIDE OF THE WORK OF
THE PREDOMINANTLY WOMAN WORKER
WOMEN OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS ARE
BEING TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF. OR
ARE YOU ON THE SIDE OF THOSE
WHO EXPLOIT THESE WORKERS. IT
IS TIME TO END LEGALIZED WAGE
THEFT IT IS TIME TO END
LEGALIZED EXPLOITATION I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AND I VOTE ON
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA MISS DAVIES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. THANK
YOU THEN SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY
ARE RISING RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO SB SIXTY TWO. WE
SAW THIS BILL COME THROUGH
JUDICIARY AND I BROUGHT UP
THESE CONCERNS THEN AND THE
BILL STILL HAS NOT ADDRESS
THEM. JOINT LIABILITY PRESENTLY
EXIST IN THE GARMENT INDUSTRY
SB SIXTY TWO TRIES TO EXPAND
THAT JOINT LIABILITY FAR BEYOND
WHAT EXISTS IN ANY OTHER
INDUSTRY. COMPANIES WERE
PRESUMED JOINTLY AND SEVERALLY
LIABLE FOR ALL WAGES OWED TO
WORKERS INCLUDING WORK DONE
UNDER SOMEONE ELSE'S CONTRACT.
THAT JOINT LIABILITY EXTENDS
EVEN TO A COMPANY THAT OWNS THE
LICENSE FOR DESIGNER CHARACTER
ON THE GOVERNMENT NO OTHER
INDUSTRY WITH JOINT LIABILITY
HAS SUCH BROAD PROVISIONS. WE
ALREADY HAVE LAWS TO ADDRESS
ALL OF THESE ISSUES RAISED BY
THE PROPONENTS OF THE BILL BUT
THEY ARE NOT BEING ENFORCED.
ENFORCEMENT OF THE GARMENT
MANUFACTURING REGISTRATION
REQUIREMENTS MINIMUM WAGE LAWS
AND OVERTIME LAWS ARE NEEDED TO
LIMON EIGHT THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY. THIS BILL DOES NOTHING
TO STOP MANUFACTURERS WHO ARE
OPERATING ILLEGALLY IT MERELY
TRIES TO PASS A BILL TO SOMEONE
ELSE. GOOD COMPANIES WILL MOVE
WHAT LITTLE BEEN AFFECTING
THEIR DOING HERE IN CALIFORNIA
TO OTHER STATES AND COUNTRIES
BECAUSE IT'S NOT WORTH THE
REST. THEY WERE DESIGNED HERE
AND SELL HERE BUT THEY WILL NOT
MANUFACTURE HERE UNTIL THESE
CONCERNS ARE ADDRESSED I'M
ASKING TO OPPOSE SB SIXTY TWO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS DAVIS
MISS AMERICA TWO G. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. SB
SIXTY TWO AND I WANT TO SHARE.
THIS IS LIKE A BLAST FROM THE
PAST FOR ME WHEN I WAS IN LAW
SCHOOL I WORKED WITH THE- A
WONDERFUL ORGANIZATION CALLED
THE- KARAN IMMIGRANT WORKERS
ADVOCATES AND- BACK IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES THEY WERE
ENGAGED AND A BOYCOTT CAMPAIGN
AGAINST THE- A POPULAR. BRAND
FOR WEDDING DRESSES THAT JUST
COME UP MCCLINTOCK- BRAND AND-
I REMEMBER THEN THAT- YOU KNOW
THEY THEY THEY- THE THEY THEY
WERE SINGLED OUT BECAUSE THEY
WERE CONTRACTING WITH THESE
ESSENTIALLY THESE THESE FLY BY
NIGHT SWEAT SHOPS THAT- THAT
WOULD THAT WOULD TO. YOU KNOW-
MAKE THEIR PARTS OF THE OF
THESE BEAUTIFUL WHAT WOULD END
UP BEING THE BEAUTIFUL WEDDING
DRESSES- AND WHEN THE WHEN THE
LABOR ENFORCEMENT WOULD TRY TO
GOAL OUR GOAL AFTER THESE FLY
BY NIGHT OPERATIONS THEY WOULD
JUST SHUT DOWN AND THEY WOULD
JUST. REFORM UNDER ANOTHER YOU
KNOW CORPORATE ENTITY AND SO
YOU KNOW IT IT SOUNDS LIKE. NOT
MUCH HAS CHANGED. IN THESE
DECADES THAT THE THAT IS THE
PROBLEM WITH TRYING TO. GO OVER
A GO AFTER THESE BAD ACTORS IN
TO ENFORCE EXISTING LAWS IS
THAT THERE'S ALL KINDS OF THESE
THESE CORPORATE SHELL GAMES.
WHERE WERE YOU CREATE THESE
THESE- AGAIN THE THESE FLY BY
NIGHT SWEAT SHOPS THAT THAT
THAT JUST WENT WHEN YOU TRY TO.
ENFORCE THE LAW THAT THEY JUST
SHUT DOWN AND REFORM UNDER
ANOTHER CORPORATE ENTITY AND SO
THAT'S WHY I THINK. YOU KNOW
THAT THIS- JOINT AND SEVERAL
LIABILITY FOR THE MANUFACTURER
FOR THE BRAND GUARANTOR IS SO
IMPORTANT. WE NEED TO PROTECT
OUR MOST VUNERABLE. WORKERS
ARE GARMENT WORKERS AND THAT'S
WHY IT RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI THE THREE OF US YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY AS A CO
AUTHOR AND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB SIXTY TWO- WHICH WOULD END
WAGE THEFT IN THE GARMENT
INDUSTRY. IN LOS ANGELES WE
HAVE ABOUT FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
GARMENT WORKERS WITH THOUSANDS
FROM THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY.
WHERE I. LIVE AND- WHO WORK
TWELVE HOUR. DAYS AND ARE PAID
BY THE PIECE SOMETIMES AS LOW
AS THREE CENTS APIECE. I
PERSONALLY HAVE SEEN HOW
EXPLOITED THESE WORKERS- HAVE
BEEN OF MY BABY CENTER WHEN I
WAS YOUNGER- LIKE A MIDDLE
SCHOOL KID. FAMILY FRIEND
WORKED IN THE GARMENT INDUSTRY
AND OFTEN TIMES WE HAD TO GO
THERE. TO PICK UP THE KEYS ARE
OUR LUNCH. AND I WOULD SEE. HOW
THESE WORKERS ARE EXPLOITED
THEY'RE GETTING PAID BY THE
PIECE AND LIKE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM. BELL GARDENS MENTIONED
THIS WOMAN ALSO WOULD TAKE THE
WORK HOME. AND WOULD HAVE HER
CHILDREN HELPER BECAUSE SHE WAS
GETTING PAID BY THE PIECE THIS
WAS A SINGLE MOTHER. THE
MAJORITY OF THE WORKERS IN THIS
INDUSTRY ARE WOMEN. AND WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
GETTING PAID AT LEAST MINIMUM
WAGE. IF A GARMENT BUSINESS
CAN'T PAY ITS WORKERS A LIVING
WAGE THEN THEY DON'T HAVE A
GARMENT BUSINESS THAT'S NOT
WHAT A BUSINESS IS- WE HAVE TO
HOLD THIS INDUSTRY ACCOUNTABLE
AND FIGHT. FOR THESE WOMEN IN
THE INDUSTRY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SB SIXTY
TWO. THANK YOU MISS REAVIS
MISTER FLOOR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THE MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER- COLLEAGUES I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS. PARTICULAR
BILL. THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS I
WANT TO JUST ADDRESS- THIS IDEA
THAT- HIS WORK IS THIS ROOT OF
ALL EVIL. THERE'S A LOT OF
INDUSTRIES WHERE IT WORKS
REALLY REALLY WELL HE TAKE THE
AUTO INDUSTRY- AN AUTO
MANUFACTURER. ALLOWS X. AMOUNT
OF HOURS TO DO A BRAKE JOB ON A
VEHICLE. A LOT OF MECHANICS ARE
REALLY REALLY FAST DOING GREAT
JOBS ON THAT PARTICULAR
VEHICLES WHAT THEY DO DAY IN
AND DAY OUT. THEY CAN GET IT
DONE QUICKER. THAN THE ALLOTTED
TIME THAT THEY'VE BEEN GIVEN.
THAT'S A GOOD THING. BUT MAKING
MORE MONEY BECAUSE A QUICKER AT
THEIR JOB. THAT'S A REALLY GOOD
THING. WE ALREADY HAVE LAWS ON
THE BOOKS TO ADDRESS THIS.
WE'VE DONE NOTHING ON THE
ENFORCEMENT SIDE OF THINGS.
BECAUSE OF THE UNPRECEDENTED
JOINT LIABILITY ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IN THE
PROVISIONS. COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT DO WHAT LITTLE
MANUFACTURE WE DO IN THE STATE.
ARE GOING TO MOVE OUTSIDE OF IT.
BECAUSE OF THE BIRDS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO PUT ON TOP OF THEM
AS A LEGISLATOR AT THE BUILDING
OF THE BODY. WE WANT TO TALK
ABOUT WAGE THEFT. WAIT STAFF
HAS WITH ALL OF THOSE JOBS MOVE
OUT OF THE STATE. MAYES WAIT
STAFF IS WITH ALL OF THOSE JOBS
GO TO CAMBODIA GO TO KOREA GO
TO VIETNAM. THAT'S WHERE THE
MAJORITY OF OUR GARMENTS ARE
MADE. IF WE WANT TO KEEP OUR
CALIFORNIANS WORKING. WE NEED
TO ENFORCE THE LAWS ON THE BOOK.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
COMPANY I'M SORRY A STATE. THAT
IS BUSINESS FRIENDLY. WE NEED
TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO COME IN
UNDER A SET OF RULES AND WE
NEED TO ENFORCE THOSE BUT THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
WILL DO NONE OF THAT WE'RE
GONNA DRIVE WHAT LITTLE WE HAVE
LEFT ALL THE STATE AND I
STRONGLY URGE. A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU MR FOR A MYSTERY- YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE MATTER. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AYE PRY AYE YOU PROBABLY RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY TWO AS
A- AS A CO OP OP AS A CO AUTHOR
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF. THE
GARMENT WORKER PROTECTION ACT
THIS BILL. AND THE ABUSES AND
SWEATSHOPS BUT IT IS NOT AS
RELEVANT TO CALIFORNIA IT IS
RELEVANT ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
ROSS THE FASHION INDUSTRY AND
BEYOND AS JUST SO MENTIONED. BY
OUR COLLEAGUE THAT THIS IS IN
FACT A GLOBAL SYSTEMIC PROBLEM.
A ROOT CAUSE OF INEQUALITY IS A
LACK OF LABOR RIGHTS AND
FINANCIAL RECORDS FOR PEOPLE
FOR WORKING PEOPLE WHO ARE
LABELED INDIRECT EMPLOYEES AND
SUPPLY CHAINS ACROSS BIG
COMPANIES CURRENTLY THERE ARE
WORKERS MOSTLY WOMEN MOSTLY
WOMEN OF COLOR. WHO ARE WORKING
SIXTY TO SEVENTY HOURS A WEEK
FOR AN AVERAGE OF ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A DAY. YOU
CAN'T FEED A FAMILY WITH TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS A DAY. OR
A WEEK I'M SORRY. YOU CAN'T PAY
YOUR RENT WITH TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS A WEEK. THE
AMERICAN DREAM DOESN'T BECOME A
REALITY WITH TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS A WEEK. EARLIER
IN THIS LEGISLATIVE PROCESS I
MET A WOMAN HER NAME IS LESSEN
YOUR OTHER FEE NOT FROM MY
COMMUNITY IN LOS ANGELES. SHE
IS THE CHAIRMAN IDEA FROM
GUATEMALA. SHE'S INDIGENOUS.
AND SHE EARNS AN AVERAGE OF
THREE TO FIVE DOLLARS A DAY.
HER ACTIONS OF WANTING TO BE A
PART OF A PROCESS THAT DEFENDS
HER RIGHTS HER DESIRE TO BE
ABLE TO FEED HER FAMILY. HER
LOVE OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
WHERESHE IS RAISING HER FAMILY
AND WHERE SHE HOPES TO BE ABLE
TO STAY IN LIVE. CAN'T COMPETE.
WITH ONLY EARNING THREE TWO
FIVE DOLLARS THROUGH PIECEMEAL-
IN HER INDUSTRY AND IN THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY IN GENERAL.
AND WHAT I TOLD HER WHEN I MET
HER WAS HER WORK HAS VALUE HER
WORK HAS DIGNITY AND SHE IS
DESERVING. OF A LIVING WAGE. SB
SIXTY TO CREATE THE STRUCTURE
OF ACCOUNTABILITY FOR WAGE
THEFT IN A DOES AWAY WITH THE
RACE TO THE BOTTOM FUELED BY
THE INHUMANE EXPLOITATION. OF
VULNERABLE WORKERS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO SEE. ACROSS VARIOUS
INDUSTRIES IN OUR STATE. IT IS
TIME TO EXTEND PROTECTIONS TO
GARMENT WORKERS AND TO ENSURE
THAT THEIR RIGHTS PROTECTIONS
WAGES AND BENEFITS MATCH THOSE
NEEDS MANY GARMENT WORKERS WHO
WERE MAKING THE MASS THAT MANY
OF US ARE CURRENTLY WEARING AND
HAVE BEEN WEARING. FOR THE PAST
NINETEEN MONTHS AMID A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC SUFFERED THE MOST.
WERE THE MOST IMPACTED BY
COVERT. AND DIED BECAUSE OF
COLD IT AND ALL THEY ARE ASKING
IS TO BE SEEN TO BE RECOGNIZED
AND TO BE VALUED FOR THEIR
WORK. THAT IS WHY I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON SB SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU
MISS CARILLO MISTER JOHN SO ARE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT AS A
CO AUTHOR OF SB SIXTY TWO. THIS
IS A TIMELY BUILDER LOOKS TO
ELIMINATE THE EXPLOITIVE
PRACTICE OF THE PIECE RATE
SYSTEM IN THE GARMENT INDUSTRY.
AND ENSURE WORKERS ARE GIVEN
BASIC LABOR PROTECTIONS. IS
UNACCEPTABLE FOR WORKERS MOST
OF WHOM ARE IMMIGRANT WOMEN TO
SPEND COUNTLESS HOURS MAKING
CLOTHING OR PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT ONLY TO PAY EIGHT
CENTS FOR EVERY PIECE EQUALLY
AS LITTLE AS FIVE DOLLARS AN
HOUR. THIS INDUSTRY CANNOT BE
ALLOWED TO CONTINUE THRIVING ON
WORKER EXPLOITATION WITH A ROB
CLOSE TO SIX HUNDRED ANDNINE
DOLLARS IN WAGES. DURING AN
AVERAGE WEEK WORK. AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW MY MOTHER WORKED IN
THE GARMENT INDUSTRY. I USED TO
VISIT HER. WHERE SHE WORKED
DOWN THE STREET FROM THE
UNIVERSITY I WENT TO. AND I SAW
HER AND OTHER WOMEN THERE
WORKING EVERY DAY. I ACTUALLY
GOT FIRSTHAND EXPERIENCE OF
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE A GARMENT
WORKER MAKING THESE CLOTHES FOR
THESE WEALTHY. DEPARTMENT
STORES WHO WOULD SELL THEM FOR
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS AND THEN THEY WOULD
COME BACK TO THE ORIGINAL JOB
WORKERS WOULD GO TO ONES THAT
DID IT AND IT WOULD SELL IT FOR
TEN CENTS ON THE DOLLAR. SO I
ALSO KNOW. WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE
ON MADISON LEE LINE AND I WILL
TELL YOU IS NOT LIKE BEING AT A
FORD PLANT NOT BEEN TO A FORD
PLANT IT TO COMPARE THE TWO IS
NOT RIGHT IN ON JUST THIS THE
COMPANY EVENTUALLY WENT TO
TEXAS. AND SO THEY COULD GET
BETTER DEAL PAID LOWER WAGES
AND HE JUST LEFT BILLS WORKERS.
MY MOTHER IS NOW IN THEIR OLDER
YEARS NO RETIREMENT THE
COMPANY'S LONG BEEN GONE. AND
SHE WAS EXPLOITED FOR ALL. AND
SO I NOT ONLY KNOW WHAT HAPPENS
TO THEM IN REAL TIME RIGHT NOW
BUT I ALSO KNOW THE DEVASTATING
EFFECT OF GARMENT WORKERS NOT
HAVING THE ABILITY. TO HAVE.
THE TYPE OF WAGES THAT THEY
NEED SO THEY CAN HAVE NOTONLY
A LIFESTYLE THAT CAN FEED YOUR
FAMILY AND MOVE ON BUT TO BE
ABLE TO GO ON BEYOND THAT
MOSTLY WHEN THEY RETIRE. AND SO
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING. OF
US ACTUALLY TAKING CARE OF
THOSE WHERE A LOT OF US DON'T
EVEN THINK ABOUT THEM BECAUSE
WE JUST ENJOYED THE GARMENTS
THAT WE HAVE ON RIGHT NOW.
WHERE WE SIT. AND YOU JUST NEED
TO REALIZE. THERE'S SOME PEOPLE
WHO. MAKE VERY VERY LITTLE. SO
YOU CAN LOOK VERY VERY GOOD.
WHEN YOU COME IT IS CAPITAL.
AND WE NEED TO PROTECT THEM. WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THEY GET THE
PRICE PAID TO PROPER WAGES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISS GONZALEZ YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU- I JUST I
WANT TO BRING. ADDRESS
SOMETHING THAT A NUMBER OF-
THOSE WHO OPPOSE THIS BILL
BROUGHT UP IN THIS THE NOTION
THAT THERE'S NO EFFORTS TO
CRACK DOWN ON THIS TYPE OF WAGE
THEFT. THERE HAS BEEN THERE
HAVE BEEN FOR DECADES LIKE MY
COLLEAGUES FROM ON THE LOS
ANGELES AREA WAS SAYING IT FROM
TORRANCE WHAT THISGONNA IT
DIDN'T TEST MY KNOWLEDGE HERE-
WAS SAYING YOU KNOW THE JESSICA
MCCLINTOCK BOYCOTT WE'VE SEEN
AT. IN FACT OUR PREVIOUS- LABOR
SECRETARY NOW NUMBER TWO IF
THEY IF THEY US DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR AT SHE MADE HER CAREER
OUT OF TRYING TO GO AFTER THESE
COMPANIES. BUT LIKE IN ALL WAGE
THEFT WHAT HAPPENS AND IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS ACHIEVABLE
WHEN YOU HAVE BUSINESSES THAT
WILL POP UP. ABUSE WORKERS AND
THEN LITERALLY DISAPPEAR. THERE
IS NO RECOURSE THERE IS NO WAY
TO MAKE THE WORKER HOLE WHEN
THAT HAPPENS AND IT HAPPENS
OVER AND OVER AGAIN IT'S LIKE
PLAYING WHACK A MOLE. AND SO
WHAT WE DID IN THE STATE I WE
HAVE A FRONT WE HAVE A FUND
THAT ALL OF US IN FACT IN THIS
LAST BUDGET PUT MONEY INTO TO
TRY TO RECLAIM SOME OF THE
WAGES FOR THOSE WORKERS HAVE
BEEN STOLEN FROM OUR- SO WE AS
TAXPAYERS ARE SUBSIDIZING THIS
ABUSE OF SUBCONTRACTORS. BUT
THE FOLKS WHO ARE ACTUALLY
PURCHASED SEEN THAT CLOTHING
FROM THE CONTRACTOR. LIKE
FOREVER TWENTY ONE FASHION NOVA
THEY KNOW THE DEMANDS ARE
MAKING ON THAT SUBCONTRACTOR
DON'T PAY ENOUGH FOR THAT
WORKER TO BE MAKING MINIMUM
WAGE THEY SHOULD BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE THEY ARE THE ONES
PROFITING OFF THAT CHEAP LABOR
IN THE END. THERE IS A
RESPONSIBILITY OF THOSE. BRAND
GUARANTORS TO ENSURE THAT THIS
ISN'T HAPPENING. AND THEY'RE
ABLE TO DO THAT. AND WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE ABUSE OF
GARMENT WORKERS FOR EVER. FOR
FAR TOO LONG IT'S TIME THAT
CALIFORNIA STAND UP AND NOT SAY
OH MY GOD SOMEBODY MIGHT LEAVE
THE STATE. NO MAYBE WILL TAKE
AN INDUSTRY THAT IS ABUSIVE NOT
JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT NEW YORK
AND INTERNATIONALLY AND START
TO MAKE A DENT IN THAT ABUSE
THAT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY THESE
ARE CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE DOING
THIS WORK. AND TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM RIPON WHO. SUGGESTED THAT
SOMEHOW PIECE WORK IS A GOOD
THING AND IT CAN BE WHERE YOU
GET INCENTIVES FOR DOING WORK
QUICKER YOU CAN MAKE MORE MONEY
THAT'S AVAILABLE UNDER THIS
BILL. THE TRUTH IS THE PEACE
WORK THAT THEY'RE BEING PAID
FOR YOU NEVER EVEN HIT MINIMUM
WAGE THESE ARE AUTO WORKERS
THESE ARE WOMEN IN SWEATSHOP
LIKE CONDITIONS S
R TWO CENTS TO CENTS PER ITEM
CAN YOU IMAGINE I REMEMBER
HEARING FROM ONE WOMAN WHO TOLD
ME AT FIRST SHE THOUGHT SHE DID
A GOOD JOB. BECAUSE BEFORE SHE
HAD THE JOB IN THE GARMENT
INDUSTRY SHE WAS HUMAN
TRAFFICKED AND GOT ZERO DOLLARS
SO SHE THOUGHT IT WAS OKAY
BECAUSE SHE WAS MAKING MONEY
AND THEN REALIZED THAT SHE
COULD NEVER MAKE ENOUGH MONEY
TO GET BY. AND SHE TOLD ME THE
STORY ABOUT HOW SHE HAD THIS
CHILD HER DAUGHTER AND SHE HAD
TO KEEP THAT CHILD IN A BOX
NEXT TO HER HER HER- SELLING
MACHINE BECAUSE SHE COULDN'T
STOP SHE COULDN'T AFFORD CHILD
CARE FOR HER CHILD SHE
LITERALLY HAD A CHILD IN A BOX
IN THE SEWING MACHINE AND SHE'S
MAKING YOUR TWO CENTS MASK.
THAT SOMEBODY SOLD TO YOU FOR
TEN DOLLARS. WELL THAT. WHO
SOLD IT TO YOU FOR TEN DOLLARS
NEEDS TO MAKE HER WHOLE.
BECAUSE THEIR WHOLE THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT IT'S ABOUT
ENSURING THAT EVERYBODY IN THE
STATE WHO DOES WORK. GET A
MINIMUM WAGE MY GOD IT'S TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE'RE FIGHTING FOR
WORKERS TO EARN A MINIMUM WAGE.
AND HOLDING PEOPLE RESPONSIBLE
FOR MAKING THE PROFITS OFF OF
THEIR LOW PAY IF WE CAN'T DO
THAT I DON'T KNOW WHAT WE CAN
DO. I IMPLORE YOU THAT THE TIME
HAS COME TO ENSURE GARMENT
WORKERS HAVE BASIC HUMAN
DIGNITY. ANOTHER SO THAT
THEY'RE PROTECTED IN THE
WORKPLACE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROAD. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO THIRTY VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE A-
CLERK. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS
FORTY THREE NEWS FOURTEEN THAT
EITHER PASSES.
MEMBERS. DURING
THIS BREAK IN OUR REGULAR
PROGRAMMING WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
UP SOME ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
SO I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR
GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO MR
MAIENSCHEIN. THE THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE BEFORE YOU
TODAY WITH A HEAVY HEART TO
REQUEST THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED
IN MEMORY OF BRUCE BROWN WHO
PASSED AWAY ON JUNE THIRD.
BRUCE HAS A VERY LONG AND
DISTINGUISHEDRECORD IS A
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVICE
SERVANT FOR THE COMMUNITY MERE
MAYES- AND THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO. AFTER GRADUATING FROM
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY NORTHRIDGE
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR BRUCE
STARTED HIS PROFESSIONAL PUBLIC
SERVICE CAREER BY ENLISTING IN
THE UNITED STATES NAVY. IT WAS
MY HONOR TO RECOGNIZE BRUCE'S
VETERAN OF THE YEAR AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FIRST PATRIOTIC DUTIES
AND COMMITMENT. TO THE UNITED
STATES. FIRST CHAIRED SEVERAL
VOLUNTEER ORGANIZATIONS HE WAS
PRESIDENT OF THE TOWN COUNCIL
CHAIR THE MIRRA MESA PLANNING
GROUP. AND CHAIR OF THE REAR
MESA RECREATION COUNCIL TO NAME
JUST A FEW. IN TOTAL BROUGH
SERVED ON OVER THIRTY COURTS.
VOLUNTEER GROUPS AND
COMMISSIONS DURING HIS LIFETIME
HE ALSO LED THE EFFORT TO
SECURE FUNDING AND WHEN
APPROVAL FROM THE SAN DIEGO
CITY COUNCIL FOR THE SAN DIEGO
REGIONAL TEEN CENTER POLICE
STOREFRONT FOR THE COMMUNITY AT
MELMASON. I HAD THE GOOD
FORTUNE TO MEET AND WORK WITH
BRUCE AND WE BECAME FRIENDS
EARLY IN MY PUBLIC SERVICE
CAREER WHEN I WAS A COUNCIL
MEMBER FOR THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO. HE AND I SPENT COUNTLESS
HOURS WORKING TO IDENTIFY
FUNDING TO BUILD NEW PUBLIC
PARKS THE COMMUNITY WE ALSO
WORK TO UPDATE OLDER EXISTING
PARK SAID THAT OUR LOCAL YOUTH
SPORTS GROUPS HAD FACILITIES
AND FIELDS TO HOST OUR
PRACTICES AND GAMES. BRUCE
ALONG WITH HIS WIFE ROSE MERRY
THEIR SON GREGORY HELP TO
ESTABLISH THE BROWN FAMILY
SCHOLARSHIP. SCHOLARSHIPS GIVEN
TO GRADUATING SENIORS AT MIRA
MESA HIGH SCHOOL EACH YEAR. FOR
OUTSTANDING COMMUNITY SERVICE.
GRADES AND LEADERSHIP. HE WAS
PRECEDED IN DEATH BY ROSE MERRY
HIS WIFE OF FORTY FOUR YEARS.
HE IS SURVIVED BY A SON GREGORY
FOSTER BROWN IS TWO GRANDSONS.
BRUCE BROWN THE SECOND AND
BODHI BROWN. HE IS ALSO
SURVIVED BY TWO BROTHERS THREE
SISTERS THIRTEEN NIECES AND
NEPHEWS AND MULTIPLE GRAND
NIECES AND GRAND NEPHEWS. I
WANT TO THANK GREGORY BRUCE'S
SON AND THE ENTIRE. BROWN
FAMILY FOR SHARING THIS
INCREDIBLE MAN WITH US FOR ALL
THESE YEARS. THE WORK THAT HE
DID IN THE COMMUNITY HE WAS
SOFT SPOKEN. BUT HE WAS KIND HE
WAS DETERMINED. I NEVER HEARD
HIM SAY A BAD WORD ABOUT
ANYBODY. A GOOD FRIEND AND
SOMEBODY WHO CARES A LOT OF
CREDIT. FOR THE COMMUNITY
BENEFITS THAT EXIST IN MIRA
MESA. BRUCE WILL FOREVER BE
MISSED AND NEVER FORGOTTEN.
THANK YOU MISTER MAIENSCHEIN.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO TURN TO
MR GALLAGHER IN JUST A MOMENT-
FOR THOSE THAT- HUNGRY AT THERE
IS DINNER AND BOXED DINNERS FOR
YOU TO TAKE BACK TO YOUR OFFICE
FOR DEMOCRATS IN THE MEMBER
LOUNGE AND REPUBLICANS IN THE
WILLIE BROWN OR WE WILL
CONTINUE ON THE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY FOR THOSE. WHO ARE HERE
TO DO THEM- AND YOU MAY. A HERE
OR GO GET YOUR MEAL AND TAKE IT
BACK TO YOUR OFFICE. AND. THANK
YOU MISTER GRAYSON FOR THE VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION WE WILL BE
RETURNING IN THIRTY MINUTES AT
SIX PM SO DINNER IS HERE SO
WE'RE ASKING RETURN IN THIRTY
EIGHT MINUTES AT SIX PM. EXTRA
POINTS TO MR GRAYSON.
THANK YOU
MEMBERS MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS- I ASKED THAT WE CLOSE.
INTEGER IN A MEMORY OF DIANE
LYNN SHINYA. WHO PASSED AWAY
PEACEFULLY ON DECEMBER
FIFTEENTH. TWENTY TWENTY. SHE
WAS TAKEN FROM US FAR TOO SOON.
SHE WAS A LOVING WIFE. MOTHER
GRANDMOTHER. SISTER TEACHER.
AND I HAD THE GREAT HONOR OF
BEING HER NEPHEW. WAS BORN IN
MARYSVILLE CALIFORNIA ON APRIL
SIXTH NINETEEN FIFTY TWO. SHE
WAS THE FOURTH OF SEVEN
CHILDREN. BORN TO BOB AND
MARION GALLAGHER. SHE ATTENDED
EAST NICHOLS HIGH SCHOOL WHERE
SHE EXCELLED AS A STUDENT AND
AN ATHLETE. AND WENT ON TO
CHICO STATE. THERE WERE SHE
THEREAFTER EARNED HER TEACHING
CREDENTIAL AND FOLLOWED INTO
HER PASSION. HER CAREER AS A
TEACHER. ONE SUMMER IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR. MY FATHER'S
BASEBALL BUDDY TOM CHIGNON CAME
TO WORK ON THE RANCH. MY AUNT
HAD A BOYFRIEND AT THE TIME BUT
TOM WAS DETERMINED. AND I GUESS
DI<c.cyan> LIKED WHAT SHE SAW. THEY</c>
WERE MARRIED FOR FORTY FIVE
YEARS. TOM WAS ALSO A TEACHER
AND A COACH AND TOGETHER THEY
UNDERSTOOD THE CHALLENGES AND
JOYS OF BEING AN EDUCATOR.
DIANNE IN TOM WELCOME GARRETT
THEIR SON KNIGHT IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE AND GABRIELLE TWO
TWO YEARS LATER SHE KEPT VERY
BUSY WITH THE CHILDREN'S
ACTIVITIES A LOVED ENTERTAINING.
THEIR FRIENDS AT THEIR HOME
WHETHER WAS CELEBRATING
BIRTHDAYS OR ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
DAN ALWAYS ENJOYED HAVING
FRIENDS AND FAMILY GATHER
TOGETHER. AND SHE ALWAYS HAD A
VERY UNIQUE WAY OF MAKING THEM
FEEL SPECIAL. SHE WAS THE
EPITOME OF A TEACHER. BOTH IN
THE CLASSROOM AND IN LIFE. SHE
BEGAN HER TEACHING CAREER AT
SOMERSET MIDDLE SCHOOL. WHERE
SHE WAS A PHYSICAL EDUCATION
INSTRUCTOR INNER THIRTY NINE
pYEARS AT SOMERSSAID SHE ALSO
TAUGHT MATH SCIENCE HEALTH.
LEADERSHIP SHE WAS A NATURAL.
SHE WAS ALWAYS MODEST ABOUT
RECEIVING ACCOLADES BUT WAS
RECOGNIZED FOR NUMEROUS AWARDS
BY HER DISTRICT COUNTY AND
STATE INCLUDING TEACHER OF THE
YEAR FOR CALIFORNIA. SHE ALSO
TOOK GREAT PRIDE IN BEING
SELECTED TO WORK ON THE FIRST
MIDDLE SCHOOL HEALTH CURRICULUM.
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SHE HAD A WAY ABOUT HER JUST
THE RIGHT FIRMNESS OF BOYS AND
GENTLENESS OF SPIRIT TO BOTH
CORRECT. AND INSTRUCT. DAN
RETIRED FROM THE CLASSROOM IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SIX BUT SHE
WAS VERY INVOLVED IN EDUCATION
BY WORKING WITH BEGINNING
TEACHERS. I WORKED AND THEN SHE
WAS TEACHING OTHER TEACHERS AND
BEING A MENTOR. WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT SHE VERY MUCH
LOVED TO DO. SHE ALSO LOVES
HELPING HER CHILDREN. WHO
FOLLOWED IN HER FOOTSTEPS INTO
THOSE CLASSROOMS AND BECAME
TEACHERS THEMSELVES. AND IT
SEEMED LIKE YOU COULDN'TGO
ANYWHERE MODESTO WITHOUT A
FORMER STUDENT COMING UP. TO
DIANE AND- INSANE WHAT IMPACT
SHE HAD HAD. IN A RETIREMENT
DIANNE QUICKLY BECAME INVOLVED
IN MANY ORGANIZATIONS YOU SHE
DID NOT STAY IDLE. AND
PRIMARILY DUE TO THE WONDERFUL
PEOPLE THAT SHE INTERACTED WITH
THESE AGENCIES AND GROUPS
INCLUDED COMMUNITY HOSPICE THE
G. LINE FOUNDATION FOR CHILDREN
CATHOLIC GILD. A MEGAN NEW. SHE
KEPT BUSY WITH HER FRIENDS
DURING HER DAILY WALKS. BRIDGE
GROUPS. HER BELOVED BIBLE STUDY.
BOOK CLUBS AND OF COURSE GOLF.
LADIES TRAVEL GROUP MANAGED TO
GET TO SOME VERY EXCITING TRIPS.
TO DIFFERENT INTERNATIONAL
DESTINATIONS AND THEY ENJOYED A
GREAT TIME TOGETHER BUT HER
ABSOLUTE MOST FAVORITE THING.
IN THE WORLD WAS TO SPEND TIME
WITH HER GRANDCHILDREN. NAOMI
HARRISON KILLIAN AND RORY.
DIANE WAS FORTUNATE. TO HAVE
LIVED A FULL LIFE AND MADE MANY
MANY FOND MEMORIES. WITH FAMILY
AND FRIENDS. AND SO ON BEHALF
OF OUR FAMILY AND HER MANY
FRIENDS COLLEAGUES AND STUDENTS.
I ASKED WE CLOSE IN MEMORY OF
DIANNE SHINYA THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU MR GALLAGHER. MISS
RUBY ARE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO
ADJOURN N MEMORY OF AUDIO HE
MUST SEE AS A LOT LONG TIME
PUBLIC SERVANT AND RESIDENT OF
THE FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT WOULD HAVE IMPACT IN
THE FORTY EIGHTH IS FAR
REACHING AND SPANS DECADES
WOULD YOU MUST YES WAS BORN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY FIFTH NINETEEN
SEVENTY AND RAISED IN THE CITY
OF AZUSA. HE GRADUATED FROM US
IS A HIGH SCHOOL WITH THE CLASS
OF NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT I
RECEIVED HIS BACHELOR'S OF
SCIENCE DEGREE IN FINANCE FROM
CAL POLY POMONA. HE WAS ALSO A
PROUD VETERAN HAVING SERVED OUR
COUNTRY IS A NAVAL NAVAL
LIEUTENANT IN COMBAT IN
AFGHANISTAN. AUGMENTING THE
ARMY AND MARINE TROOPS AS PART
OF OPERATION ENDURING FREEDOM.
AND ENDED UP WORKING WITH
INTERNATIONAL SERVICE MEMBERS
UNDER THE NEEDLE ORGANIZATION.
WOULD YOU MY CS IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE OF TWELVE YEARS ANGELA
AND THEIR FOUR CHILDREN EVEN
NATALIE CECILIA AND ANDREW. HE
ALWAYS REPRESENTED THE CITY AND
THE CITY COUNCIL WITH PASSION
AND DEVOTION. AND HE WILL BE
GREATLY MISSED IN THE US IS A
COMMUNITY. MR MONTHS YES WAS IN
HIS FOURTH TERM ON THIS IS A
CITY COUNCIL HAVING FIRST BEEN
ELECTED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVEN. MR MATHEUS HONORABLY
SERVED THE CITY OF US IS OUR
FOR CLOSE TO TWO DECADES AS
MAYOR PRO TEM COUNCIL MEMBER
PERSONNEL BOARD MEMBER AND
FORMER CITY TREASURER. HE ALSO
SERVED ON VARIOUS COMMITTEES
AND REGIONAL BOARDS
REPRESENTING THE BEST INTERESTS
OF OUR LOCAL RESIDENTS. MISTER
MURPHY HAS BROUGHT GREAT
SUPPORT TO THE COMMUNITY OF THE
FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF AUDIO D.
I. C. S. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MYSTERY A- MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES THE DESI PRETENDED
JOURNAL ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
JUST TO REITERATE THAT WE WILL
BE BACK FROM OUR DINNER RECESS
AT SIX PM MEMBERS THANK YOU.
MEMBERS IT IS SIX OH EIGHT PM
AND WE ARE BACK FROM DINNER
RECESS AND A HUGE SHOUT ABSENT
MEMBERS WO ARE ALREADY HERE ON
THE FLOOR READY TO GET BACK TO
WORK.
THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS
WHO JOINED US ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR SO WE COULD RE COMMENCE
BUSINESS. IF YOU HAVE NOT
JOINED US AND FOR YOU TO DO SO.
MEMBERS WE- I'M GONNA BE TAKING
UP SENATE BILLS. PLEASE RETURN
TO THE FLOOR. IMMEDIATELY.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE AT A. ONE
TWENTY NINE. WE ARE FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY. FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY. YEAH MEMBERS PLEASE
RETURN OF THE FLOOR WE ARE
TAKING UP ITEMS FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY
EIGHT CORPORATE. SENATE BILL
SIX TWENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
ALLEN AND OTHERS AND ACCORDING
TO WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT MS
CLARK SILVA. GOOD EVENING
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TONIGHT I PRESENT SB SIX TWENTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR ELLEN THE
GOLDEN STATE TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY POINT THREE. BILLION
CREATIVE ECONOMY IS THE LARGEST
IN THE WORLD YET COVERT BROUGHT
NINETEEN BROUGHT MUCH OF IT TO
A STANDSTILL NEARLY 96% OF
CREATIVE WORKERS HAVE LOST
REVENUE OR EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE
OF THE PANDEMIC. CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC AND CIVIC RECOVERY
WILL DEPEND ON RETURNING MANY
PEOPLE TO WORK AS RAPIDLY AS
POSSIBLE SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT
THE CREATIVE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT ACT WOULD DIRECT
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD. AND
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL TO
ESTABLISH AND EARN AND LEARN
PROGRAM IN CONSULTATION WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND COMMUNITY
NONPROFITS TO EMPLOY A CREATIVE
WORKERS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL WOULD ESTABLISH A
TRAINING PROGRAM. THIS BILL
WOULD ESTABLISH A TRAINING
PROGRAM FOCUSED ON DEVELOPING
MARKETABLE SKILLS IN THE ARTS
PRIORITISING LOW INCOME
UNEMPLOYED AND DISADVANTAGED
PERSONS BEGINNING THEIR CAREERS
IN THE CREATIVE ARTS THIS THREE
BILL RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY ARTS COMMITTEE AS WELL
AS ASSEMBLY LABOR AND HAS BROAD
SUPPORT FROM CREATIVE INDUSTRY
WORKERS EMPLOYERS AND THE
UNIONS ACROSS THE STATE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CLARK SILVA
SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. KIRK WELL. CLOSER ROLE.
THE TELEVOTE. I FIFTY TWO NO TO
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
TWO ONE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
TAKING UP SOME SUPPORT SUPPORT
ITEMS. THESE ARE SUPPORT
SUPPORT ITEMS WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE OF MR GARCIA'S FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY NINE. SENATE BILL.
SIX NINETEEN. CLAVERIA SENATE
BILL SIX NINETEEN BY CENTER
LAYERED NECKLACE AND SOLOWAY'S
MR GARCIA. MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES S. B. SIX ONE NINE
IS IN RESPONSE TO COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THIS BILL
SEEKS- LIMITED RELIEF FOR
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES WHILE
ENSURING CLIMATE. CHANGE GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES RELATED TO THE
S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
ORGANIC WASTE DIVERSION
REGULATIONS THAT WERE RELEASED
BY CAL RECYCLE NOVEMBER THIRD
TWENTY TWENTY RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MR GARCIA I
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. CALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS HERITABLE.
NO CLARK WELL THOSE ARE ALL.
CATEGORIZE SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. WE ARE
TAKEN OUT SUPPORT SUPPORT. NEXT
UP FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY TWO. SB
SIX SIX FIVE CORPORATION SENATE
BILL SIX SIXTY FIVE BY CENTER
ON BURKE AND OTHERS MEDICALLY
TO EMPLOYMENT. MISS BERNARDA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ON BEHALF OF MY QUALITIES A
COLLEAGUE SENATOR- BURKE I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT SB SIX SIX
FIVE WHICH SUPPORTS OUR
VETERANS AND CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY BY ALLOWING A PRIVATE
HIRING PREFERENCE FOR VETERANS.
SB SIX SIX FIVE WOULD ALLOW I
WOULD ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO JOIN
WITH THIRTY NINE OTHER STATES
TO ALLOW QUIET PRIVATE
EMPLOYERS TO GIVE PREFERENCE TO
VETERANS IN HIRING PROMOTION
AND RETENTION DECISIONS. THIS
BILL ALSO CONTAINS LANGUAGE
ASSURING THAT THE PREFERENCE
CANNOT BE USED AS A PRETEXT TO
INTENTIONALLY DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST APPLICANTS TO BELONG TO
A PROTECTED CLASSES SB SIX SIX
FIVE WILL HONOR AND RECOGNIZE
THE SACRIFICES MADE BY OUR
VETERANS. AND ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT THE TRANSITION FROM
SERVICE TO CIVILIAN LIFE IS
OFTEN DIFFICULT AND HAS
RESULTED IN HIGH SUICIDE AND
HOMELESSNESS RATES FOR VETERANS
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR UMBERG I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVALS. SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF. BUT IS
THAT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESERT ABOUT. CARDWELL
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP I SIXTY
SIX. OZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY THREE
PASS AND RETAIN ON FIVE AND.
ONE THIRTY FOUR. THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY FIVE SENATE
BILL. SIX EIGHTY TWO CORPORATE
SENATE BILL SIX EIGHTY TWO BY
SENATOR RUBIO AND OTHERS
AMERICANS PUBLIC HEALTH. AFTER
WEBER EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL SIX EIGHTY TWO THE
END RACIAL INEQUITIES IN
CHILDREN'S HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA
INITIATIVE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
RUBIO. THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY IN
COLLABORATION WITH RELEVANT
AGENCIES DEPARTMENTS AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A PLAN THAT REDUCES
RACIAL DISPARITIES IN
CHILDREN'S HEALTH OUTCOMES. BY
AT LEAST 50% BY TWENTY
THIRTEEN. ABSOLUTELY 25% OF ALL
CHILDREN EXPERIENCE CHRONIC
HEALTH CONDITIONS OVERALL
IMPACTING THE QUALITY OF LIFE
AND REDUCING PRODUCTIVITY IN
ADULTHOOD. IN CALIFORNIA SOME
OF THE MOST COMMON CONDITIONS
AMONG OUR YOUTH INCLUDE ASTHMA
DIABETES DEPRESSION DENTAL
CARIES AND VAPING RELATED
DISEASES. THE STATE NEEDS TO BE
PRO ACTIVE IN ITS APPROACH TO
TACKLING RACIAL HEALTH
INEQUITIES AND MUST CLEARLY
ESTABLISHED CLEAR TARGETS AND
STEPS TO ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON S. B. SIX EIGHTY TWO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU JACK
WEBER. SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CARBONARO ALL MEMBERS
REPRESENTATIVE OF. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO GO. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TELL YOU
THAT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO BE JUMPING AHEAD IN
THE FILE TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY FOUR THIS IS FILE
ITEM. ONE FORTY FOUR. SENATE
BILL. THREE FORTY THREE.
CARBERY SENATE BILL THREE FORTY
THREE BY SENATOR ALLEN AND
OTHERS MACALINTAL ENVIRONMENTAL
ADVERTISING. THIS GONZALEZ
EMAIL. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS IS A SIMPLE BILL
THAT I CAN'T IMAGINE ANYONE IT
WOULDN'T BE FOR I HONESTLY
CAN'T IMAGINE HOW ANYONE COULD
ARGUE AGAINST THIS BILL IT IS
SIMPLE IT SAYS YOU CANNOT HAVE
THE CHASE SCENE ARROW SYMBOL
THAT SYMBOL THAT WE ALL
ASSOCIATE WITH BEING RECYCLABLE
ON MATERIAL THAT'S NOT
RECYCLABLE. LAKE HOW DO YOU
ARGUE AGAINST THAT. WE ARE
ALLOWING AND ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE CONSUMERS TO
PUT MATERIAL INTO THE RECYCLING
BIN THEY CAN NEVER BE RECYCLED
THAT WE KNOW HAS TO THEN BE
REMOVED TO RECYCLABLES AND SENT
INTO THE LANDFILL WHY BECAUSE
IT MAKES A COMPANY'S BRAND TO
LOOK GREEN FRIENDLY. WHICH
CYCLE LEAN WE'RE GONNA PRETEND
THAT SOMEDAY IN THE FUTURE WILL
HAVE SOME TECHNOLOGY IN ORDER
TO RECYCLE IT BUT FOR NOW WE'RE
JUST GOING TO MAKE IT LOOK
PRETTY FOR YOU. THIS IS
RIDICULOUS. IT'S DISHONEST IT'S
NOT THE INTERESTS OF CONSUMERS
OR COMPANIES TO ALLOW IT. AND
IT'S CERTAINLY NOT IN THE
INTEREST. OF OUR GOALS TO REACH
RECYCLING RATES FOR SINGLE USE
PLASTICS. WE HAVE TO GET TO THE
POINT WHERE WE'RE HONEST WITH
OURSELVES. THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL SEEKS TO START TO DO. I
HAVE YET TO HEAR AN ARGUMENT IN
OPPOSITION THIS BILL THAT MAKES
ANY SENSE IF SOMEBODY HAS IT
PLEASE TELL ME. I HEARD
SOMETHING ABOUT BATTERIES WELL
GUESS WHAT WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE
THROWING BATTERIES IN THE
RECYCLING BIN THAT'S WHAT
STARTS FIRES. THEY'RE NOT
RECYCLABLE. THAT IS A BAD
CONDUCT THAT WE DON'T WANT TO
ENCOURAGE WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE
THROWING IN PLASTICS THAT MAYBE
FIVE YEARS FROM NOW WE'LL HAVE
TECHNOLOGY TO RECYCLE. THE
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL MISTER
ALLEN SENATOR ALLEN HAS WORKED
WITH THE OPPOSITION
STAKEHOLDERS FROM ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM IN AN EFFORT TO REACH
A MIDDLE GROUND AND IT'S TAKEN
NUMEROUS AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS INCLUDING GIVING YOU
MANUFACTURES MORE TIME TO
COMPLY. AND REDUCING CALORIE
CYCLES DISCRETION AND WORKLOAD.
CURRENT LAW ALREADY PROHIBITS
THE MANUFACTURE FOR MAKING
UNTRUTHFUL ENVIRONMENT CLAIMS
SUCH AS EARTH FRIENDLY OR
RECYCLABLE. AND SB THREE FORTY
THREE SIMPLY EXTENDS THE
PROHIBITION TO THE USE OF THE
CHASING ARROW SYMBOL IF A
PRODUCT OR PACKAGING IS NOT
TRULY RECYCLABLE. BY CLARIFYING
THE ONLY ACTUAL RECYCLABLE
MATERIAL CAN DISPLAY THE
CHASING ERA SYMBOL SB THREE
FORTY THREE WILL END CONSUMER
CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT IS
RECYCLABLE. IMPROVE RECYCLING
EFFICIENCIES AND REDUCE
CONTAMINATION COSTS AT
RECYCLING FACILITIES. WE WORK
HARD TO TRY TO TAKE ON THE
PLASTIC ISSUE THE SINGLE USE
PLASTIC ISSUE. ON THE FLOOR AND
WE COME SHORT. BUT COLLEAGUES
IF WE CANNOT EVEN SAY THAT
CONSUMERS DESERVE THE RIGHT TO
KNOW WHETHER PRODUCTS SHOULD BE
THROWN INTO THE BLUE BIN OR NOT
IF THAT'S TOO DIFFICULT I
REALLY WORRY ABOUT THE FUTURE
OF OUR EARTH QUITE FRANKLY SO
IF ANYONE'S OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL I CHALLENGE YOU TO STAND
UP AND EXPLAIN WHAT IS SO
ONEROUS ABOUT. ASKING A PRODUCT
TO TELL US THE TRUTH. BUT IF
NOT. I ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE BY.
THANK RESIDENTS ALSO. THERE'S
NO NEED TO STAND UP. THIS RIVAS
DIRECTOR THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY AS A CO
AUTHOR AND SUPPORTER OF SB
THREE FORTY THREE WHICH WOULD
EXPAND THE EXISTING TRUTH AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVERTISING LAW
TO END CONSUMER CONFUSION ABOUT
WITH WHAT MATERIALS ARE%
RECYCLABLE I AGREE WITH THE
MEMBER FROM SAN DIEGO I THINK
THIS IS VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD
PEOPLE SHOULD KNOW. OF WHAT IS
RECYCLABLE BY THE LABEL THAT IS
ON THE CONTAINER YEAH AS CHAIR
OF NATURAL RESOURCES I BELIEVE
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE THE
RECYCLING PROCESS
STRAIGHTFORWARD WE KNOW THAT
LESS THAN 15% OF SINGLE USE
PLASTICS ARE RECYCLED AND PART
OF THAT IS BECAUSE IT'S OFTEN
UNCLEAR TO CONSUMERS WHAT IS
AND WHAT IS NOT RECYCLABLE WITH
THIS BILL WE WOULD PROHIBIT
COMPANIES FROM USING THE WORD
RECYCLABLE ON UN RECYCLABLE
PRODUCTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
REAVIS. MISTER MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I THINK SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES MIGHT HAVE BEEN
THINKING OF STANDING UP TO
SPEAK AGAINST THIS- BUT I'M
ACTUALLY GOING TO ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON THIS ONE- OF- TALK
TO MY LOCAL WASTE MANAGEMENT
GUYS- THEY REACHED OUT THEY
RICHARD ME THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
DO THIS. I KNOW THERE'S A LOT
OF CONCERN ON AND SOME OF THE
FOOD PRODUCTS AND SOME OF THAT
THINGS BUT THE AUTHOR HAS
ACTUALLY TAKEN AMENDMENTS TO
WORK WITH PEOPLE- WHICH IS A
NICE SURPRISE- SO ON THIS ONE.
I THINK THE BOTTOM LINE HERE IN
THE BIG ACADEMIC. CORPORATE
TERM IS CORPORATE SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY. IT'S ONLY
ENOUGH IT'S DOING THE RIGHT
THING AND USING THE LABELS
CORRECTLY. AND WHEN YOU TALK TO
GUYS LIKE WASTE MANAGEMENT BACK
HOME THAT DO THIS AS A
PROFESSION. AND THEY SAY
THEY'RE ABLE TO DO THIS. THE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN. TALKED TO
THIS ISN'T SOMETHING NEW THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
DISCUSSED FOR YEARS. AND IT'S
TIME TO TAKE THAT STEP FORWARD
AND MAKE IT RIGHT SO
ASTRONOMICAL. FIGMENTS MATHIS
MS GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU I ALSO ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE FOR THIS BILL THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL BUT IT'S REALLY
A MODEST BILL. IT'S JUST
LETTING CONSUMERS KNOW THAT
WHEN THEY SEE THAT ARROW THINGS
ARE REALLY BEING RECYCLED WE'VE
DONE A LOT OF EDUCATION. OUT
THERE ARE A LOT OF ASSUME THAT
WE SEE THERE WHERE YOU PUT IT
INTO THE TRASH AND IS BEING
RECYCLED BUT- IT'S IN THE
SINGLE DIGITS A LOT OF TIMES
WITH BEING RECYCLED. FOLKS HAVE
TALKED ABOUT ON RAMPS THE ON
RAMP IS YOU HAVE UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. TO GET TO WRITE A
MODEST GOAL OF ONLY 60% WE
SHOULD REALLY GOING GETTING TO
NINETY FIVE YES ME. AND IF
YOU'RE ABLE TO SHOW THAT YOU
HAVE A MAP THAT WILL BE ON YOUR
WAY THAT YOU CAN GET AN
EXTENSION. ON SO THERE'S ARMS
THERE'S BEEN CONFUSION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT OTHER EPR
PROGRAMS ARE EXEMPT AND THEY
ARE YOU CAN LOOK AT PAGE SEVEN.
OUR EARLY UNEASY THAT CARPET
THAT- RECHARGEABLE BATTERIES
THAT MATT MATTER SAYS ANYTHING
WHEN AN EXISTING THE PR PROGRAM
IS EXEMPT ALSO. IN THIS BILL AS
WELL THE AUTHORS IN THE
ADVOCATES HAVE WORKED
DILIGENTLY TO TRY TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS. THERE'S A LOT WE NEED
TO DO IN THIS SPACE BUT THE
FIRST STEP IN SHARING THAT
CONSUMERS HAVE SIMPLE
INFORMATION. TO MAKE SMART
CHOICES ALONG THE WAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS. GARCIA
THANK YOU MEMBERS. C. NO OTHER
MEMBERS RECOGNITION AS- YOU
MAKE. I HAVEN'T I WANNA POINT
OUT THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN BY THE
AUTHOR- ENSURED THAT THE
CHAMBER THE RETAILERS IN THE
ABA AND TONS OF OTHER BUSINESS
INTERESTS ARE NOW NEUTRAL- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE ON
THIS VERY COMMONSENSE
TRANSPARENCY BILL. BARBARO.
DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THAT A VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT. HIGHS FORTY
THREE NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE BACK IN THE FILE TO TAKE A
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY ONE. THIS
IS FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY ONE.
SENATE BILL SIX THREE NINE.
CORKERY SENATE BILL SIX THIRTY
NINE BY SENATOR ALSO AND OTHERS
NOT GOING INTO EMPLOYMENT. THIS
GONZALES THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SB SIX THIRTY NINE
ENSURES THAT WORKERS WITH
DISABILITIES CANNOT BE PAID
LESS THAN MINIMUM WAGE. THE
CALIFORNIA PRIDES ITSELF IN
LEADING THE COUNTRY WITH A
FIFTEEN DOLLAR MINIMUM WAGE AND
CIVIL RIGHTS PROTECTIONS
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS WITH
DISABILITIES ARE STILL BEING
EXPLOITED OFTEN FOR LADY WAGES
LESS THAN TWO DOLLARS PER HOUR.
SB SIX THIRTY NINE WOULD STOP
PERMITTING NEW EMPLOYERS FROM
PAYING LESS THAN MINIMUM WAGE
BEGINNING NEXT YEAR IT REQUIRE
RELEVANT AGENCIES AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP A PLAN
BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO PHASE
OUT THE EXISTING MINIMUM WAGE
EXEMPTIONS. ALL REMAINING
EXEMPTIONS TO MEMO AGE WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO BE PHASED OUT BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THE PAYMENT
OF SUB MINIMUM WAGE AND IT'S AN
ARCHAIC RELIC OF THE NINETEEN
THIRTIES AND DATES TO A TIME
WHEN CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES
WERE DENIED AN EDUCATION. AND
BEFORE LEGISLATION CLEAN
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT
RECOGNIZE THE FULL HUMANITY
APART PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
THE STATE OF ALASKA CONNECTICUT
MARYLAND NEW HAMPSHIRE NEW YORK
OREGON MINNESOTA RHODE ISLAND
TEXAS. AND WASHINGTON HAVE ALL
STOPPED THE PRACTICE OF
GRANTING EXEMPTIONS TO THE
MINIMUM WAGE EMPLOYMENT IT'S
TIME FOR GAP CALIFORNIA TO JOIN
THE RANKS. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
THE DIGNITY OF WORK IN THE
VALUE WE PLACE ON LABOR OF
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. THIS
YEAR THE LEGISLATURE IS
INVESTED HEAVILY IN PROGRAMS
THAT WILL SUPPORT THE
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION OF
INDIVIDUALS MOVING OUT OF SUB
MINIMUM WAGE EMPLOYMENT. THIS
INCLUDED SIXTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET FOR
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICE
COORDINATORS AND DOUBLING THE
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS TO PRINT
SERVICE PROVIDERS FOR PLACING
FOLKS IN COMPETITIVE.
INTEGRATIVE EMPLOYMENT. NOW
IT'S THE TIME TO END THIS
UNJUST PRACTICE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. MISTER
LUCKY YOUR RECORD. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. I STAND UP
TODAY IN OPPOSITION SB SIX
THIRTY NINE. AND I WANT TO BE
CLEAR HOWEVER THAT THERE ARE
SOME VERY GOOD THINGS ABOUT
THIS BILL. BUT IT CONTAINS A
FATAL FLAW ONE THAT REQUIRES AN
EXPLANATION. FIRST THE NOTION
THAT WE OUGHT TO PASS THE
DEPARTMENT. OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TO COME UP WITH THE
PLAN. UNDER WHICH PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES COULD MAKE MINIMUM
WAGE OR HIGHER WHEN THEY'RE
WORKING IS A TERRIFIC IDEA. AS
IT STANDS TODAY PEOPLE WITH IBD
WORK IN JOBS WHERE THEY WORK
VERY INDEPENDENTLY MAKE WAGES
THAT ARE HIGHER THAN MINIMUM
WAGE. THERE ARE SOME HOWEVER
THE SOLELY BECAUSE OF THEIR
INTELLECTUAL OR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY. CANNOT COMPETE IN
MANY JOBS BECAUSE OF
PRODUCTIVITY DOESN'T MEET THE
STANDARDS OF THE COMPETITIVE
MARKETPLACE. THOSE PEOPLE
LITERALLY MEET THE STANDARDS OF
THE FEDERAL FAIR LABOR
STANDARDS ACT THAT ALLOWS THEM
BY CHOICE. TO TAKE A JOB THAT
PAYS LESS THAN MINIMUM WAGE.
THE OTHER PART OF THELAW
REQUIRES THAT THEY EXPRESSED
THIS CHOICE TO THE
INDIVIDUALIZED PROGRAM PLAN OR
KNOWN AS THE I. P. P. THAT IS
DEVELOPED WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTER. THE FEDERAL LAW FURTHER
REQUIRES THAT THEIR
PRODUCTIVITY IN THE JOB. BE
REMEASURED EVERY SIX MONTHS.
AND OTHER PRODUCTIVITY
INCREASES SO MUST OUR PAY.
ADDITIONALLY IF THE PAY FOR
THAT POSITION GOES UP THEIR PAY
MUST ALSO BE INCREASED AS WELL.
THE FATAL FLAW THIS BILL IS
THAT IT ALSO SAYS THE PEOPLE
WITH IBD MAKING LESS THAN
MINIMUM WAGE CAN NO LONGER DO
THAT PASSED JANUARY. ONE OF
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE OR POSSIBLY
LATER THE DEPARTMENT TAKES
LONGER TO DEVELOP A PLAN.
MEMBERS WE SHOULD ASK THE
DEPARTMENT TO SEE IF THERE'S A
WAY THAT ALL PEOPLE WITH
ALREADY WORKING TO MAKE MINIMUM
WAGE OR HIGHER. IN FACT THERE
ARE WAYS TO MAKE THIS WORK. WE
COULD SUBSIDIZE THE SUBSIDIZE
THE GAP BETWEEN PRODUCTIVITY
WAGE UNDER FEDERAL LAW AND
MINIMUM WAGE. WE CAN ALSO DO AS
OUR COLLEAGUE BRIAN MAIENSCHEIN
PROPOSED TWICE. TWO TIMES. HE
PROPOSED A BILL OFFERING
EMPLOYERS WITH THE TAX CREDIT
TO PAY MINIMUM WAGE TO THEIR
WORKERS WITH IDT EVEN THOUGH
THEY COULD BE PAID LESS UNDER
FEDERAL LAW. BOTH TIMES THIS
BILL WAS HELD APPROPRIATIONS.
AFTER PASSING UNANIMOUSLY IN
THE REVENUE TAX COMMITTEE. THE
THIRD BILL BY IT ALSO A FORMER
COLLEAGUE DANTE ACOSTA PROPOSED
THE SAME AND HAVE THE SAME
HOLDING. OF THE MICE. THE FACT
IS THAT THIS BILL IS PASSED AS
IS THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE THAT
TWELVE THOUSAND PEOPLE. WITH
IDT WILL LOSE THEIR CURRENT
JOBS THAT THEY HAVE CHOSEN TO
BE WORKING IN. AND ARE APPROVED
IN THE I. P. P. SITTING
IS THAT A TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN. A BILL DECLARING
EMPLOYMENT TO THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR PEOPLE WITH IBD.
THE EMPLOYMENT RATE OF PEOPLE
WITH IDT. WHEN THIS BILL WAS
PASSED WAS 40% 14% GUESS WHAT
IT IS TODAY EVEN AFTER WE MADE
A POINT WITH THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY OF THE STATE. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF BILL OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES 14%
WE'VE ALSO NOT FUNDED
ADEQUATELY THE PROGRAMS SERVING
THIS POPULATION. SO SUDDENLY
EXPECTING THAT THIS RATE WERE
MIRACULOUSLY GET BETTER IT'S
CRAZY. I CANNOT SUPPORT THIS
BILL UNLESS THE TIMELINE IS
TAKEN OUT OF THE BILL. YES THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES GIVES US OUR BEST
IDEAS. BUT WHEN YOU DO. TELL US
HOW YOUR GOING TO FUND IT IF WE
LIKE IT WE CAN PASS IT AND PUT
THE FUNDING IN THE BUDGET BUT
IN THE MEANTIME PLEASE DON'T
TAKE AWAY THE JOBS AT TWELVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE HAVE. A PEOPLE
THAT HAVE ADD- TODAY WITHOUT
HAVING A PLAN IN PLACE. SO I
ORIGINAL VOTE. MR MATHIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS I RISE
IN OPPOSITION OF THIS ONE. IN A
LOT OF THE CONCERNS OF ALREADY
BEEN ADDRESSED WHAT I'M GONNA
READDRESS THEM. INFIRMITY YOU
YOU KNOW I'LL- I AM A FATHER OF
A CHILD WITH DISABILITIES. I
LIVE IN THIS COMMUNITY I WORK
WITH THIS COMMUNITY MY PHONE
HAS BEEN RINGING OFF THE HOOK.
OUT OF CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL
FROM OUR IT D. COMMUNITY. WHILE
IT'S A GREAT IDEA IN IN WE
THINK THAT YES LET'S GIVE THEM
A MINIMUM WAGE LET'S DO THIS
LET'S MAKE SURE THEIR WORK
MATTERS. BUT WHAT WE'RE MISSING.
IS THE IMPORTANCE THAT THEY
FEEL ABOUT THE LITTLE BIT OF
WORK THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO DO.
THEY ENJOY GOING INTO AND WHAT
THEY DO BECAUSE- THEY SEEK
FULFILLMENT FROM IT. THEY IT
THEY ARE IT'S LITTLE BIT THEY
ARE ABLE TO DO. I BEEN ON TOURS
ALL OF AND DOWN THE STATE. BACK
WHEN I WAS CHAIR OF HUMANS.
GOING IN A MEETING WITH OUR IDT
COMMUNITY GOING INTO THE JOB
SITE THAT WE FIGHT LIKE HELL TO
BE ABLE TO GET THE CONTRACTS
JUST TO BE ABLE TO OPEN THE
DOOR. SO THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES. CAN DO THESE JOBS.
WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE IS
PUSHING THOSE CONTRACTS AWAY
AND I AND I GET IT I THINK WE
ALL AGREE. THAT YES THEY SHOULD
GET PAID MORE. WHERE'S THE
SUBSIDY TO PAY THEM MORE WE'RE
GIVING ALL THIS MONEY AWAY FOR
ALL THESE OTHER THINGS WHERE'S
THE MONEY. FOR MORE BUDGET TO
SUBSIDIZE THEIR WORK TO HELP
THEM OUT TO DO THAT. THAT'S
WHERE THE MONEY SHOULD BE
COMING FROM. WE'RE TRYING TO
HELP THEM WE'RE TRYING TO GIVE
THE MEANING IN LIFE IN THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION TAKES THAT
AWAY FROM THEM. BECAUSE THEY'RE
GOING TO LOSE IT THE COMPANY'S
THAT GO OUT AND FIGHT FOR THESE
CONTRACTS TO TRY TO GET. OUR
FAMILY MEMBERS WITH
DISABILITIES UP OFF THE COUCH
OF OUT OF THE HOUSE OUT INTO
THE COMMUNITY TO BE PRODUCTIVE
MEMBERS OF OUR SOCIETY YOU'RE
TAKING THAT AWAY MEMBERS PLEASE
DO NOT DO THAT I ASK YOU FOR
YOUR NO VOTE WE CAN DO BETTER
ON THIS AN INSURER. THEN THE
RESPECT THAT THEY DESERVE.
MISTER VEHICLE GLASS. THANK YOU
MR THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT ALTHOUGH THIS BILL WAS
WELL INTENDED. I HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THIS BILL- THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS IT IS TRYING TO
HELP. I TRULY BELIEVE THAT
EMPLOYERS WHO AREN'T ARE
IMPACTED BY THIS BILL WANT TO
PAY A FAIR WAGE OF UP TO ALL
THE WORKERS REGARDLESS OF THIS
OF THE DISABILITY.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE NO
REINSURANCE IN THIS BILL THAT
WORKERS AFFECTED WILL REMAIN
EMPLOYED IN THE LONG RUN. I GOT
TO SAY THAT AYE AYES AYE
SUPPORTED THIS AND COMMITTEE.
AND I BROWN STRONGLY WHEN I
SUPPORTED. BUT AFTER HEARING IN
GETTING MORE AND MORE
INFORMATION GETTING THE CALLS
HEARING HEARING FROM PARENTS.
THAT THEY'RE SCARED THAT THIS
IS NOT GOING TO HELP BUT THIS
IS REALLY GOING TO HURT THEM.
AND THEY WISH THAT MAYBE THE
STATE WOULD WOULD JUMPED IN TO
HELP AT THE END TO GRANDFATHER
THURMOND. AND BECAUSE OF THAT
BUT LISTENING TO MANY PARENTS.
FOLKS THAT GOT ON THE PHONE
BOOKS THAT SHOWED UP. I
LITERALLY WENT BACK TO MY
OFFICE AND SAT WITH STAFF AND
GO HEY YOU KNOW WHERE DID WE
NOT SEE THIS COMING. SO I
CALLED I QUESTION THAT RIGHT
NOW I REALLY DO. YOU KNOW I DUG
DEEP IN MY DISTRICT AND MAKE
CALLS AND VISIT. AND TALK TO
PARENTS. I GO I GO TO A BAGEL
SHOP IN MY AND MY COMMUNITY.
AND I SEE THAT THOSE WORKERS
THERE ARE REALLY TRYING TO DO
THE BEST THING BUT- IT IS SO
HARD I JUST FEAR I FEAR FOR
THAT FOR THAT WORKER THAT THEY
MAY LOSE THEIR JOB SO FOR THOSE
REASONS. I WILL NOT BE STE I
WILL NOT BE VOTING FOR THIS
BILL THANK YOU FOR SPEAKER. MR
FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND-
FIRST OF ALL I WOULD LIKE TO
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR. FOR HER
COMPASSION. IN FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. I'M BUT I CAN'T
SUPPORT THIS BILL- EARLY ON I
HAD A CONVERSATION WITH MY
COLLEAGUES AND SAN DIEGO ARE
PROVISIONS CHAIR. AND SHE-
ACKNOWLEDGED MY CONCERNS AND
MADE THE BILL MUCH BETTER. AND
I THANK HER FOR THAT. I'M THE
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT. AND
IT'S BEEN SPOKEN OF. IS THAT
THERE ARE MANY DIFFERENT
CAPABILITIES IN THE DISABLED
COMMUNITY. YOU HAVE PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES YOU HAVE COGNITIVE
DISABILITIES THERE'S A
DIFFERENTIAL OF CAPABILITIES OF
HOW PEOPLE CAN FUNCTION. IN A
WORKPLACE. NO A LOT OF FOLKS
AND I'VE BEEN IN IF YOU'VE
NEVER BEEN INTO A WORK CENTER
WITH PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
YOU SEE THAT THEY'RE FAST
THEY'RE IT'S FASCINATING. THE
WAY THEY ARE HAPPY WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IS PLEASURABLE FOR THEM
THEY FEEL ENGAGED. BUT THEY
COULDN'T COMPETE WITH SOMEBODY
WHO'S IN A TYPICAL. PERSON WHO
HAS ALL THE ABILITIES THEY
CAN'T DO THAT. AND SO IF YOU
PUT THEM UP TO AN EMPLOYER WHO
SAYS YOU'RE GONNA PAY THIS
PERSON. MINIMUM WAGE. WHO ARE
THEY GONNA PICK. WHO ARE THEY
GONNA PICK. SO HAS BEEN
MENTIONED TWELVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE ARE IN JEOPARDY. OF
BEING DISPLACED WITH THIS BILL
AT A COST OF ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IN ADULT
DAY CENTERS FOR CALIFORNIA NO
WE DID PASS A ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLAR. BUDGET PLAY FOR
THE IDT POPULATION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IT'S IMPLEMENTED OVER
FIVE YEARS. AND THAT MONEY WAS
NEEDED FIVE YEARS AGO. SO WHEN
WE GO TO OUR FIVE YEARS FROM
NOW. THAT ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. IS GOING TO BE LESS
IMPACTFUL. IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
NOW. NO ONE I'D SAY THAT THIS
IS HARMFUL TO PEOPLE I'M I WANT
THEM TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THE
MOST MONEY POSSIBLE N. AS MR
LACKEY FROM. HIS DISTRICT FROM
WHERE. PALMDALE. MENTIONED THAT
IT IS ASSESSED EVERY SIX MONTHS
FOUR CAPABILITY GROWTH THAT IS
NO KID THAT'S OKAY. EVERYBODY
WANTS THEM TO MAKE MORE MONEY
BECAUSE THE PROVIDER WOULD MAKE
MORE MONEY IF THEY MAKE MORE
MONEY. SO PLEASE UNDERSTAND
THAT AGAIN THIS MIGHT HAVE THE
MOMENTUM. IT MIGHT GO FORWARD
AND IF IT DOES I HAVE TO
APOLOGIZE TO THE IDT POPULATION
WERE I HAVE. BEEN INVOLVED WITH
THEM FOR SIXTEEN YEARS. SIXTEEN
YEARS THAT I'VE DEVELOPED MY
DEVOTED MY LIFE IS POPULATION
AND ALL OF YOU HAVE BEEN
AMAZING THIS LEGISLATIVE
SESSION WITH YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THEIR- FISCAL GROWTH WITH THE
PROVIDERS. BUT IF WE VOTE YES
ON THIS BILL. WE'RE GONNA BE
HURTING MORE PEOPLE THAN WE
HELP. I REGIONAL. MR GRAYSON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I I TO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE PASSION
THE AUTHOR HAS FOR THE IDT
COMMUNITY. AND I ALSO WANT TO
STATE THAT- INTENTIONS OF BOTH
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS ARE
TO BE LAUDED. HOWEVER YOU KNOW
THAT- GOOD INTENTIONS DON'T
ALWAYS DELIVER DESIRED RESULTS.
AND I SAY THAT BECAUSE EACH AND
EVERYONE OF US KNOW ALL TOO
WELL WHAT UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES CAN BRING OUR WAY.
AND WHEN- WHEN I INQUIRED
UNANSWERED WAS GIVEN THAT WELL
WE WILL MAINSTREAM. THESE
PEOPLE ARE THESE FOLKS INTO THE
WORK FORCE. AND I REMEMBER WHEN
A SCHOOL DISTRICT TRIED TO
MAINSTREAM MY SISTER. AND THE
HELL SHE WENT THROUGH. AND THE
TORMENT EVERYDAY UNTIL FINALLY
MY PARENTS WERE ABLE TO
CONVINCE THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
THE SHE COULDN'T BE MAINSTREAM.
AND I AM CONCERNED THAT- SHERRY
IN WHOM MANY OF YOU ON THIS
FLOOR HAVE MET. THAT- SHE WOULD
FALL VICTIM TO AN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE. OF THIS BILL. FOR
HER AND I KNOW THE CONS OF THE
CONVERSATION OF THE DISCUSSION
HAS BEEN A LOT ABOUT. MONEY AND
PAYMENT AND THEN THERE ARE
THOSE THAT CAN BE MAINSTREAMED
AND HAVE BEEN AND THERE ARE
THOSE THAT CAN AND WILL BE. AND
WE DEFINITELY NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT NO ONE IS DISCRIMINATED OR
PAID LESS AND EXPLOITED BECAUSE
OF THEIR LIFE SITUATION.
HOWEVER IN SOME CASES IT'S NOT
THE CASE AND FOR SURE IT'S NOT
ABOUT THE MONEY IT'S ABOUT THE
SOCIAL NETWORK IT'S ABOUT THE
SELF CONFIDENCE THAT COMES.
IT'S ABOUT BUILDING THE INWARD
PERSON. WHERE SHE IS SO PROUD
TO BE ABLE TO STAND UP AND SAY
I HAVE A JOB. AND WHEN I CALL
AND I TALKED TO HER AND I ASK
YOU DID YOU GO TO WORK TODAY
YES WOULD YOU DO THAT'S NOT
EVEN THE ISSUE. THE ISSUE IS
WHO SHE WAS WITH. AND TO BE
ABLE TO LIVE THAT LIFE AND TO
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY AND THAT
HONORED THAT PRIVILEGE. TO BE
ABLE TO SAY I WENT TO WORK I
CONTRIBUTED I DID SOMETHING
LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT IN A WORKING
ENVIRONMENT. AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE IT'S NOT ABOUT TWO
DOLLARS AN HOUR OR TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS AN HOUR BUT AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE SHE CAN GO
AND WORK ALONGSIDE SOMEONE ELSE
THAT KNOWS EXACTLY WHERE SHE'S
AT. AND THAT SHE CAN RELATE
WITH AND SO WITH THAT- I WOULD
SIMPLY ASK THAT WE LOOK AT THIS
AND THINK ABOUT IT. AND-
APPROACH IT WITH THE WITH THE
FLOSS WITH THE IDEA OF DO NO
HARM. AND THAT'S ALL I ASK I
ASK THAT. THAT WE LOOK AT THIS
IN A IN A PERSPECTIVE IN A WAY
AND IF IT MEANS HAVING TO COME
BACK. WITH SOMETHING BETTER
THAN I WOULD BE VERY VERY
SUPPORTIVE. IF IT MEANS WE'RE
GOING FORWARD WITH THIS THAN TO
BE ABLE TO GO AND LOOK AT WAYS
THAT WE CAN FIND A FIND
PROTECTIONS IN THE FUTURE. TO
PRESERVE THESE JOBS BECAUSE
THERE ARE SOME FOLKS THAT
REALLY REALLY DO BENEFIT FROM
THESE PROGRAMS THAT WOULD NOT
MAKE IT IF THIS BILL GOES
THROUGH. THANK YOU. THANK M. S.
GRAYSON MISTER PATTERSON YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS OF. I RISE TO JOIN
MY VOICE IS WITH OTHERS WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES HERE ARE
UNINTENDED. AS THEY MIGHT BE
SHARED SHARON AND I HAVE. BEEN
DEEPLY ENGAGED IN. THE
COMMUNITY THAT SERVES AND CARES
FOR AND LOVES THESE INDIVIDUALS
AS MAYOR FRESNO I OFTEN VISITED
THE ARC WHICH IS A MAGNIFICENT
WONDERFUL PLACE. AND TO WATCH
V. INDIVIDUALS THERE WERE
WORKING. MEMBERS I SAW THE JOY
OF THE WORK. AND I SAW THE JOY.
OF THE PEOPLE AROUND THEM. AND
I CAN REMEMBER ONE SPECIFIC
EXPERIENCE WHERE. AND THESE
WERE MOSTLY THAT DOWN SYNDROME
CHILDREN. THEY WERE COLLECTING.
NUTS AND BOLTS AND SCREWS AND
THEY WERE PUTTING THEM ON A
TEMPLATE. SO THAT THEY COULD
PUT THEM IN A BAG. THAT HAD THE
RIGHT CORRECT AMOUNT AND TYPES
OF SCREWS. THAT LOCAL HARDWARE
STORES. WOULD HAVE ON THEIR
SHELVES. ALL I CAN TELL YOU IS
THE JOY. OF HAVING ONE OF THOSE
SWEET DOWN CHILDREN. HOLD IT UP
TO ME. AND SAY LOOK WHAT I DID.
LOOK WHAT I DID. SO I
UNDERSTAND IN THE PERFECT WORLD.
THAT THERE COULD BE A LOT MORE
MONEY. GOING TO THAT TO THAT
JOB. BUT AS WE HAVE HEARD. FROM
THOSE WHO CARE FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS. FROM OUR.
DISTRICTS IN FROM OUR CITIES.
BE CAREFUL HERE. I CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS BUT I WOULD. JOIN
IN THE CALL. THAT IS THIS IS
SOMETHING WE WANT. TO HELP THE
PROVIDERS AND HELP THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. LET'S NOT RISK
TAKING THE JOB RIGHT AWAY.
LET'S FIND WAYS. OF SUBSIDIZING
AND PUTTING MORE IN THEIR
PAYCHECKS. AND SO THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE IS
ELIMINATED AND THEIR JOY OF
WORK REMAINS. THERE IS
PATTERSON MS VALDERS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS- UNFORTUNATELY
I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. THE NET COMMUNITY
CURRENTLY HAS AN 85%
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AND I FEEL
THAT THIS BILL IS GOING TO
FURTHER THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE MANY OF
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN AN ADVOCATE
FOR THE SPECIAL NEEDS NINETY
COMMUNITY FOR WELL OVER A
DECADE. AND IF ANYTHING THAT I
LEARNED IN MY NONPROFIT
EXPERIENCE IS HOW MANY OTHER
NONPROFITS OR STAB WISH JUST TO
SERVE THE ADD COMMUNITY I HAVE
MET PARENTS THAT HAVE STARTED
VINEYARDS NOT TO MAKE MONEY.
BUT TO CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THEIR CHILDREN FOR A PLACE
FOR THEIR CHILDREN AT THE END
INDIVIDUAL FAMILY MEMBER WITH A
DISABILITY TO WORK NONPROFITS
OTHER COFFEE SHOPS NONPROFITS
THAT ARE BAKERIES. THAT THEY'RE
NOT DOING THIS FOR PROFIT THEIR
BUSINESSES THAT GIVE GOD
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
AN OPPORTUNITY BEYOND SCHOOL TO
MEET WITH PEERS WORK WITH PEERS
AND MAZING OPPORTUNITIES AND I
FEEL LIKE SINCE THERE IS NO
EXEMPTION THIS BILL FOR
NONPROFITS WE'RE NOT ONLY GONNA
KILL JOBS BERNECK WE'RE GONNA
KILL MORALE WITHIN THE IDT
COMMUNITY- AND. AND I STRONGLY
URGE A NO VOTE THANK YOU. MR
LEE YOUR ATTACKS. THANK YOU
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT I JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY
SPEAK ABOUT HOW POOR AND I
THINK THIS BILL IS THIS BILL
ALREADY HAS AN IMPLEMENTATION.
TODAY WHICH IS PLENTY OF TIME
AS WE'VE SEEN HOW MUCH THE
WORLD CAN CHANGE N A COUPLE
YEARS ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
THE STATES THAT HAVE ALREADY
MADE THIS CHANGE IN THIS
PROGRESS THAT WE WILL BE
JOINING OUR STATES LIKE A
HANDFUL OF STATES LIKE
WASHINGTON OREGON TEXAS VERMONT
AND ALASKA THAT IS THE LEAGUE
OF STATES WE ARE CATCHING UP
TO. I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT
SOMETHING REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
I HEAR A LOT OF PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT AND COMMON ALI WITH A LOT
OF BILLS WE TALK ABOUT TODAY IS
THAT AS A BORN IT IS FOR THE
JOIN THE PURPOSE THAT A WORKER
FINDS INFO AT THE WORK. A WAGE.
IS NOT ABOUT HOW THE WAGE TO
WORKERS NOT ABOUT HOW MUCH THEY
VALUED EMPLOYER. IT'S ABOUT HOW
MUCH OF THAT VETERAN PLAYER
VALUES THAT WORKERS. AND IF WE
VALUE ALL WORKERS NO MATTER HOW
THEY WERE BORN. WHATEVER THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE WE SHOULD BE
TREATING THEM WITH EQUAL
RESPECT AND THAT IS HOW. WILL
HAVE THE EQUALITY THAT EXISTS
IN THE SOCIETY TO TREAT THEM
WITH THE FAIRNESS DESERVE. AND
ALL WORKERS OF THE RIGHTS THAT
THEY OUGHT TO HAVE- DRIVER
THANK YOU. MEMBERS IF YOU'D
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE BAY
RAISE YOUR MICROPHONES RIGHT
NOW. HE'S. MISTER BRIAN YOU
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I WILL
KEEP IT BRIEF. AS A CO AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL. SOME YOU MAY KNOW
THIS THAT I GREW UP BY A FAMILY
THAT. THE FOSTER CARE FOR
TWENTY SIX YEARS. THANK YOU
TOOK ON THE HARDEST CASES.
SPECIAL NEEDS CASES ESPECIALLY
MY LITTLE BROTHER HAS TROUBLE
POLICY MODEL BROTHER HAS AUTISM
AND I KNOW THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN
TOUCHED BY THIS MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS. FOR ME THIS BILL A SIMPLE.
WE DON'T PAY PEOPLE SOLELY
BASED ON THE PRODUCTIVITY
OTHERWISE I'D BE A LOT OF WOMEN
MAKING A LOT MORE MONEY. WE
DON'T PAY WHITE FOLKS MORE THAN
WE PAY PEOPLE OF COLOR JUST
BECAUSE WE DON'T PAY. PEOPLE
WHO COME FROM CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES LET ME PAY FROM
OTHERS I HEARD. TOM OF MY ONE
OF MY COLLEAGUES THAT IF YOU
PUT SOMEONE WHO'S ESS ABLE.
WITH SOMEBODY WHO'S TYPICAL I
BELIEVE WITH THE WORD THANK
WHICH TO THIS PERSON I WOULD
ARGUE TO PUT A BLACK EMPLOYEENEXT TO A WHITE POTENTIAL
EMPLOYEE. YOU GET A SOMEWHAT
OFTEN WE DON'T ALLOW FOR THAT
DISCRIMINATION. WE DON'T ALLOW
FOR THEM WE SHOULD ALLOW FORD
IN WAGES EITHER WE DON'T TREAT
PEOPLE DIFFERENT BECAUSE THEY
ARE LESS ABLE. WE DON'T PAY
THEM DIFFERENT AND IF IMPLORES
GONNA CHOOSE PROFIT. OVER
PEOPLE THEN THAT'S MORE WORK
FOR US TO DO. AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED FROM THE
BANK WE GOT FOUR YEARS TO ROLL
THIS OUT IMPLEMENTATION AND WE
CAN WE SHOULD GET THIS RIGHT.
BECAUSE TWELVE THOUSAND PEOPLE
WORKING RIGHT NOW TO BE ALLOWED
TO BE WORKING AND THERE ARE A
LOT MORE THAN TWELVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE BY THE WAY FOR LESS ABLE
TO CALIFORNIA. WHO NEED JOBS
THERE'S WORK FOR US TO DO. BUT
I STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
BECAUSE WE DON'T PAY PEOPLE
LESS. BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT
THEY ARE LESS ABLE WE DON'T
NOTICE THE MONEY'S WORTH. BASED
ON THE ECONOMIC PRODUCTIVITY.
THERE IS BRYANT SEEN DISCUSSION
OR TO. REMAINING MS GONZALEZ
YOU MAY CLOSE I WANT TO FIRST
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS AN
EMOTIONAL TOPIC. AND IT'S A
TOPIC IN A AREA THAT I'VE
WORKED ON FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
ON BEHALF OF THE DISABLED
COMMUNITY. SO OFTEN OUR
APPROACH TO THE SUBJECT MAY
TURN ON. THOSE WORKERS WHO
WE'VE HAD CONTACT WITH. SO THE
LEVEL OF FUNCTIONING FOR SOME
DISABLED WORKERS. IS HIGHER AND
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT TODAY
AND THEY'RE BEING ABUSED BY THE
SYSTEM AND THEY CONTINUED TO BE
ABUSED BY THE SYSTEM SINCE THE
NINETEEN THIRTIES THAT'S WHEN
THIS WAS ESTABLISHED. AND I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE OTHERS WHO
FEAR. CAPS BECAUSE OF THE
CAPABILITIES OF THE PEOPLE
THERE ADVOCATING FOR THAT
THEY'LL GO WITHOUT. BUT I HEARD
SOME THINGS ON THIS FLOOR THAT
LEAVE ME A LITTLE DISTURBED AS
WELL. THESE ARE CHILDREN THESE
ARE ADULTS. THESE ARE OFTEN
FUNCTIONING ADULTS WITH THEIR
OWN APARTMENTS WITH THEIR OWN
LIVELIHOOD. AND WE HAVE GROUPED
THEM ALL TOGETHER AND ALLOW
EMPLOYERS TO PAY LESS THAN THE
MINIMUM WAGE AND I WANT TO
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A MINUTE
BECAUSE WE'VE ALL HEARD THE
STORIES RIGHT NOW TO DATE
TODAY. THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYERS
WHO CANNOT FIND WORKERS TO FILL
THEIR MINIMUM WAGE JOBS. AND
YET WE'RE SANE- BUT IT'S
COMPETITIVE AND THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO PICK SOMEBODY WITH
DISABILITIES. SOME PEOPLE AND
CONGRESS WILL SAY THAT'S WHY WE
NEED TO BE BRING MORE PEOPLE
OVER IN A VISA RIGHT BECAUSE WE
CAN'T FILL OUR MINIMUM WAGE JOB
SO WE'RE GONNA BE WE'RE GONNA
BRING PEOPLE FROM A COUNTRY
WHERE THAT SEEMS LIKE A BETTER
WAGE. WHEN WE HAVE WORKERS
DOING THE WORK HERE TODAY WHO
AREN'T BEING PAID A MINIMUM
WAGE. SOMETHING IS WRONG WITH
THE WAY WE'RE VIEWING. ADULT
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK WITH
DISABILITIES. I UNDERSTAND WE
NEED MORE PROGRAMS I UNDERSTAND
THAT EVERY INDIVIDUAL NEEDS TO
FEEL FULFILLED BY WHATEVER IT
IS THEY'RE DOING IN THAT DAY.
WHETHER THEY'RE WORKING FOR A
PAYCHECK WHETHER THEY'RE DOING
VOLUNTEER WORK WHETHER THEY'RE
DOING ACTIVITIES AND WE NEED TO
INVEST IN THOSE PROGRAMS SO
THAT EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA
HAS. A FIELD DAY. WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS WORK IN THE
DIGNITY OF WORK. AND THE
DIGNITY OF SHOWING UP EVERY DAY
AND DOING A JOB THAT HAS TO BE
DONE BY SOMEBODY. IN EXPECTING
THAT EMPLOYERS PAY THE VERY
LEAST. A MINIMUM WAGE. IT IS
NOT NINETEEN THIRTY ANY MORE.
IT IS TIME WE STEPPED UP TO
THOSE PROGRESSIVE STATES LIKE
TEXAS AND ALASKA AND START
PAYING PEOPLE FOR THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE DOING. THIS IS NOT A
PARTISAN ISSUE GETTING RID OF
THE SUB MINIMUM WAGE IS BOTH IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY PLATFORMS IT
IS SOMETHING WE HAVE BEEN
LOOKING OUT FOR YEARS SOMETHING
WE'VE ALL SAID IS IMPORTANT. IT
IS SOMETHING THAT HAS ALWAYS
BEEN IN CONFLICT WITH THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT.
I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE AND WE HAVE ADVOCATES
ON THE FOR THAT WILL CONTINUE
TO PUSH FOR MORE PROGRAMS FOR
BETTER PROGRAMS FOR OUR ENTIRE
IT COMMUNITY. BUT THERE THIS
BILL WAS SPONSORED BY. AND
ADVOCATED FOR BY PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WHO ARE IN SUB
MINIMUM WAGE JOBS. THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING HURT BY
THE FOURTEEN C. EXEMPTION AND
FEDERAL LAW THAT'S WHAT THEY
THEY APPLY UNDER. AND IT'S TIME
WE LIFT EVERYBODY UP AND THEN
FIGURE OUT WHO ELSE WE HAVE TO-
AT YOU KNOW ACCOMMODATE CREATE
PROGRAMS FOR SPEND MORE MONEY
ON I'M FOR THAT. BUT LEAVING
PEOPLE IN A SUB MINIMUM WAGE
JOB WITHOUT THE DIGNITY KNOWING
AND THEY KNOW THIS IS NOT
PEOPLE WHO DON'T UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY'RE NOT GETTING PAID A
MINIMUM WAGE THEY KNOW THAT CAN
YOU IMAGINE CAN YOU IMAGINE
GOING TO WORK EVERY SINGLE DAY
IN YOUR DOING THE JOB SOMEBODY
PUT IN FRONT OF YOU YOU KNOW
YOU'RE DOING IT AND YOU KNOW
YOU'RE NOT GETTING PAID. WHAT
THE LAW SAYS YOU PAID ABLE
PEOPLE TO DO. THINK ABOUT THAT
DIGNITY. THINK ABOUT WHAT THAT
DOES TO THE PSYCHE OF AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO UNDERSTANDS THAT
AND THEY DO. THESE ARE NOT
CHILDREN. THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE DIFFERENTLY ABLED. AND I
THINK THEY DESERVE A MINIMUM
WAGE. I THINK IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE SHOULD EVEN BE HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION. I IMPLORE
YOU FINALLY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
STEP UP AND JOIN THOSE STATES
WHO'VE ALREADY DONE WHAT IS
NECESSARY AND PHASE IN BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS PLENTY OF
TIME TO PHASE IN A MINIMUM WAGE
AND CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
OF US ON THE FLOOR TO ENSURE.
THAT WE'RE PROVIDING ACTIVITIES
AND RESOURCES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NIVEAU. CORPORAL SAID ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
HOWEVER IS FIGHTERS AT ABOUT.
THIS CONSULTS WITH THE CALL.
THERE IS A PREPARE TO LIVE THE
CALL ON. MS AGUIAR-CURRY. FILE
ITEM NINETY TWO SENATE BILL FOR.
CORPORAL POST. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
SHOULD WISH TO VOTE. THIS TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR. WELL CLOSER ALL
TIED ABOUT ICE FIFTY FIVE NO
SEAT ON THE URGENCY HIGHS FIFTY
FIVE KNOWS A ON THE MEASURE THE
BILL PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE.
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE OUT. FILE
ITEM ONE A. ONE FILE ITEM ONE
ON ONE. THIS IS SENATE BILL.
EIGHTY ONE. SAID ABILITY WORKER
PROGRAM. SENATE BILL EIGHTY ONE
BY CENTER SKINNER AND OTHERS
FACULTY TO SYNCING IS BACK QUE
HAN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE TO PRESENT SB EIGHTY ONE
BY SENATOR SKINNER. THIS BILL
PROVIDES GUIDANCE TO JUDGES ON
SENDS ENHANCEMENTS CALIFORNIA'S
PENAL CODE HAS OVER ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY CENTS ENHANCEMENTS THE
CAN BE ADDED TO A CRIMINAL
CHARGE. ENHANCEMENTS TO BE
CLEAR NOT ELEMENTS FOR CRIME
BUT THEY'RE ADDITIONAL
CIRCUMSTANCES THE WEBSITE CAN
INCREASE THE SENTENCE LENGTH
FOR AN UNDERLYING CRIME. SO LET
ME BE CLEAR MEMBERS WHEN
SOMEBODY GETS ENHANCEMENT
STACKED ONE ON TOP OF THE OTHER
THEY'RE SERVING MORE THAN THE
BASE TIME THAT THEY SHOULD BE.
I'M SERVING THE SENTENCE AND
THE CRIME THEY COMMITTED. NOW I
WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED WITH SB EIGHTY ONE
BECAUSE I KNOW MANY OF YOU HAD
RESERVATIONS SENATOR SKINNER
HAS WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION
REGARDING THEIR CONCERNS.
AMENDING THE BILL TO ELIMINATE
THE PRESUMPTION THAT THESE
ENHANCEMENTS SHOULD BE
ELIMINATED. THE BILL NOW
PROVIDES GUIDANCE TO THE COURTS
AND- LEAVE IT IN THE DISCRETION
OF THE JUDGE WHETHER OR NOT TO
REMOVE THE ENHANCEMENTS. THE
COURT IS TO LOOK AT THINGS LIKE
UNDERLYING TRAUMA. MENTAL
ILLNESS. WHAT WE HOPE THE COURT
DOES LOOK AT WHEN DECIDING WHAT
THE APPROPRIATE SENTENCE IS.
AND THOSE ARE GIVEN GREAT
WEIGHT I ALSO WANT TO BE VERY
VERY CLEAR. THAT THE COURT CAN
AND DOES UNDER THIS BILL LOOK
AT. WHETHER THE DISMISSAL OF
THE ENHANCEMENT WOULD ENDANGER
PUBLIC SAFETY. AND IF IT
DOESN'T ENTER PUBLIC SAFETY
THEN THE COURT IS ENTITLED TO.
AN TO WELL UNDER THIS BILL. PUT
THE ENHANCEMENTS ON TO THE
CRIME. SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES
MEMBERS IT ASKS A JUDGE TO LOOK
AND SAY DOES THIS PERSON
DESERVE THESE ENHANCEMENTS.
THESE MANY MORE YEARS ON THEIR
SENTENCE THIS DENIAL OF
FREEDOM. AND IF THE ANSWER IS
YES THE JUDGE MAY GIVE THEM BUT
IF. IT WOULD BE RACIALLY
UNJUST. IF THE PERSON SUFFERS
FROM MENTAL ILLNESS THEN THE
COURT IN ITS OWN DISCRETION CAN
REMOVE THOSE ENHANCEMENTS. WITH
THAT THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
ASSOCIATION HAS REMOVED ITS
OPPOSITION AND IS NEUTRAL ON
THE BILL. I WANT TO REPEAT THAT
SB EIGHTY ONE DOES NOT
ELIMINATE ANY ENHANCEMENTS AND
IT DOES NOT LIMIT JUDICIAL
DISCRETION. IT PROVIDES
GUIDANCE TO JUDGES TO HELP
INSURE PENALTIES CLOSELY
REFLECT THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF
THE CRIME. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER.
DAVIS BURKE A HAND. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION FOR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM. PURPLE OF THE ROLE.
ESERVER ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
YEAH.
WELL CLOSER ALL.
TYLER HIGHS FORTY THREE DOES
TWENTY THREE. THE MEASURE
PASSES.
WE HAVE ONE REMAINING
ITEM ON CALL.
MEMBERS WE CAN
ENTERTAIN VOTE CHANGES AT THIS
TIME. PREMIER DEATHS. THE
CHANGES. MISTER RODRIGUEZ. YES
VOTE CHANGE AB THREE THREE
THREE FROM NOT VOTING TO KNOW.
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THIRTY THREE NOT VOTING TO KNOW.
THIS RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. R. S. SB FORTY SEVEN
FROM I TO NOT VOTING. BURKE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
SENATE BILL FORTY SEVEN I TO
NOT VOTING. MISTER BENNETT. YOU.
CAN YOU GIVE ME ONE MOMENT.
MISTER BENNETT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. SB FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT FROM I DO NOT VOTING.
BURKE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT SENATE BILL FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT I TO NOT VOTING.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A REMAINING
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY. MR
GALLAGHER. MR GALLAGHER I'D
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE YOU FOR YOUR
GERMAN ABOUT REMEMBERS. ASAGI
YOU GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO MR GALLAGHER FOR
HIS A GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF A GENDER SAYING CHILL AND-
WHO PASSED AWAY ON JULY
NINETEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SURROUNDED BY HIS FAMILY.
RAJENDER WAS BORN ON OCTOBER
ELEVENTH NINETEEN FORTY NINE IN
PUNE JOB INDIA. TO DARSHAN
ANGER BOTCHAN CHILDREN.
VIRGINIA MOVED TO CANADA IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO AND THEN
TO THE UNITED STATES IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE. WHERE
HE LIVED THE AMERICAN DREAM. IT
WAS THERE THAT HE MET THE LOVE
OF HIS LIFE. PAM AND JUST
RECENTLY THEY CELEBRATED THEIR
FORTY EIGHTH ANNIVERSARY
TOGETHER. WE'RE GOING TO WORK
AS A FARM WORKER IN A NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE HE PURCHASED HIS
FIRST PEACH ORCHARD. TOGETHER
REGION- AND PAM GREW THEIR
BUSINESS INTO A DIVERSIFIED
FARMING OPERATION OF ALMONDS
PEACHES PRUNES AND WALNUTS. HE
WAS A FAMILY MAN. PLANTAGO THEY
WELCOMED THREE CHILDREN
JITENDER KNOWN AS GEORGE. L.
GENDER AND INTERPOL. THEY
CONTINUE TO GROW THEIR BUSINESS
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX THEY
WERE ACTUALLY AWARDED THEIR
VERY FIRST OVERSEE YOUR
MEMORIAL QUALITY AWARD GIVEN TO
A FARMER IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
HE WAS ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR THE PEACH
ASSOCIATION FOR THIRTY TWO
YEARS. STEPPING DOWN ONLY DUE
TO HIS ILLNESS THIS YEAR. HIS
WILLINGNESS TO HELP THE
COMMUNITY AND FELLOW GROWERS
REACH FAR AND WIDE. OUTSIDE THE
FARM GATE AS HE WAS ALWAYS
LOOKING AT THE BIG PICTURE. TO
HELP THE COMMUNITY. AND THE
ASSOCIATION. HE WAS A BOARD
MEMBER OF HIS LOCAL TEMPLE.
INTERROBANG IN A ALSO SERVED ON
THE FSA AND NRCS BOARDS AND THE
GARDEN HIGHWAY WATER DISTRICT.
HIS PASSION FOR BUSINESS
COVERED NOT ONLY OUR CULTURE
BUT ALSO REAL ESTATE PACKING
AND HAULING VENTURES. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE HE WAS MADE A
GRANDFATHER FOR HIS FIRST TIME
AND HE LOVED HIS GRANDSON
BISSCHEN AS LOVE A FAMILY WAS
ANALYST BEYOND WORDS. HE WAS A
MAN OF FEW WORDS HE CHOSE HIS
WORDS WISELY. IF SOMEONE NEEDED
HELP HE WAS ALWAYS THERE FOR
THEM NEVER EXPECTED ANY KIND OF
RECOGNITION IN RETURN HE NEVER
MET A STRANGER. HE TREATED
EVERYONE AS A FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. AND I CAN RECALL MANY
TIMES MEAN HIM AT HIS FAVORITE
PLACESTAR OF INDIA RESTAURANT
IN YUBA CITY TO JOIN HIM FOR T.
YEAH TO TALK ABOUT THE ISSUES
OF OUR COMMUNITY. EVERYONE KNEW
HIM AS THE MAN WITH THE
BEAUTIFUL GREEN EYES. AND HE
DID HAVE THESE PIERCING. GREEN
EYES. AND HE WOULD ALWAYS
ENCOURAGE YOU TO. NOT THAT THE
HIGHEST COMMON DENOMINATOR TO
DO WHAT'S BEST. FOR YOUR
COMMUNITY HE WAS HONEST HARD
WORKING AND A PILLAR OF OUR
COMMUNITY. SO MEMBERS I ASKED
THAT WE- CLOSE THE MEMORY OF AN
IMMIGRANT WHO CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY. AND LIVE THE AMERICAN
DREAM. I ASKED WE CLOSE THE
NAME OF RAJINDER CHAUHAN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS GALLAGHER.
YES.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ANYMORE
VOTE CHANGES. MS PH NORTH. THE
CHANGE SB FIVE SIXTY SEVEN
PETRIE-NORRIS I DO NOT VOTING.
YOUR PIZZA IS PIZZA CHANGE
PETRIE-NORRIS SB FIVE SIXTY
SEVEN I TO NOT VOTING. CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
SENATE BILL FIVE SIXTY SEVEN I
TO NOT VOTE. ANYMORE VOTE
CHANGES MEMBERS. A SPORTS
SCORES. YEAH CHANCE ONE THANK
YOU. THAT'S REALLY ALL THE
MATTERS.
MISS CLARK SILVA YOUR
VOTE CHANGE YEAH VOTE CHANGE SB
EIGHTY ONE ALL RIGHT TO NOT
VOTE NOT VOTING. CHANGE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA
SENATE BILL EIGHTY ONE I TO NOT
VOTING.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO
LIVE THE CALL. ON FILE AT A ONE
THIRTY ONE SENATE BILL SIX
THIRTY NINE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS FOLKS WHO WISH TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL. CLOSER
ROLE. TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS
FORTY TWO KNOWS TWELVE THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS. THURSDAY
SEPTEMBER NINTH FLOOR SESSION
AS OF TEN AM FRIDAY SEPTEMBER
TENTH. FLOOR SESSION IS AT TEN
AM. ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WILL BE PASS AND RETAIN OUR
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING OR FOR THE
BUSINESS I AM READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
DR WOULD MOOSE MR FONG SECOND.
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
SEPTEMBER NINTH AT TEN AM IN
THE QUORUM CALLS LIFTED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE SB SIX SIX
FIVE ON BURKE I TO NOT VOTING.
VERY CHANGE LEASE SENATE BILL
SIX SIXTY FIVE I DO NOT VOTING.